Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie geht's dem Wahl?
Da musst du Caroline Wahl fragen.
Sie ist das Weiße. Seit der 22. Wahl ist der Bahnen endlich geschwommen.
Wir wollen es hoffen, aber da hast du natürlich schon alle Verbindungen hergestellt. Ich finde den einzigen angemessenen Beitrag zu diesem ganzen Wahltheater.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen wie bei den Köchen, ein paar Spitzenköche, globales Einzugsgebiet des Publikums und bei dem Rest ist so nur Systemkastronomie. Genau, wenn nicht Essenslieferanten, also die billigsten Arbeitskräfte, die es einfach nach Hause bringen. So, also hier ist einiges in Bewegung und dieses Rechtssystem ist ja super interessant, denn wir haben es ja, uns ist es ja kürzlich unter verschiedenen Gesichtspunkten begegnet, zum Beispiel bei Peter Sloterdijk, der noch mal an Niklas Luhmann erinnerte, der das Rechtssystem immer als Immunsystem der Gesellschaft bezeichnete, weil dort Sachen verhandelt werden, die am Ende wie so eine Krankheit auf die ganze Gesellschaft wieder normativ zurückwirken können, statt einfach nur kognitive Lernerfolge. Das heißt, beim Recht gibt es kein Entrinnen. Wir benutzen das also auch so ein bisschen als den, wie heißt dieser, kanarische Vogel, der Canarian auf Englisch, also der schon mal das giftige Gas aus der Grube, die danach die ganze Gesellschaft vergiftet, sozusagen, der als Erster stirbt. So, es gab im Bundestag Verhandlungen zu einem neuen Gesetz, zu dem die Bundesregierung verpflichtet ist, eigentlich am 7. Mai ein fertiges Gesetz vorzulegen. Wir sind aber gerade mal bei der ersten Lesung. Es geht um SLAPP.
Ja.
Wolfgang, weißt du wahrscheinlich, was SLAPP ist? Wenn noch die Abkürzung?
Die Abkürzung ist mir jetzt nicht präsent, also dass ich die aufdröseln kann. Aber SLAPP ist, wenn man versucht, durch Abmahnungen beispielsweise oder andere Rechtschreiben Leute einzuschüchtern. Das heißt, dass sie gar nicht erst anfangen, weiter noch zu forschen. Es geht zum Beispiel so, dass man Journalisten immer mehr darüber klagen hört, dass sie, wenn sie zu einem Konzern eine Recherche anstellen, weil es da irgendwelche Ungenauigkeiten oder so gibt, dass sie dann schon gleich zugemüllt werden mit Anwaltspost, in der dann steht, und das und das und das und das dürfen sie nicht und bitte unterschreiben sie diese einstweilige Verfügung, wodurch Einschüchterung stattfindet und wer dann nicht Kapital im Rücken hat, also zum Beispiel ein großes Zeitungshaus, wo auch eine Rechtsabteilung da ist, die sagt alles Quatsch, Antworten wir gar nicht drauf, weitermachen, dann bedeutet das eben, dass Leute gar nicht erst dazu übergehen, das zu publizieren oder weiter zu recherchieren. Das betrifft natürlich auch zunehmend Leute, die Blogs machen oder dass auch freie Journalisten vor allem, die dann mal da mal dort schreiben, davon bedroht werden. Aber im Ganzen ist es also eine Möglichkeit für die, die Kapital haben, kritische Berichterstattung zu hintergehen.
Genau. Es ist im Grunde ein Missbrauch des Zivilrechts.
Ja.
Weil das bringt da so Probleme mit wie Kostennoten oder sowas.
Weil die meisten Leute, wenn sie nicht jetzt sehr reich selbst sind und eine Rechtsabteilung haben, einen Anweis schreiben bekommen, oh Gott, dann lasse ich es lieber mal sein.
Genau.
Oder probiere es erst gar nicht.
Kennt man ansonsten nur von der Gesundheitsversorgung in Amerika, dass Leute auf zehn Jahre Urlaub verzichten müssen, um einmal eine Darmspielung zu machen. So ist das hier auch ungefähr. Brief im Postkasten direkt die Frage, will ich jetzt um 70.000 Euro streiten oder was? Also sofort so Jahresgehälter im Flug. SLAPP heißt Strategic Lawsuit Against Public Participation. Es ist also genau dieser Missbrauch, der da stattfinde. Denn wir brauchen ja das Recht. Also wir brauchen dieses Immunsystem. Aber andere Lektüre, Julia Enners, sie hat ja auch gesagt, das muss immer ausbalanciert sein. Ansonsten hat man es mit Autoimmunerkrankungen zu tun. Dann kämpft das Immunsystem gegen den Körper selbst. Und das ist nicht gut. Was bedeutet für eine, wir brauchen eine Balance, ist es gar nicht gut, wenn KI da jetzt so hart reinhämmert und einfach alles auf den Kopf stellt. Das ist wie, als schon mal das Internet kam und es dann plötzlich hieß, ja, also sie haben jetzt gerade drei Sekunden von einem Hollywood-Video hochgeladen. Es ist, als hätten sie selber einen Kino betrieben. 20.000 Euro bitte. So, ja, also das schlägt mal schnell über die Strecke. Wir hören, wie die erste Lesung im Bundestag eröffnet wurde von Bodo Ramelow.
Erste Beratung des von der Bundesregierung eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Umsetzung der Richtlinie EU 2024-1069 über den Schutz von Personen, die sich öffentlich beteiligen vor offensichtlich unbegründeten Klagen oder missbräuchlichen Gerichtsverfahren. Sowie Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel Einschüchterungsklagen stoppen, Demokratie und Pressefreiheit schützen.
Ja, damit sind wir jetzt also. Thema SLAPP ist eröffnet. Ich kurz darauf hinweisen, mich hat jemand kontaktiert. Philipp von der noslap.de Initiative. Der hatte mich letztes Jahr schon mal zu einer Veranstaltung eingeladen, wo ich Gott sei Dank sagen konnte, ich bin überhaupt nicht sprechfähig. Ich weiß, das ist ein wichtiges Thema, aber ich bin davon gar nicht betroffen. Für den Fall, dass ihr mich als Journalist eingeladen habt, der da irgendwie und so. Deswegen war ich da nicht da, aber er hatte mich jetzt noch mal kontaktiert, um mich darauf hinzuweisen, dass diese Initiative der EU von 2024 jetzt im Bundestag so langsam gemacht werden muss, denn es ist eine Richtlinie, die jetzt in ein nationales Gesetz gemacht werden muss. Und unsere Justizministerin Frau Hubech eröffnet hier mal inhaltlich.
Es ist in dieser Woche zehn Jahre her, die Journalistin Daphne Caruana Galizia deckte auf, wie einflussreiche Personen auf Malta in Steuerhinterziehung und Geldwäsche verstrickt waren. Ein Jahr später war sie tot, getötet durch eine Autobombe. Galizia ließ sich bis zuletzt nicht einschüchtern. Dabei haben ihre Gegner es mit allen Mitteln versucht, auch mit Klagen. Als sie starb, waren 48 Gerichtsverfahren gegen sie anhängig. Wer sie mundtot machen wollte, versuchte auch, die Justiz dafür zu missbrauchen. Das Schicksal von Galizia veranlasste die EU zur Anti-SLAPP-Initiative.
Ja, also eine Journalistin, die Steuerrückzugsorte aufdeckt, hat natürlich die denkbar schlechtesten Gegner, denn um Milliarden zu schützen, kann man schon mal eine Million investieren. Aber wenn sie eine Million mit ins Spiel werfen muss, ist natürlich aussichtslos. 48 solcher Fälle und am Ende ein Mord. Das Drama könnte natürlich kaum größer sein. Und nun ist es so, das ist halt, wie wir es eben schon beim Thema Recht, immer aus zwei Seiten. Also diese Balance kann man immer aus zwei Seiten betrachten. Und hier haben wir es jetzt in Personalunion. Wir hören uns einen AfD-Abgeordneten Bonhoff in dieser ersten Lesung des Gesetzentwurfs an.
Sehr geehrter Herr Präsident, meine Damen und Herren, liebe Bürger, stellen Sie sich vor, ein Familienvater, der in den sozialen Medien kritisch über eine große Bank postet. Er hat Fakten, er hat Beweise und plötzlich landet eine Klage auf seinem Tisch. Nicht, weil er lügt, nein, weil er es wagt, dem Mächtigen auf die Füße zu treten. Die Bank hetzt ihre Anwälte auf ihn und zerrt ihn vor Gericht. Der Mann verliert nicht nur Geld, sondern Schlaf, Gesundheit, vielleicht sogar seinen Job. Genau das soll das sogenannte SLAPP-Gesetz verhindern. Klingt gut, oder? Aber warten Sie die Geschichte ab, ich erzähle sie Ihnen ganz.
So, also ja, der erste Teil nachvollziehbar, aber klingt nur gut, ist nicht gut, er erzählt die Geschichte ganz, wir hören noch in den zweiten Teil rein.
Es gibt keine Erfahrungen mit SLAPP in der Praxis. Warum dann dieses Gesetz? Schauen Sie sich die Kriterien missbräuchlich, hauptsächlich überlegene Stellung an. Es sind offene Begriffe schwammig wie ein Sumpf. Das schafft Recht und Sicherheit. Schreckt Kläger mit einem echten strittigen Anliegen ab, die vielleicht zurechtklagen. Noch schlimmer aber ist das Kostenthema, Ersatz über die gesetzlichen Gebühren hinaus. Es ist ein Systembruch an der Stelle. Kalkulierbare Kosten werden durch unbestimmte Angemessenheit ersetzt. Die Betroffenen riskieren so Liquidationsprobleme, der Zugang zu Gerichten wird erschwert und das öffnet neue Schlupflöcher. Grundsätzlich gilt, was aus Brüssel kommt, ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Ja, so. Er hat es selber wieder eingefangen. Man muss am Anfang kurz markieren, dass das Problem schon da ist. Man weiß ja nie, wann man als AfD das Thema braucht.
Eben. Da würde mir auch das ein oder andere einfallen.
Wir können ja mal referieren. Wer mit HUBIG gehört, die ist natürlich federführend, Ministerin zuständig, öffnet natürlich die Sitzung, dann der Bonhoff. Die nächsten CDU, die nächsten Kandidaten des Bundestags sind Sassenrath, CDU, Tis, Faisus, Grüne, Valent, Linke, Rinkert, SPD, von Zons, AfD, Preisendanz, CDU, Körner, CDU. Davon haben wir noch nie gehört. Aber das sind wahrscheinlich Leute vom Fach und so. So wünsche ich mir im Grunde grundsätzlich auch Podcastgespräche. Dass die alle auch eine Meinung zur Migration haben, finde ich gut, aber bitte nicht im Podcast. Gut. Also es gab im Bundestag die Sitzung, die erste Lesung zu diesem Gesetz. Aber es gab parallel oder nicht parallel zwei Wochen später, jetzt im April dazu auch eine Ausschussanhörung. Die ist auch interessant, deshalb wird es so ein bisschen gemischt gucken. Hier beginnen wir mit einem BGH-Richter, der als Gutachter, wie das heißt, eine Sachverständige eingeladen wurde. Er ist der allererste, deswegen hören wir auch noch die Anmoderation, die Eröffnung der Sitzung. Das sind typischerweise Ausschusssitzungen. Man darf durchaus schockiert sein bei dem, was man hört, denn so ein bisschen für das Publikum ist das ja eigentlich auch gemacht. Das ist ja nicht nur für Politiker oder nur für Juristen. Wir hören aber mal hier in den Anfang rein.
Wenn Sie sich zu Wort melden oder etwas ausführen, bitte aktivieren Sie Ihr Mikrofon. Das ist auch wichtig für die Übertragung und Aufzeichnung. Wenn Sie mit Ihren Ausführungen am Ende angekommen sind, halten Sie das Mikrofon wieder ab. Vielen Dank, Herr Dr. Allgall.
Danke schön. Sehr geehrter Herr Vorsitzende, sehr geehrte Mitglieder des Ausschusses, vielen Dank für die Einladung und vielen Dank für die Gelegenheit, hier Stellung zu nehmen. Eine Übertragung der Vorgaben der Richtlinie auf Verfahren ohne grenzüberschreitenden Bezug wäre nur sinnvoll, wenn es bei diesen ein entsprechendes Schutzbedürfnis gäbe, diesen durch dieselben Maßnahmen Rechnung getragen werden könnte und dies zuletzt auch angemessen wäre. Jedenfalls nach der aktuellen Erkenntnis- und Diskussionsgrundlage ist das zumindest nicht offensichtlich. Entsprechendes gilt für die Einführung eines Kostenerstattungsanspruchs bei Vor- bzw. außerprozessualen Abmahnungen. Das Meinungsbild dazu ist denkbar uneinheitlich. Eine Ergänzung oder Konkretisierung des § 615 Absatz-
Bist du noch dabei, Wolfgang?
Es kommt mir eigentlich vor, wenn man bei einem Notar ist, dann liest er einem ja genau in diesem Doktor-Sinnvertrag vor.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Notar und ein BGH-Rechter, macht im Bundestag eine Sachverständigen-Aussage. Der Notar kümmert sich um eine Sache, die nur dich angeht. Ja. Er hier.
Und der liest mir das ja auch pro forma vor und weiß dann nur auf was hin womöglicherweise.
Und du kannst auch mitlesen.
Und vollstreckt das. Aber ich soll jetzt quasi nicht zum ersten Mal diesem Text begegnen.
Genau. Wir hören uns hier noch 50 Sekunden weiter. Denn es ist wirklich wichtig, dieser Typ ist als Sachverständiger eingeladen, um am Immunsystem der Gesellschaft rumzudoktern. Und zwar da, wo es in Autoimmunerkrankungen umschlägt. Und uns alle betrifft, die wir in dieser Gesellschaft leben. Dass nämlich morgen einfach im Briefkasten ein Brief stecken kann, der sagt 80.000 Euro, du kommst nicht drum rum, du weißt nicht, wie du drum rum kommst. Aber als BGH-Richter hat man wahrscheinlich so eine andere semantische Gewohnheit oder so.
Absatz 2 ZPU würde im Ergebnis nicht zur Rechtssicherheit beitragen, denn die Vorschrift ist, Richtlinien konform auszulegen und völlig zurecht thematisierte Unschärfen sind bereits in der Richtlinie selbst angelegt. Sie ist gerade in diesem Bereich hochgradig Auslegungs- und Konkretisierungsbedürftig. Aber die erforderlichen Klärungen können nicht durch den nationalen Gesetzgeber, sondern erst durch den EGH erfolgen. Daher bin ich der Auffassung, dass sich die Formulierungen des Gesetzes möglichst eng an der Richtlinie orientieren sollen. Wenn Klärung in Zukunft erfolgen sollte, könnte und müsste das Gesetz angepasst werden. Die Regelung zum Anwendungsbereich im § 615 Absatz 3 Nummer 1 ZPU weicht von der Richtlinie ab und erweitert diesen ganz erheblich. Diese Erweiterung würde, insgesamt betrachtet, nicht zur Vereinfachung und Beschleunigung führen. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Also gibt es offenbar einen Konflikt zwischen dieser Richtlinie, die jetzt von der EU da ist, und Erweiterungen, die vorgenommen wurden, von der Bundesregierung und den Beratenden, sodass er jetzt anmahnt, das könnte schwierig werden. Vor allem wird es lange dauern, das dann durchzusetzen. Deswegen würde er vorschlagen, das sehr rechtlinienkonform und nah an den Formulierungen zu halten, um nicht zu große Spielräume entstehen zu lassen.
Und rechtlinienkonform heißt ja hier, wir behandeln es wie eine Verordnung. Wir übersetzen sie einfach auf Deutsch, schreiben ein Gesetz darüber. Eigentlich ist eine Richtlinie mit Absicht dafür da, dass man sie nochmal in ein nationales Gesetz überträgt, weil es so Eigenheiten gibt, die in 28, 27 Ländern unterschiedlich sind. Jetzt hat er ja ganz kurz so darauf verwiesen, ich referiere schon mal, aber wir entfalten es gleich, grenzüberschreitende Fälle, hat er zum Beispiel gesagt. Die EU-Richtlinie sagt, alle Verbesserungen, die jetzt für beklagte, juristisch angegriffene Menschen da sind, sollen überhaupt erst mal nur gelten, wenn es internationale Fälle sind. Wenn das greift, sind das so ein paar Vorschläge wie Prozesskostendeckeln, die Sache ein bisschen beschleunigen, dass du jetzt nicht acht Jahre am Bein hast und was auch immer. Also so ein paar Sachen. So, wir öffnen aber das Thema nochmal mit jemanden von der No SLAPP Anlaufstelle, die es gibt für Hilfesuchende in diesen Fällen. Wir haben jemanden Flint mit Nachnamen. Da stehen ja immer nur und, also Dr. Flint, hören wir jetzt.
Wir reden hier heute über nicht weniger als die Meinungsfreiheit. Der Staat muss sie gewährleisten und schützen. SLAPPs bewirken jedoch, dass Menschen, die sich im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit geäußert haben, Missstände angesprochen haben, eingeschüchtert werden und dadurch aus dem öffentlichen Diskurs verdrängt werden.
So, da versteht man auch, wie besser es geht, ne?
Ja, aber das ist ja auch wichtig, dass man das in dieser Weise kommuniziert. Jetzt, also gut für den Ausschuss, können die natürlich in anderer Weise nochmal da reden. Und du bist wahrscheinlich einer der wenigen, der das gesehen hat jetzt.
Vielleicht der Einzige.
Also mit diesem Podcast jetzt hier.
Ich sehe da hinten sitzt die grüne Parlamentarierin, die ich eben in der Rundown liste, die im Parlament dazu sprach. Die ist noch vor Ort Zuschauerin, ansonsten.
Jaja, eben. Von daher jetzt wird das richtig publik gemacht mit diesem Podcast hier. Jetzt gibt es richtig Aufrufzahlen. Aber genau darum geht es. Also es ist eigentlich ein Anliegen, die Meinungsfreiheit zu gewährleisten.
Ja, genau. Und es ist ein echtes Problem, wenn hier einfach Fachidioten unter sich bleiben. Weil wir hier unterstellen müssen, dass es Profiteure gibt davon. Also Leute schreiben ja eine Abmahnung nicht zum Spaß, sondern da werden 20.000 Jugendliche abgemahnt, weil sie mal einen Film hochgeladen haben über Kasar oder so. Und wenn 20.000 Leute 20.000 Euro zahlen, kommt da ganz schön viel zusammen, was man in ein Boot vor Mallorca investieren kann. Von diesen Kanzleien. Ist also durchaus ein Problem. Jetzt allerdings ein Feinschmecker-Clip. Ich konnte es selbst nicht ganz glauben. Aber der BGH-Richter von eben ist nicht der einzige vor Ort, sondern es gibt noch einen zweiten, Herrn Sachse. Herr Sachse arbeitet gegenwärtig am OLG Hamburg, am Oberlandesgericht Hamburg. Bei Hamburg klingelt es bei uns schon so ein bisschen. Ist das nicht dieser fliegende Gerichtsstand, vor dem quasi alle Abmahnungen stattfanden? Androhungen, sonst ziehen wir sie vor Gericht. Hamburg, warum Hamburg? Obwohl sie in, was weiß ich, wo wohnen. Naja, weil das halt eine Tat im Internet war. Da gilt der fliegende Gerichtsstand. Auch so eine Neuerung. Plötzlich gibt es Internet, ja. Und die Anwälte wussten alle, wenn wir vor das LG Hamburg gehen. So, jetzt kommt er vom OLG Hamburg. Das ist also nicht die Pressekammer LG Hamburg. Das ist ein anderes Gericht. Aber er zeigt so ein bisschen, er hat Karriere gemacht.
Der Deutsche Richterbund hatte von Beginn an darauf hingewiesen, dass der Richtlinien...
Ah, ich für dich noch. Wir fangen nochmal von vorne an. Neben ihm sitzt Herr Selinger. Ja, der kommt von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Da sitzen ausschließlich Juristen, die sich natürlich nichts anmerken lassen wollen. Der Herr Richter Sachse macht gleich einen Spruch, so mitten im Clip. Du sagst uns dann, wie Herr Selinger als ganz kühler Jurist darauf reagiert.
Der Deutsche Richterbund hatte von Beginn an darauf hingewiesen, dass der Richtlinie keine belastbare Bedarfsanalyse zugrunde legt. SLAPP Klagen sind aus vielen Ländern bekannt. Vor deutschen Gerichten muss man sie aber mit der Lupe suchen. Das weiß ich aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung aus der Pressekammer am Landgericht Hamburg.
Der Herr Sachse, der gerade noch darauf verweist, das weiß ich aus meiner eigenen Arbeit in dieser Pressekammer vom LG Hamburg, dass man diese Fälle mit der Lupe suchen muss.
Ein Problem, das es gar nicht gibt hier in Deutschland. Und genau in diesem Moment, als er das sagt, schreckt der Seelinger auf und guckt an die Decke, verdreht die Augen. Das ist wunderbar.
Im Grunde sitzt man nur da, also dieses ganze Gesetz, diese ganze deutsche Initiative, also dass da jemand von der SLAPP-Initiative, von Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, überhaupt nur wegen LG Hamburg, Pressekammer, Sachse.
Aber wer hat ihn dann eingeladen? Wahrscheinlich dann die Union?
Das nehme ich mal an. Ich weiß nicht genau, wer das ist.
Das wird wohl nicht die Linkspartei gewesen sein.
Nee, also das ist einfach ein Clip für die Ewigkeit hier, dass man nach 20 Jahren Internetstress alle Eltern so, ich habe da einen Brief, irgendwas mit Abmahnung, was hast du denn gemacht mit deinem Computer? Und alle so, keine Ahnung. So, ne? Dass der Typ jetzt da sitzt und sagt, muss man mit der Lupe suchen, gibt es nicht. Also hier wurde noch nie Recht missbraucht. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Nun gut, es kommt ein weiterer Professor Mann. Universität, muss ich hier mal nachgucken. Mann ist Fachanwalt für Urheber und Medienrecht online zugestaltet. Ach so, der ist gar nicht an der Universität, sondern der ist auf eigene Faust. Okay, sehr gut. Der reagiert jedenfalls direkt mal auf den Sachsen.
Sehr geehrter Herr Ausschussvorsitzender, liebe Mitglieder des Senats, vielen Dank für die Möglichkeit, hier Stellung zu nehmen. Ich will das auch in aller Geburt eine Kürze machen, allerdings nicht ohne Einladen darauf hinzuweisen, dass mein Gesamteindruck des jetzt folgenden Entwurfs ist, dass man eine minimalinvasive Umsetzung der Richtlinie versucht hat, die dazu führt, in diesem Abschnitt 3, der hier aufgefüllt wird, ein Paragraphengrab zu schaffen, das in der Praxis weitgehend vorbeigeht.
Das wäre sozusagen diese Umsetzung der Richtlinie, nur internationale Fälle. Dass natürlich irgendwer nutzt den fliegenden Gerichtsstaat Hamburg, um eine Strafe, also ein Gerichtsverfahren anzudrohen und sagt, dann überweisst du einfach 8.000 Euro. Da ist das Gesetz natürlich untauglich. Ein Paragraphengrab, wie er sagt, finde ich sehr gut.
Deshalb sage ich das so überpointiert, weil ich deutlich, insbesondere der Stellungnahme meiner Vorrednerin, widersprechen möchte, dass SLAPP Klagen, das mag auf Klagen zutreffen, aber dass das Phänomen SLAPP an sich in Deutschland keine Rolle spielt. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Allerdings findet das weitestgehend im vorgerichtlichen Bereich statt.
So, das ist ganz wichtig. SLAPP, der Richter sagt einfach, also bei mir im Landgericht Hamburg kamen da nie Fälle an. Und da denkt man sich so, ja, weil da einfach nur in diesem vorgerichtlichen, der Anwalt schreibt hier einen Brief, drinsteht. Ansonsten gehen wir zum LG Hamburg. Gucken Sie gerne mal im Internet nach, wie das dann für Sie aussieht. So, also das ist sozusagen vorgerichtlich angedroht. Das ist das SLAPP-Moment. Und jetzt sagt er völlig zurecht, na ja, wenn das Gesetz nur die vor Gericht landenden Fälle betrachtet und da dort Prozesskostenhilfe zugesteht, dann nützt das natürlich gar nichts.
Man erhält einen Brief mit einer Abmahnung und dann soll man Geld überweisen und das war's. Das Gericht hat erst mal nichts mit zu tun. Da kommt ein Briefkopf, da stehen 17 Anwälte drauf und dann wird man sich überlegen, wie verhalte ich mich dazu. Für die Leute, die dann rechtsschutzversichert sind und all das, bieten sich da vielleicht Wege an. Aber die meisten Leute sind es ja gar nicht und vor allem auch nicht für sowas dann rechtsschutzversichert. Das greift ja dann oft auch gar nicht. Und wer lässt sich dann auf solche Fälle ein?
Genau, also wenn wir jetzt ein Gesetzesvorhaben, das wir hier natürlich nicht im Detail jetzt lesen, wortwörtlich, aber von dem wir einfach sagen können, also wenn das nur internationale Fälle regelt und nur Sachen, die vor Gericht landen, ja dann muss man die Fälle wirklich mit der Lupe suchen. Aber es gibt halt trotzdem hunderttausende, zehntausende von SLAPP-Fällen in Deutschland die ganze Zeit.
Und ich habe ja hier schon mal lauter Clips mitgebracht über Meinungsfreiheit und diese neue Verrechtlichung, die stattfindet, dass ja alle jetzt anfangen zu klagen. Das ging ja damals auch um die Politiker, die plötzlich bei jeder kleinen Beleidigung sofort das Anwalzteam losschicken. Und da konnte man auch schon sehen, dass in diesen ganzen Beefs, die es bei YouTube gibt zwischen irgendwelchen Streamern und so, plötzlich auch immer schon die Drohung mit dem Anwalt zu kommen, so gang und gäbe geworden ist und dass dann auch gleich die Leute, die in den Kommentaren sich so oder so verhalten, auch noch mit abgemahnt werden für irgendetwas. Das scheint sich ja immer weiter auszubreiten und ist ja gerade durch KI, das ist ja auch der Einstieg mal gewesen, jetzt hier in dieses Thema, das Ganze noch zu erleichtern, dass man sagt, so und dann passt das mal auf alle Kommentare und so an und lasst es durchrattern und dann verschicken wir das in großer Masse.
Genau, ich bin jetzt auch Laie, aber dieses SLAPP hier betrifft ja Zivilrecht. Bei diesen speziellen Paragrafen, die Politiker schützen sollen, ist das ja wahrscheinlich, weiß nicht genau, immer schon strafrechtlich relevant oder irgendwie so.
Kann sein.
Also da geht es dann sozusagen um echte Strafen und auch sofortige. Also nicht nur um die Androhung von, sondern da kommt einfach direkt die Staatsanwaltschaft und macht so was.
Beziehungsweise, naja, ich glaube, es wird schon viel mit Abmahnung gearbeitet und dann muss man einfach eine Strafe zahlen.
Genau, also bei diesen Firmen, die Politiker auffordern, zeigt uns nochmal der Falle, damit wir schon mal, da ist es auf jeden Fall noch zivilrechter. Wir hören mal den Mann zu Ende.
Dort allerdings umso massiver. Es ist so, dass umso...
So, also vorgerichtlich und dort aber umso massiver.
Vorgerichtlichen Bereich statt. Dort allerdings umso massiver. Es ist so, dass wir in der Praxis eine Fülle von Abmahnungen auf dem Tisch haben, von zivilgesellschaftlichen Einrichtungen, von NGOs, aber auch teilweise von kleineren Medienunternehmen, mit teilweise sechs, sieben Abmahnungen, die sehr umfangreich sind, mit umfangreichen Gegenstandswerten und entsprechend hohen angehängten Kostennoten. Und es ist in der Praxis meine Erfahrung, und das sieht kein Gericht hier in Deutschland, dass auf solche Abmahnungen hin allein aus Angst vor den angedrohten Kosten und dem Bearbeitungsaufwand, den viele schlichtweg nicht leisten können, wenn sie mit einer solchen umfangreichen Abmahnung konfrontiert sind, sehr schnell und unnötig Unterlassungserklärungen abgegeben werden, die den öffentlichen Diskurs einschränken.
Ja, ich kann mal ein Beispiel nehmen aus dem Bekanntenkreis. Jemand, der eine journalistische Arbeit geschrieben hat als Freier über einen Kongress von einer Unternehmerpersönlichkeit. Das war ein kritischer Bericht, der auch zeigte, wie ideologisch aufgeladen das ist und wie irrsinnig das ist. Und dann konnte man natürlich jetzt diese Kritik an sich nicht angehen. Das ist ja eine Meinungsäußerung. Aber was man natürlich angehen kann, ist, wenn gesagt wird, in Reihe eins sitzen sie alle da mit ihren Slimfit-Jackets und offenen Hemdkragen. Wenn jetzt aber in dieser Reihe, das ist ja eine journalistische Arbeit, wenn in dieser Reihe natürlich jetzt Leute sitzen, die durchaus einen geschlossenen Hemdkragen haben und keinen Slimfit-Anzug anhaben, dann wird das aufgelistet und sagt sie, das ist ja falsche Tatsachenbehauptung. Und da waren dann mehrere solche Dinge, wo dann auch es schwierig wird für den anderen zu sagen, naja, ich prüfe das mal hier nochmal nach. Und dann stehst du da.
Genau.
Und dann brauchst du dann selbst einen selbstfindigen Anwalt und selbst auch Geld und die Gelassenheit zu sagen, ich reagiere mal darauf und zahle nicht gleich irgendwas und nehme da alles raus.
Genau. Und jetzt ist ja so, in den Briefen steht dann drin, ich fühle mich in meiner Ehre verletzt, was auch immer und so. Also werden so die Paragraphen durchgegangen. Und man denkt sich so, das hätte vor keinem Gericht Bestand. Aber alleine das klären zu lassen, ist wirklich sehr, also wie er gesagt hat, kostenaufwendig, zeitaufwendig. Dann lieber sich mit 480 Euro Anwaltskosten für, der hat da zwei Stunden mir den Brief geschrieben gegen mich, zahlt man es halt oder wie auch immer. Also durchaus große, große Probleme. In der Anhörung hören wir noch von Greenpeace eine Stimme, Frau Nölle. Ich hoffe, das stimmt mit Greenpeace. Das muss man ja mal alles selber recherchieren. Also klar, ich habe auf der Bundestagsseite nachgeguckt, aber ich finde, das kann man alles mal in dieses Video. Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass ich habe jetzt verschiedene Fernsehsendungen gesehen, zum Beispiel Fußballspiele. Da bietet der Amazon einfach an und mein Sohn fand das natürlich super, dass so ein Spiel mit 20 Sekunden Zeitverzögerung und es werden dir sofort alle Namen eingeblendet, wie schnell rennt der Spieler.
Wirklich?
Ja, das ist supertoll. Das wünsche ich mir für die Bundestags-Mediathek auch. Ich will einfach grundsätzlich immer gewissen, wer redet da eigentlich so?
Auf wessen Einladungen?
Genau, auf wessen Einladungen, wer redet da, wie ist die Redezeit verteilt, Ballbesitz, den ganzen Kram. Also gut.
Das Phänomen der außergerichtlichen Einschüchterung ist von?
So, außergerichtliche Einschüchterung, das finde ich ein sehr gutes, weil es ist ganz wichtig im Rechtssystem, aber außergerichtlich.
Das ist zentraler Relevanz. Die Praxisdaten der No-SLAPP-Anlaufstelle zeigen, dass es bei über 80 Prozent ihrer Fälle bereits im außergerichtlichen Bereich begonnen hatte mit den SLAPP-Strategien. Wenn wir das jetzt also quasi komplett ausklammern, dann regulieren wir eigentlich nur die Spitze eines Eisberges, wenn man es mal so ein bisschen zugeschwitzt.
Ja, und das finde ich, also das wird uns noch sehr beschäftigen, Spitze des Eisberges. Das Recht findet nicht nur statt, wo Anwälte was machen, sondern überall. Und jetzt haben wir wirklich alle Gesetzesbücher immer parat. Wir können Fälle beschreiben, uns eine juristische Einschätzung geben lassen, wie auch immer. Also es wird uns künftig auch nochmal sehr befassen. Gut, jeder, der sich so von der Anlaufstelle gesprochen hat, kann auch sein, dass sie von SLAPP nochmal war, wie auch immer. Zurück im Bundestag, wo auch nochmal von der, wir haben sie vorhin im Bild sitzen sehen, von der Grünen, Frau Tess Faisus, die richtigen Anmerkungen gemacht werden, sodass wir sie alle verstehen.
Die Bundesregierung ist nun in der Pflicht, diese Rechtslinie mit Mut und Entschlossenheit umzusetzen. Die Botschaft muss ganz klar lauten, das Recht darf nicht als Einschüchterungsinstrument benutzt werden. Der Entwurf der Bundesregierung genügt diesem Anspruch leider nicht. Aus Zeitgründen will ich an zwei Stellen das herausstellen. Zum einen begrenzt sich dieser Entwurf auf grenzüberschreitende SLAPP-Klagen. Reine nationale Fälle fallen nicht darunter.
Wir überhalten mal diese Frage im Hinterkopf. Das wird gleich noch erklärt in der Anhörung, warum das so ist. Also warum die EU mit so einem komischen Konstrukt um die Ecke kommt.
Das bedeutet, nehmen wir ein, ein deutscher Konzern geht gegen einen Journalisten vor, weil er Aktivisten, die gegen den Konzern demonstrieren, dokumentiert, fotografiert hat. Ein reeller Fall. Er überschüttet diesen Journalisten mit horrenden Schadensersatzansprüchen in Höhe von zwei Millionen. Dieser Journalist wird sich nicht auf dieses Gesetz berufen können, weil es kein grenzüberschreitender Fall ist. Und angesichts, dass davon, dass 75 Prozent der SLAPP-Fälle solche rein nationalen Fälle sind, werden sich die Allermeisten nicht auf dieses Gesetz berufen können. Das zweite Problem. SLAPP-Verfahren starten nicht mit einer Klage, sondern mit einer Abmahnung. Forderung zur Unterzeichnung, eine Unterlassungserklärung drohen mit hohen Schadensersatzforderungen und obendrauf die Rechnung der Großanwaltskanzlei. Das Ziel ist die Einschüchterung. Wie würden Sie reagieren? Für die Allermeisten ist das Risiko, sich lebenslang zu verschulden, viel zu groß. Die Allermeisten geben nach und gehen nicht in Gerichtsverfahren.
Ich finde, jetzt, da wir KI haben, sollten auch BGH-Richter, im Grunde alle, immer wieder Thomas Fischer, pointiert, lebensweltlich, wenn auch immer ein bisschen konträr sie selbst oder wie auch immer, um die Bäume wickelnd, schreiben. Aber ich finde, so sollte man darüber reden. Also das Recht ist hier zweitrangig. Dass es missbraucht wird, macht es erstrangig. Aber erstrangig ist, da kümmert sich jemand um die Gesellschaft, deckt irgendwas auf, ein NGO, ein Journalist, was auch immer und so und dann wird halt Recht missbraucht. Stattdessen haben wir vorhin gehört, der BGH-Richter erstmal mit so gesetzes Sprache da anfängt, das ist natürlich nicht gut.
Man manifestiert damit eine Klassenjustiz. Das ist ja voll klar.
Absolut.
Es gibt ja keine andere Beschreibung dafür.
Ja, wir hatten im Salon mal diesen Text, Sozialrecht, wie Leute einfach vorgeführt werden, acht Minuten lang von Richtern, nicht wissen, was da passiert. Und danach noch mal fragen, also bin ich jetzt verurteilt oder was? Ich habe es gar nicht verstanden. Ja, und genauso ist das hier auch. Gut, wir haben also hier eine Bruchlinie jetzt markiert. Wir haben die CDU und ihre Justizsachverständigen, also Sachse, ja, hier steht es durchaus, also von der CDU eingeladen. Dann den OLGHR-Richter, also der Richter, Fuhrmann, BGH, Alga Meyer, also das sind alles CDU-Einladungen. Und dann eben alle Leute, die tatsächlich in der Gesellschaft was machen, von der CDU ja immer nicht behaupten. So, wir haben also wieder ein klares Lager zu diesen Kosten. Das ist wirklich crazy. Wir hören hier jetzt den Selinger von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrecht.
Der Gesetzesentwurf sollte dringend den außergerichtlichen Bereich in Betracht nehmen. Wir haben jetzt schon die Situation, dass wer sich gegen eine unberechtigte Abmahnung zur Wehr setzt, die Kosten nicht erstattet bekommt. Umgekehrt aber, man im Fall der berechtigten Abmahnung die Kosten zu tragen hat. Also wir haben jetzt insofern schon eine gewisse strukturelle Benachteiligung des Äußernen gegenüber demjenigen, der sich in seinen Rechten verletzt sieht.
Ja, dass wir hier ein Problem haben, dass Juris, also das durch ein Gesetz gelöst werden soll und dann hören wir, es wird überhaupt nicht mal adressiert, finde ich wirklich grotesk. Also was er jetzt gerade beschrieben hat ist, du bekommst eine Abmahnung, beauftragst selber einen Anwalt dagegen vorzugehen. Die Gegenseite zieht zurück und du musst deinen Anwalt trotzdem selber bezahlen. Den Kampf hast du dir gar nicht ausgesucht. Anwaltsstunde 190 Euro Minimum, bist du schon immer drei Stunden los, 600 Euro. Und das kriegt man nicht erstattet, weil da sitzt ja neben ihm, ja so vor Gericht suchen wir das mit der Lupe. Und hier ist doch alles klar. Also wenn jemand verliert, bezahlt der andere eben den Anwalt. Ja, also wenn man es drauf ankommen lässt, bis zu einem Richter-Urteil zu kommen, ja. Aber das ist nun mal dieser Vorgerichtlich-Raum, der hier so wichtig ist, der einfach gar nicht betrachtet wird von diesem Gesetz.
Und wir halten fest, die Union konsequent wieder auf der falschen Seite.
Absolut.
Aber offenbar die SPD auch. Also scheint ja dann nicht jetzt entsprechende Deutsche.
SPD wie so häufig, aber da kommen wir nachher noch drauf. Es geht gerade nichts zu erwarten.
Zur Frage von Ihnen, Herr Müller, zur Frage nach der Sinnhaftigkeit einer Regelung des vorgerichtlichen Bereichs nach Empirie und dem, wer eigentlich definiert was missbräuchlich ist, wurde jetzt schon viel gesagt, deswegen beschränke ich mich auf zwei Facetten. Das eine ist die strukturelle Entscheidung, die Herr Dr. Allgäier beschrieben hat. Und die ist die geltenden Prozessrechte, dass derjenige, der abmahnd Aufwendung erstattet bekommt und derjenige, der abgemahnt wird, bekommt keine Aufwendung erstattet. Und das hat für viele Bereiche durchaus eine Berechtigung. Das ist gelübte Praxis. Aber den Bereich, über den wir hier sprechen, es kam auch bislang in der Diskussion relativ kurz. Herr Dr. Sachs hat es in seiner Einleitung kurz gesagt, das ist einer, der uns vielleicht besonders wichtig sein sollte, nämlich derjenige, der Ausübung elementarer Freiheitsgrundrechte, also Meinungsfreiheit, Versammlungsfreiheit, Pressefreiheit, Wissenschaftsfreiheit, die durch missbräuchliche Klagen oder Abmahnung potentiell eingeschränkt werden. Und das ist, würde ich sagen, eine politische Entscheidung, ob man sich jetzt dafür entscheidet, zu sagen, hier sehen wir ein besonderes Schutzbedürfnis und das regeln wir dann auch mit den entsprechenden Konsequenzen. Oder wir sagen, wir tun das nicht. Ich glaube, sozusagen rechtlich ist da das eine oder das andere zwingend geboten.
Ich übersetze mal, was er gerade sagte. Warum sitze ich hier in einem Ausschuss abseits der Öffentlichkeit, wo hinter mir nur ein Gast sitzt aus dem Plenum, der sich den Bauch streichelt, während wir es doch hier mit einer grundsätzlichen, großen politischen Fragestellung zu tun haben? Wie gehen wir um mit den anderen Immunsystemen unserer Gesellschaft? Die sind Journalisten, NGOs, die alle mal so Sensorik haben für, hier liegt was im Argen, wir machen jetzt mal. Und die werden von der autoimmun befallenen, sehr aggressiven Rechtspraxis einfach schachmattgesetzt. Und es gehört eigentlich auf die große Bühne. Klar, Ausschusssitzung gehört dann auch dazu. Aber wo ist die große Bühne dazu? Also wir können jetzt alle mal unseren Parlamentariern schreiben, wir haben gehört, bald steht die zweite Lesung des SLAPPs an. Wie sieht denn ihr Redebeitrag aus? Kündigen sie einen an? Können sie alle mal auffordern. Also das wäre so ein Thema, wo ich sage, da muss ich jetzt jeder Parlamentarier einlesen. Da gilt nicht, was Stefan Schulz gefordert hat, nämlich jeder drei Themen, sondern bei dem Thema SLAPP. Also wie gehen wir mit dem Immunsystem unserer Gesellschaft um, mit dem Rechtssystem, das Aggression gegen sich selber richtet, gegen Journalisten, gegen NGOs und so weiter. Wie kriegen wir das wieder gebändigt?
Und dabei muss man wirklich einmal bereit sein zu begreifen, dass es eine autoritäre Wende auch ohne die AfD geben kann und sie gibt. Weil es immer so getan wird, ja, was machen wir, wenn mal die AfD, nein, wir müssen, was machen wir jetzt gerade? Und dass wir EU-Sanktionen gegen Journalisten vorfinden, dass wir jetzt auf nationaler Ebene sehen, dass man nichts gegen dieses SLAPP-Verfahren tun will, sondern dass man eigentlich sich wegduckt, beziehungsweise, ja, bis vor allem sogar behauptet, das sei ja kein großes Problem, zeigt ja, dass man eigentlich diese Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit, die dadurch stattfindet, nicht nur hin nimmt, sondern offenbar auch gut findet.
Ja, unterlassene Hilfeleistung ist ja Förderung von auto-aggressiven Immunerkrankungen unserer Gesellschaft. Der Seligen hat es ja sehr gut formuliert. Der vorgerichtliche Raum ist der entscheidende. Und damit sind wir in einem politischen Raum, bei dem wir uns grundsätzlich fragen müssen, wie gehen wir damit um? Und wenn der Sachse sagt, also in meiner Rechtspraxis als Richter suche ich das mit der Lupe, ja okay, geschenkt. Jetzt diese offene Fragestellung, warum diese Internationalität in den Fällen? Und jetzt, es wird sehr grotesk, der Prof. Mann, oder der private jetzt nicht an einer Universität und nicht an irgendeiner Institution, sondern der Anwalt, genau, macht mal diese kleine politische Erklärung, wo ich auch denke, das ist schon wieder so.
Für mich stellt sich im Ausgangspunkt die Frage, welchen Grund, welchen sachlichen Grund es überhaupt gibt für die Begrenzung auf grenzüberschreitende Verfahren. Dass das im Richtlinienentwurf steht, hat ausschließlich seinen Grund darin, dass der europäische Gesetzgeber nur insoweit eine Gesetzgebungskompetenz hat. Wenn man das nicht zweckfremd, dieses Argument benutzen will, um das ganze Institut der Verteidigung gegen SLAPP-Klagen abzulegen, gibt es aus meiner Sicht überhaupt keinen sachlichen Grund für den Ausschluss rein innerstaatlicher Sachverhalte.
Aha, das heißt also, man kann das zum Anlass nehmen, diese Richtlinie jetzt die politische Debatte zu führen, aber zu sagen, ne, ne, wir binden uns einfach nur an diese EU-Richtlinie. Das heißt, wir wollen diese Debatte gar nicht führen, sondern machen nur dieses minimale, was aus Brüssel gekommen ist.
Brüssel hat nur eine Zuständigkeit, wenn sie grundsätzlich eine Internationalität formulieren. Das ist also ein Artifakt dieser Rechtshierarchie, Gesetzgebungshierarchie. Und damit kann man das in Deutschland komplett leer laufen lassen, wenn man es so macht, wie die es machen. Vorgerichtliche Rauben sehen wir nicht. Und national ist alles Töfte. Also wirklich, ich finde, das Gesetzgebungsverfahren zum Thema SLAPP selbst ist ein Missbrauch von Recht.
Ja.
Und das Reentry von diesen Problemen. Gut, wir hören noch drei Stimmen. Wir wollen natürlich die Gegenrede jetzt hören. Was sagt die CDU im Bundestag? Wir hören die Abgeordneten Sassenrath, Preisendanz und von Zons. Ah nee, von Zons ist schon AfD, aber wir sind ja im Lager denken. Also Clip Nr.
Man darf, meine Damen und Herren, in diesem Land fast alles sagen und schreiben. Das heißt im Übrigen aber nicht, und ich schaue niemandem an, dass man es auch muss.
Ja, mach mal eine pro-Palästinand-Demo, weil du es nicht so cool findest, dass irgendwelche Schulen im Iran oder so noch oben drauf bombardiert werden. Da kommt aber die Polizei mit so einer handgeschriebenen Liste. Sie haben gerade dieses Wort gesagt, das dürfen sie nicht. Bäm, bist du weg auf der Straße. Aber du darfst alles sagen in Deutschland, weißt du?
Ja, alles, was der CDU gefällt, davon sagen in Deutschland.
Aber wir tun gut daran, gerade in Zeiten, in denen in Europa ein Krieg herrscht, der ganz gezielt unsere Freiheit ins Visier nimmt, festzustellen. Deutschland steht auf Platz 11 im Ranking von Reporter ohne Grenzen. Deutschland erhält 95 von 100 Punkten von Freedom House. Wir sind ein freies Land mit einer freien Presse und wir sind stolz darauf.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie die CDU das sieht, aber wenn man sich im Benchmark setzt, bin ich dafür immer Topposition.
Immer eins.
Ich bin Platz 11 geworden.
Vor allen Dingen, wir wissen ja, welche anderen Länder wir so kennen. Und dann würde ich sagen, dann ist man ja mit 11 doch.
Wir sind viel besser als Ungarn. Wow. Das können die CDU auf ihren Links schreiben.
Es ist unglaublich. Vor allen Dingen, jetzt würde der sonst irgendwo auf dem Podium sitzen und würde dann wahrscheinlich nochmal sagen, ja, diese ganzen Link mit ihrem Kulturkampf, die wollen uns das Wort verbieten. Also das ist ja genau die Redeweise, die sonst von denen kommen. Und jetzt wird aber so getan, als wäre die Pressefreiheit und so, ist alles ganz wunderbar. Und da haben wir ja auch eben im Voraus allen in Gehorsam durch SLAPP oder durch andere Sachen. Also da hat ja Richard David Precht auch wirklich den Punkt, wir haben ja über das Buch im Salon ausführlich diskutiert, dass eben der Preis plötzlich sehr hoch wird, dafür, dass man seine Meinung sagt.
Genau, wir geben der CDU eine zweite Chance, David Preysen dann.
Wir müssen ja im Falle dieser Anti-SLAPP-Klagen auch die andere Seite sehen. Also das Recht jedes Einzelnen, sich vor Gericht zu wehren gegen falsche Tatsachenbehauptungen, Rufschädigungen, Rechtsverletzungen. Oder um es mit weiteren passenden Redewendungen zu sagen, wir dürfen das Kind nicht mit dem Bade ausschütten, das Pendel nicht zu weit in die andere Richtung ausschlagen lassen, nicht mit Kanonen auf Spatzen schießen, die Kirche im Dorf lassen. Sie wissen, worauf ich hinaus will.
Ich glaube, die machen sich lustig über uns.
Das ist für Gesinnungsethiker natürlich furchtbar nervig.
Die Kirche im Dorf lassen, CDU, wie du es schon angesprochen hast. Ich habe es von so vielen Studenten mit alles erzählt bekommen. Ich war ja wieder viel unterwegs in den letzten Monaten. Dann erzählen die ja, wenn die planen, irgendjemanden an die Uni einzuladen, der sich kritisch zu dem Thema nach Ost verhält, dann sind sofort CDU-Abgeordnete, die finden das raus. Dann ist die CDU-Studentenschaft, sorgt dann dafür, dass die keinen Raum bekommen und dann nur einen kleinen Raum und dann doch wieder keinen Raum. Dann muss Sicherheitspersonal engagiert werden. Ich habe ja, und da habe ich nicht über den Ost gesprochen, sondern über Kriegstüchtigkeit. Ich habe ja eine Veranstaltung an einer Universität gemacht, wo zur Auflage gemacht wurde von der Unileitung, dass es zwei Security-Leute gibt, die mussten an den Eingängen stehen und meinen Vortrag bewachen, um zu schützen. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wen sie geschützt haben, mich vor dem Publikum, das Publikum vor mir, das Publikum untereinander, einfach nur, damit man es ein bisschen teurer macht, damit man wieder eine neue Hürde einbaut. Das erleben wir auf dieser Ebene, und das erleben wir natürlich auf der rechtlichen Ebene auch laufend, dass mit diesen Klagen alles kurz und klein gemacht wird. Das sehen wir auch. Wir haben ja das angesprochen bei dem Fall Kolin, wie vorsichtig dann plötzlich alles wird, weil man zugepflastert wird mit irgendwelchen SLAPP-Geschichten.
Ja, genau so. Wir hören auch aus dem Lager AfD von Zons.
Die Linke setzt noch einen drauf. Ihr Antrag liest sich wie ein Bauplan für politisch gelenkte Justiz. Mehr Gebühren, Sonderrechte für NGOs und Verbände und Klagen sollen sogar dann missbräuchlich sein, wenn sie teilweise berechtigt sind.
Die Klagen sollen sogar dann gerechtfertigt sein, wenn sie, äh, die, äh, warte, nochmal, den letzten Teil, der ist sehr amüsant.
Die Linke, O's und Verbände und Klagen sollen sogar dann missbräuchlich sein, wenn sie teilweise berechtigt sind.
Genau.
Also er verweist auf teilweise gerechtfertigte Klagen, die dann trotzdem durch das neue Gesetz, das die Linke plant, ihr habt einen eigenen Antrag gestellt, als missbräuchlich gelten. Das heißt ja, in seinem Denken findet das auf jeden Fall statt.
Ja.
Dass es Klagen gibt, die eigentlich nicht mal teilt, sondern gar nicht gerechtfertigt sind.
Ja, aber auch selbst da nicht. Und die dürfen, und die teilweise sind auch immer noch okay.
Also das ist wirklich...
Es wird gar nicht mehr davon ausgegangen, dass vielleicht noch irgendwas richtig so ist, wenn man so eine Aufgabe hat.
Naja. Zum Kern Ringkart SPD. Wir schließen natürlich nicht mit diesen komischen Leuten hier aus dem falschen Lager, sondern wir hören noch Daniel Ringkart in der SPD.
Sehr geehrter Herr Präsident, liebe Frau Ministerin Hubech, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren. Wir sprechen heute über ein Thema, das auf den ersten Blick technisch klingt. Verfahrensrecht, Kostensicherheit, Beschleunigungsgebot. Aber in Wahrheit geht es um den Kern unserer Demokratie, um Meinungsfreiheit, um Pressefreiheit, um den Mut und die Macht zu kontrollieren. Lassen Sie sich deutlich sagen, worum es geht. SLAPP-Klagen, strategische, offensichtlich unbegründete Klagen sind kein Mittel der Rechtsdurchsetzung. Sie sind ein Instrument der Einschüchterung.
Ja, also Auto-Aggression. Man kann durchaus so im Bundestag reden. Ich befürwöre das sehr. Es gibt ja eine zweite Lesung dann.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist es so wichtig, man müsste es eigentlich noch viel mehr strapazieren, dass man jetzt daraus den Kampf für Meinungsfreiheit macht. Ich sage ja schon die ganze Zeit, das linke Lager lässt das Thema Meinungsfreiheit liegen, weil sie mal irgendwie gehört haben, dass das auch von Leuten vertreten wird, die sie gar nicht so mögen. Jetzt wäre es ja wirklich der Anlass zu fragen, wollt ihr, die ihr immer gerufen habt, die Meinungsfreiheit ist bedroht, wirklich die Meinungsfreiheit verteidigen? Offenbar ja nicht, wie wir hier aus CDU und AfD-Seite ganz deutlich gehört haben. Das müsste man ja jetzt in Anschlag bringen gegen die. Also das heißt, hier muss das Lager sich ja dann positionieren und zeigen. Deswegen müsste eigentlich das, was da besprochen wird, viel mehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt werden, weil das ja die Sachen sind, die man auch sehr gut mal skandalisieren könnte. Und da hörst du dann nämlich auch nichts von Nios zu oder von Springer oder so. Halten die sich dann auch plötzlich zurück?
Das ist nicht der Metier. Wir schließen mit einem Clip von der Nölle aus der Anhörung. Und ich finde nämlich auch, wenn man eine große politische Debatte hätte, wie es der Selinger ja auch angesprochen hat, der vorgerichtliche Raum ist ein politischer Raum, da kann man durchaus mit einer großen Debatte reingehen. Wir haben ja durchaus Markierungen, wie zum Beispiel Gemeinnützigkeit. Die wird ja auch finanziell unterstützt. Da könnte man ja auch überlegen, ob man da nicht ein Rechtsinstitut schafft. Aber wenn man das sagt, na ja, da gucken wir schon mal genauer hin, wenn jetzt irgendwelche Abmahnungen gegen gemeinnützige Organisationen abgefeuert werden.
Im Gegensatz zu großen Medienhäusern, Lobbygruppen oder großen Konzernen können wir jedoch keine wirklichen finanziellen Rücklagen für solche jahrelangen Rechtsstreitigkeiten bilden. Wir können dadurch tatsächlich in den Bankrott geklagt werden, bevor überhaupt ein Urteil gefallen ist. Da fordern wir eine Missbräuchlichkeitsvermutung bei Klagen gegen als gemeinnützig anerkannte Organisationen, sofern diese innerhalb ihres satzungsmäßigen Zwecks handeln. Wenn der Staat einer Organisation bescheinigt, dass ihr Handeln dem Gemeinwohl dient, muss er sie auch konsequent schützen, wenn sie für eben dieses Gemeinwohl angegriffen wird.
So, und da finde ich, das gilt ja mal mindestens für Journalisten. Natürlich die Frage jetzt, wie man sich zertifiziert dafür und so, ja, aber trotzdem kann man ja zumindest eine Debatte darüber führen, wie man da gewisse Schutzräume schafft. Weil eigentlich so richtig schwer durchschaubar ist das ja alles, nicht? Also der Todesfall am Anfang von der DAFN, 48, einige Gerichtsverfahren und jeder, der sich fragt, warum, was hat sie denn gemacht? Naja, sie hat gegen Steuerhinterziehungsreichtum sie vorgegangen. Also das braucht für niemanden eine weitere Erzählung.
Ja, klar, das ist ein sehr eindeutiger Fall, aber definitorisch wird es natürlich schwierig, weil wir nicht alle einen NGO-Status haben. Der kann ja auch wieder aberkannt werden, dann aus anderen Gründen. Wir haben ja auch schon solche Fälle von, wer bekommt Gemeinnützigkeit und wer nicht zugeschrieben in journalistischen Tätigkeiten. Dann die Frage, Journalismus ist ja in dem Sinne kein Ausbildungsberuf, dass man sagt, also nur wer die Ausbildung hat, kann sich Journalist nennen. Von daher sind da natürlich sehr viele Grauzonen. Da weiß ich auch nicht so genau, wie das dann umgesetzt werden würde. Aber de facto ist das ja etwas, was sie anspricht, was ja erdrückend ist, wenn man bedenkt, dass wirklich der Bankrott hergestellt werden kann, bevor irgendetwas aufgeklärt ist.
Genau. Also es steht eine zweite Lesung aus. Dieses Gesetz wird hoffentlich in seinem Text so geändert, dass davor gerichtlich Raum eine Rolle spielt und die nationalen Bezüge da sind. Und ansonsten kann ich hier verweisen auf diese No-SLAPP-Initiative. Denn die machen relativ viele Fallbeispiele. Also da wird es sehr anschaulich. Und sie bezeichnen das eben auch als ein Mittel der autoritären Beeinflussung. Das ist nicht einfach irgendein Richter oder so eine Anwaltskanzlei, die über die Stränge schlägt. Sondern da geht es einfach richtig zur Sache.
Zunächst wollte ich dich mal fragen, bevor wir jetzt zu dem Thema kommen, Ukraine, ob du alles gehört hast von Bojan Pancewski zu dem Anschlag auf Nord Stream 2. Hast du das gelesen?
Nein.
Ja, dieses Buch jetzt veröffentlicht wurde, also Bojan Pancewski ist ja der Wall Street Journal Journalist, der ja schon sehr lange darüber berichtet hat, dass ja eine Gruppe von ukrainischen Soldaten und Geheimdienstlern dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Pipeline gesprengt wurde. Er hat ja schon vor vielen Monaten damit aufsehenerregende Interviews und Reportagen geliefert. Und jetzt hat er ein Buch dazu veröffentlicht, das auch in Deutschland erschienen ist. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen. Er war aber in einer Doppelfolge bei Ronzheimer zu Gast. Ich habe keine Clips dazu, weil ich sagen würde, wenn man das genauer wissen will, kann man es da tatsächlich hören. Es ist ein sehr interessantes Gespräch, bei dem man sieht, okay, die Informationen sind jetzt alle da. Das war jetzt nicht nur eine kleine Gruppe, die völlig autonom gehandelt hat, sondern er sagt schon, das ging weit hinauf in hohe Kreise. Auch wenn Zelensky und die seinen sagen, da haben wir nichts von gewusst und alles da leugnen, er schildert das so, wie das jetzt gerade sehr widersprüchlich kommuniziert wird. Man kann dann seine Schlüsse dann durchaus daraus ziehen. Bojan Pancewski zieht die auch daraus. Ich finde es sehr bemerkenswert, dass wir noch unsere Phasen ändern können, wo Enthüllungen kamen, wie die von Julian Assange oder Edward Snowden. Da wurde das Handy der Kanzlerin abgehört oder so. Das war ein Thema wochenlang in den Medien. Man hat überlegt, wie kann man eigentlich noch kooperieren mit den Amerikanern, wenn das so und so ist. Hier werden einfach Milliarden kaputt gemacht durch einen terroristischen Anschlag. Und man sagt einfach, ja gut, aber das war eh eine dumme Idee mit Nord Stream. So kann man ja nicht damit vorgehen. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wir müssen nochmal über Nord Stream diskutieren oder was. Das steht überhaupt nicht hier zur Debatte. Aber ich kann nicht anfangen, Infrastruktur, staatstheoretisch anzugreifen, weil mir das irgendwie nicht passt.
Wobei wir sagen müssen, Holger Schlag von der Zeit hat auch sehr intensiv dazu recherchiert und viel geschrieben. Also es ist jetzt nicht nur die ganze deutsche Debatte und zum Glück hat jemand von Wall Street Journal oder so.
Was ich jetzt interessant finde, ist, dass es sowohl die Recherchen von Holger Starke, wie auch dann die noch viel ausführlicheren Reportagen von Bojan Paschewski. Also jetzt alles auf dem Tisch haben wir Informationen und trotzdem sagt man so, oh ja, okay, interessant.
Wir hatten auch ein 100 Millionen Veruntreuungsskandal direkt mit dem Finanzminister der Ukraine und dem Büroleiter von Solensky oder wem auch immer da involviert war. Ja, war auch nur für drei Tage.
Ja und da sehen wir einfach, wie sich das so gewandelt hat, dass man jetzt offenbar sagt, naja, das ist halt Krieg und wir wissen im Krieg und in der Liebe ist alles erlaubt. Deshalb reden wir jetzt nicht mehr davon. Das kann doch nicht sein.
Also im Krieg und in der Liebe, ich dachte im Krieg und auf hohe See.
Also, vielleicht auch so.
Im Krieg ist nicht alles erlaubt.
Eben, im Krieg aber eigentlich auch nicht. Das ist ja der Witz bei der Sache und das ist doch unglaublich, dass wir jetzt in so einer Zeit leben, wo man nicht mehr so ist, dass man jetzt erst mal die Information benötigt. Und jetzt sagt man, leider kommen wir da nicht ran. Und so können wir nur spekulieren und spekulieren ist immer schwierig, deswegen reden wir nicht drüber. Das ist ja die alte Zeit. Jetzt sind wir in einer neuen Zeit, wo man sagt, man hat es alles, da ist schon das Sachbuch geschrieben zu. Und trotzdem sagt man, naja, als weiter, was sollen wir jetzt hier groß thematisieren? Dass die Ukrainer in diesen Leuten Helden sehen, das können die ja gerne so machen. Aber das kann ja nicht die Reaktion des deutschen Staates darauf sein.
Ich bin im Bilde.
Merkwürdig. Ich wollte das nur mal einschieben, weil mich das doch sehr verblüfft hat. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal zu der Situation der Soldaten in der Ukraine gehen. Machen das aber über einen kleinen Umweg. Es gibt einen Handelsblatt-Podcast, der heißt Merkel und Mathis, unter anderem mit, nee, nicht Merkel, sondern Merkel. Miriam Merkel und ihr Kollege Mathis unterhalten sich dort über wirtschaftliche Dinge. Sie kommen dann auf Iran zu sprechen und wie sich das wohl auswirken könnte auf die Weltwirtschaft. Das wollen wir aber hier gar nicht thematisieren.
Machen wir gleich.
Sondern wir wollen uns ein Clip anhören. Sie macht so eine Herleitung, Miriam Merkel, wie das heute anders ist, als damals mit dem Terroranschlag vom 11. September. Und damals stand der Westen geschlossen zusammen. Heute hat man den Iran, der Westen steht nicht mehr zusammen. Sie sagt, weil die Situation auch für heute eine völlig andere ist. Mir geht es aber gar nicht um diese Kontextualisierung, die da erfolgt, sondern die Anekdote, die Miriam Merkel bringt. Und die sagt uns doch unfreiwillig sehr viel darüber, wie eigentlich so eine Elite darauf blickt, was jetzt gerade zu tun ist. Wir springen jetzt 25 Jahre zurück. In Deutschland gibt es wieder eine Debatte, sollen wir uns an irgendeinem Krieg beteiligen oder nicht. Es geht um den Krieg in Afghanistan. Sie schildert jetzt ganz persönlich, wie sie das erlebt hat. Wir wissen, Gerhard Schröder stellt ja die Vertrauensfrage, um das Lager zu einen, also um Grüne und SPD-Abweichler hinter sich zu bekommen, für diesen Einsatz in Afghanistan.
In der Aktion Enduring Freedom, also der Afghanistan-Operation, und wollte auch Bundeswehrtruppen schicken. Und der Grüne Koalitionspartner fand das nicht so toll. Es gab auch einige in der SPD, die das nicht so toll fanden. Und dann hat Schröder etwas gemacht, was ein echtes historisches Erstmaligkeitsprinzip hatte. Er hat nämlich gesagt, dann gibt es dazu im Bundestag eine Abstimmung. Und das wird eine Vertrauensfrage. Ich verbinde diesen Einsatz mit der Vertrauensfrage. Und diese Abstimmung ist am 16. November 2001 passiert. Und ich erinnere mich so gut daran, weil ich an diesem Tag einen Preis bekommen habe. Es geht gleich darum, zusammen mit der wunderbaren Hertha Müller, der Schriftstellerin und mit Hans-Olaf Henkel, damals BDI-Präsident.
Ja, alles ganz wunderbare Leute. Ja, es scheint ein Gruselkabinett gewesen zu sein, ja.
Wir waren im alten Wasserwerk in Bonn und als ich meine Rede, meine Dankesrede gehalten habe, wurde die Abstimmung verkündet. Ich hatte mein Telefon neben mir und dachte, ich muss das jetzt einfach wissen, was da passiert. Und hab mitten in der Rede dann gesagt, übrigens, die Abstimmung ist positiv ausgegangen, trotz einiger Abweichler. Also es gibt diesen Einsatz. Und dann weiß ich noch, dass es einen riesen Applaus gab in diesem Wasserwerk bei allen, die da waren, weil die Stimmungslage war, das können wir nicht ausschlagen. Wir müssen hier als westliche Verbündete den Kampf gegen den Terror unterstützen.
Ja, da stand man also schon...
2001, sechs Jahre vor dem iPhone, hatte sie ein Handy, wo sie während sie selber eine Rede in die Nachricht...
Ja, sie ist ja sehr technikaffin. Sie ist ja enorm technikaffin. Und es gab ja schon Nokia.
Sony Ericsson, Browser damals.
Und da konnte man doch auch schon so Push-Nachrichten, glaube ich, drauf bekommen oder irgendwie so SMS-Dienste.
Ich glaube, jemand hat in der MMS geschrieben.
Vermutlich. Was für mich jetzt entscheidender ist, wir haben also da die großen Denker, Miriam Meckel, Hertha Müller, Hans-Olaf Henkel. Und im Saal kann man sich auch vorstellen, wer da so alles rumgesessen hat, die heute auch wieder da irgendwo sitzen würden, wenn so was ist. Und heute auch dann applaudieren, wenn es heißt, und jetzt nochmal mehr Aufrüstung, nochmal dies und das. Und ich finde interessant, dass sie diese Anekdote nochmal so erzählt, wo man ja sagen muss, ja, dieser Afghanistan-Krieg war ein großer Fehler und ein unendliches Fiasco. Aber sie nochmal das nicht kritisch jetzt einordnet, sondern einfach nochmal sagt, ja, und da waren wir alle so froh und alle haben applaudiert. Das ist so ein bisschen die Haltung, die ja heute genauso im Journalismus zu finden ist. Dann gibt es ja noch die Leute, die noch weiter hervorgehen und sagen, ich würde kämpfen. Es steigen ja jetzt nach und nach so Bücher von Leuten, die sagen, ich würde kämpfen. Und wir haben ja auch gerade so im Kulturbereich viele, die sagen, jetzt müssen wir mutig sein.
Campino würde für mich kämpfen, das finde ich natürlich sehr gut.
Ja, so Leute, wo man immer sagt, ihr kämpft ja gar nicht, ihr sitzt ja zu Hause oder singt dann, wenn es ganz schlimm kommt, auch eine CD voll. Ein Autor der Fraktion Ich würde kämpfen ist Arthur Weigand, der hin und wieder auch in die Ukraine reist. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt, für euch würde ich kämpfen. Das ist sozusagen der Antipode von unserem Ole Nymond. Diese beiden sind nun aufeinander getroffen auf einem Podium in München bei einem Literaturfestival. Und Ole hat eine ganz simple Frage gestellt, das hören wir uns jetzt mal an und versuchen auch mal dieses Timing abzufüllen.
Ich beneide Ole immer noch sehr dafür.
Ich nicht. Ich würde es nicht machen wollen.
Du bist so ein Idioten über den Nationalstaat und hier Verteidigung, Geschichte, bla bla.
Also ist es Comedy Gold auf jeden Fall?
Genial.
Mir wäre es unangenehm, ich sitze lieber im Schweizer Literaturclub und kann über Bücher reden. Aber gut. Schön, dass Ole sich opfert für uns, das zu tun.
Ich springe gern mal ein, Ole, falls du mal krank bist oder so.
Also wir hören jetzt mal da rein.
Aber jetzt lass mich doch kurz die polemische Frage dir stellen, wie es mit der Ausbildung läuft.
Er fragt, ob denn jetzt eine Reservisten-Ausbildung da ist bei ihm, bei Arthur Weigand, und er würde ja schließlich kämpfen wollen.
Meine Reservisten-Ausbildung, sag ich mal so. Also ich bin ja gerade in der Position, dass ich explizit ukrainische Soldaten unterstütze, weil ich der Meinung bin, wenn die Ukraine Russland dort auffällt, wo sie ist, wird niemand in dem Kontext eine Reservisten-Ausbildung brauchen, niemand wird in die Wehrpflicht eingezogen, wären wir Russland in der Position.
Die machen das für uns. Toll, die machen das einfach für uns.
Ich unterstütze ja die Ukraine, damit ich keine Reservisten-Ausbildung machen muss. Der wird sich gleich noch wundern, ich spiele gleich einen anderen Clip.
Dort aufhalten, wo es gerade ist. Die Problematik ist ja gerade, dass aus russischer Perspektive kein Verhandlungsfrieden herbeigeführt werden kann, weil sie bestimmte Oblasten haben wollen, die in der Konstitution festgeschrieben sind. Und die Aufgabe beispielsweise, wenn man immer sagt, sie sollen den Donetsk Gürtel aufgeben, was würde das im Endeffekt dann für die Gesellschaft und für die Menschen bedeuten? Nämlich ständiger militärischer Druck auf politische Entscheidungen, die potenziell liberal oder alliberal sind, das ist eine andere Frage, aber trotzdem Druck von außen. Deswegen ist aus meiner Perspektive der wichtigste Beitrag, gerade damit wir uns überhaupt nicht die Frage stellen, würde ich kämpfen oder nicht, ist gerade Russland aufzuhalten, damit sie auch gar nicht in den Gedanken kommen, das Baltikum anzugreifen.
Hört es ja auch praktisch. Er schreibt ein Buch, für euch würde ich kämpfen, um dann zu sagen, die Fragen brauchen wir uns jetzt nicht zu stellen, weil die dann der Ukraine irgendwas machen, erzählt was von liberal, illiberal. Es geht dann weiter. Oder hat er fast so ein Timing wie so ein Harald Schmitt in seinen besten Zeiten. Wir hören mal weiter.
Kämpfen oder nicht, ist gerade Russland aufzuhalten, damit sie auch gar nicht in den Gedanken kommen, das Baltikum anzugreifen.
Hört es ja auch praktisch tun.
Könnte ich auch machen.
Warum nicht?
Also da ist doch der Konjunktiv im Titel für euch wurde ich kämpfenbewusst gewählt. Ja.
Okay, gut.
Absolut. Ich habe mit einem guten Freund mal drüber geredet, tatsächlich in Kiew.
Hat er ein Buch geschrieben, ohne einmal über seinen Titel und seine Argumente nachzudenken?
Offenbar. Und ich meine, er wird ja Ohles Argumente eigentlich schon auch rauf und runter kennen. Von daher geht man ja da höchst vorbereitet rein.
Das ist, wie Ole Liebel sagte, Leute kommen auf Podien und als wären sie gerade falsch geboren. Keine Vorbereitung, kein Nichts. Es ist grotesk.
Auch darüber, mit der Internet, sich einfach mal drüber geredet, weil er sich überlegt nach ein, zwei, nach drei Jahren, ob er kämpfen will oder nicht. Er ist jetzt gegangen nach drei Jahren und er meinte zu mir, als ich auch genau diese Frage gestellt habe, ehrlicherweise ist er ein bisschen feige, jetzt nicht an die Front zu ziehen oder ähnliches, meinte er zu mir, vielleicht findest du es auch ein bisschen polemisch, ich kann es nicht so pathetisch sagen, aber er sagte, man braucht auch manchmal Zeit, um sich zu überlegen, ob man kämpft oder nicht. Oder inwieweit man bereit ist zu kämpfen. Okay, aber die nimmst du dir jetzt noch? Also du nimmst dir noch die Zeit, zu überlegen, ob du es tätest, schreibst aber schon mal ein Buch mit einem halben Versprechen auf dem Titel, dass du es tun wirst? Ja. Okay, alles klar. Nö, keine weiteren Fragen.
Da würde ich ganz kurz reingehen.
Wie heißt der Autor? Arthur Weigand. Was ist, wenn deine Freundin gerade von einem Rosen angegriffen wird, während du daneben stehst? Wie lange denkst du nach?
Jetzt machst du genau die Frage, die sie dann immer ohne stellen. Dann nehme ich mir Zeit zu überlegen. Also das ist wirklich paradigmatisch für den deutschen Kulturdiskurs über diesen Krieg. Ich würde, aber nicht jetzt, und ich überleg's mir mal, und gut, dass es andere machen, bitte meine Söhne nicht, ich guck mal.
Das ist einfach sehr, sehr, sehr gut. Hast du mitbekommen, was der Reservistenverband für einen Bock geschossen hat?
Nein.
Okay, wir spielen es über Bande. Der Reservistenverband hat einen Vorschlag gemacht. Der Deutschlandfunk greift das auf, aber nicht direkt, sondern in der Presseschau kommt man drauf zu sprechen, was die FAZ darüber und so weiter. Also wir sind sozusagen im Kontext des Kontexts von Sachen, die so und so weiter. Es ist wirklich verrückt und wir müssen uns jetzt kurz ein paar Gedanken machen.
Auch die FAZ findet es gut, wenn Reservisten bis 70 dienen. Sie ist der Meinung, tauglich für den Wehrdienst ist man auch da noch, wenn man die gesetzliche Altersgrenze schon überschritten hat. Die Äußerung des Verbandspräsidenten kann der Regierungskoalition noch aus einem ganz anderen Grund, den Marsch blasen. Wenn Reservisten bis 70 dienen können, dann können sie auch bis 70 ihren zivilen Beruf ausüben. Das Renteneintrittsalter nach oben zu setzen, wäre die Konsequenz.
So, wir haben schon über das Phänomen der Versicherheitlichung gesprochen. Wenn, wie zum Beispiel alte Klimafragen oder so, wir müssen aus Gründen der nationalen Sicherheit jetzt Solar zählen, hier auch. Deutschland ist bedroht, also brauchen wir alle Männer schussfähig bis 70. Und jetzt, wo wir einmal dabei sind, also da kann ja keiner was sagen, außer Ole, dass man mit 69 noch in den Krieg zieht. Dann können wir doch auch gleich die grundsätzliche Lebensarbeitszeit bis 70 ausdehnen.
Vor zwei Wochen gab es in der FAZ einen Artikel, der wir überschrieben mit, eine Lockerung des Kündigungsschutzes erhöht unsere Wehrfähigkeit. Ich habe ihn nicht gelesen. Ich vermute, es geht in eine ähnliche Richtung. Flexibilisierung.
Ja, Leute brauchen Anschlussverwendung.
Der Ernstfall ist ja eigentlich immer schon da. Und wenn wir nur das BIP verteidigen.
Man soll halt nicht zu lange drüber nachdenken, weißt du?
Ja, jetzt...
Wollen wir nicht alle auf so ein Podium gehen? Ich würde mir sofort zusagen.
Vielleicht könntest du auf ein Podium gehen.
Kann man halt so einen Streit-Schießwütiger mit mir ein Podium machen.
Ja, also ich würde dir vorschlagen als Gesprächspartnerin Christina Dunz. Du kennst sie vielleicht. Sie ist Journalistin für Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland.
Ich kenne sie natürlich.
Sie hat einen Kommentar geschrieben. Silensky und Merz haben sich ja getroffen. Da haben beide angemerkt kritisch. Das sei ein Problem, dass so viele junge Männer in Deutschland sind, die aus der Ukraine geflohen sind. Christina Dunz schreibt einen Kommentar, der schon überschrieben ist, mit eine schmerzhafte Frage der Fairness. Folgendes lesen wir jetzt da. Die Dankbarkeit von Präsident Silensky für die Solidarität und die Wertschätzung von Kanzler Friedrich Merz für die ukrainische Verteidigung, auch der europäischen Demokratie, waren bei der Regierungskonsultation entsprechend erwartbar. Aufhorchen ließ ein anderes sehr sensibles Problem, das beide ansprachen, die Flucht ukrainischer Männer im wehrfähigen Alter nach Deutschland. Jetzt beginnt also eigentlich der Kommentar. Sie fehlen der Ukraine an der Front, um eine gerechte Rotation der Soldaten zu ermöglichen. Denn hier wird ja so getan, als sterben ja ukrainische Soldaten nicht an der Front, sondern die rotieren.
Ja, die fahren nach Hause und fallen wieder an die Front.
Die wollen wieder ein bisschen mehr Urlaub haben, deswegen müssen die kommen. Silensky wählte nicht das Wort Drückeberger oder Verräter, schilderte aber in aller Härte die Lage seines Landes. Die Soldaten, die gegen die Russen kämpfen, hätten auch Familien. Und da können wir hinzufügen, ja, und die meisten werden die Familie nicht wiedersehen, weil sie da sterben. Also hier wird so suggeriert, wenn die Soldaten kommen jetzt, also wenn die jungen Männer aus Deutschland wieder in die Ukraine zurückkehren, dann gibt es einfach nur mehr Urlaub für die Frontsoldaten, was ja nicht der Fall ist. Sie schützen den Staat. Und jeder Ukrainer, der dazu in der Lage sei, müsste nach der Verfassung diesen Schutz gewährleisten. Hier wird es ja wenigstens mal ausgesprochen, was Ole immer sagt, genau, die schützen den Staat. Aber der Schutz des Staates bedeutet für die dann möglicherweise einen Einwilligen in den Tod. Also der Zweck ist hier der Staat und der Mensch ist dann Mittel dazu. Weiter heißt es im Kommentar, viele hätten mit ihrer Ausreise ukrainische Gesetze verletzt. Muss man sagen, ja, wenn man einen Ausnahmezustand ausruft und sagt, jetzt darf keiner mehr raus, dann ist halt keine Reisefreiheit mehr. Aber von Gesetzesverletzung, na ja. Ihre Rückkehr sei eine Frage der Fairness. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt in einem Gerechtigkeitsdiskurs angekommen, wo man ja sagen muss, Gerechtigkeitsdiskurs sind ja eh so ein bisschen doof, meistens zumindest. Hier geht es ja sogar noch so, dass man sagen muss, ja, wird es ein bisschen gerechter, wenn ich auch ein bisschen sterben darf oder wie?
Soll ich dir mal flankieren dazu, kurz ein Zitat von Zelensky vorlesen? Spiegel online, 29. April, Überschrift Russlands Angriffskrieg, Zelensky sieht Chancen für Rüstungs-Exporte der Ukraine. Das Zitat von Zelensky lautet, aktuell verfügen wir über Produktionsbereiche mit 50 Prozent Überkapazität. Sie haben wirklich zu wenig Leute und zu viel Zeug.
Ja.
Und wir rüsten ja in Deutschland auch gerade auf und haben auch zu wenig Leute. Jetzt kommt diese Automatisierung und so, ja? Ja.
Das knappe Gut Arbeit.
Genau, genau. Das knappe Gut Soldaten. Das knappe Gut nächster Jahrgang.
Ja.
Es ist grotesk.
Also weiter heißt es dann und sicherlich ist es auch eine Frage des gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalts, sagt jetzt Christina Dunz, von dem man ja doch eigentlich nichts mehr hat, wenn man tot ist, von diesem gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhang. Zudem kann man ja fragen, was ist das jetzt für einen Zusammenhalt in so einem ungleichen Land mit so einer solchen Klassengesellschaft, wo man sich ja übrigens auch für 12.000 Euro wieder dann aus einem Bus rauskaufen kann, wenn man da eingesperrt wurde. Kaum jemand erträgt die Vorstellung, dass der eigene Bruder, Ehemann oder Vater in einen Kampf zieht und vielleicht nicht wiederkommt. Wer könnte nicht nachvollziehen, dass Betroffene nach Schlupflöchern suchen? Und wir ahnen schon, wenn das so formuliert wird, leider, leider, leider muss es aber sein. Und natürlich muss der Kriegstreiber im Kreml die Ukraine endlich in Frieden lassen. Denn wir wissen ja, nur Putin kann den Krieg beenden. Das wird ja seit März 2022 so gesagt. Schluss jetzt dieses Kommentars. Die bittere Wahrheit ist nur, dass Russland sie längst überrollt hätte. Wären ihre Soldaten nicht zur Stelle gewesen? Wer würde Zelensky da nicht verstehen? Und da würde ich mich anfügen, ich zum Beispiel, weil ich ja leben will. Also wir sind hier in einem Abnutzungskrieg, der ja jetzt auch wirklich von allen so genannt wird. Und da sagt man jetzt, ne, die sollen doch bitte mal gehen. Und das ist zwar eine schmerzhafte Frage, aber doch eine der Fairness. So Mainstream-Journalismus, der geht dann natürlich überall so in diesem Ton. Beispielsweise war Susanne Petersen bei Ronsheimer zu Gast, die dann auch nochmal sagt, ja, aber es gibt ja eigentlich keine Alternative und und so hart das ist und die dann so. Also das lassen wir aber alles weg jetzt. Ich habe das hier nur so paradigmatisch vorgelesen, Christina Dunst.
Darf ich noch einen kleinen Kurs machen? Ich habe ja eben zu meinem Handy gegriffen. Ich kriege ja immer Kritik von Hörern, weil du liest was Schönes vor und ich greife zum Handy.
Und dass du dann da in der Zeit...
Aber ich habe natürlich hier, du siehst es, meine Mitarbeiterinnen, Alcina ist gerade aktuell oben. Alcina liest für mich Texte. Du hast ja jetzt gesagt, im Grunde sollte man dem Text nicht vorbeigehen, aber die ganze Prose und so. Ich habe Alcina darauf getrimmt, mir aus jedem Text, den ich ihr gebe, mir den Anlass, in einem Satz zu nennen, die Kernaussage in drei Sätzen, dann die Protagonisten aufzulisten und dann die wichtigsten Zitate. Danach erst Proante, was will der Autor und so. Und ich führe ein so entspanntes Leben, weil ich tagsüber nichts mehr lese, sondern ich speichere mir nur noch Sachen weg, die ich irgendwie denke, sollte ich mal nicht dran vorbeigehen. Am nächsten Morgen gehe ich das einfach kurz durch. Ich fühle mich sehr gut informiert, ich habe alle Zitate griffbereit. Es ist wie so ein Werbefilter gegen Christina Dunz, Rosa und so. Ich werde mal eine KI-Sprechstunde zum Thema haben.
Vor allem den Text muss man wirklich der KI geben, weil sie ja hier einfach nur noch mal die Worte wiedergibt von Zelensky mit Konjunktiv erst, um irgendwann den Konjunktiv dann zu verabschieden und zu sagen, ja, da können wir ihn doch verstehen. So ist es auch einfach.
Und sie möchte konstant erinnern, dass sie eine Menschlin ist, die natürlich auch einen Bruder hat. Und es wäre ganz schlimm, wenn jetzt Krieg wäre.
Aber leider muss es wohl sein. Deswegen lassen wir jetzt diesen ganzen Klatterradar weg, wo Susanne Petersen nochmal sagte, aber trotzdem die Situation so weiter und fragen uns nur, wie ist es denn, wenn man in der Ukraine ein junger Mann ist und zwangsrekrutiert wird? Das heißt, man wird einfach aufgegriffen und in einen Bus gesteckt. Sie hat mit solchen Leuten gesprochen. Und diese Abschnitte jetzt, die gehen ins Eingemachte. Man kann es ja schwerertragen, aber man muss sich dem wirklich stellen. Sie erzählt.
Die das nicht wollen, also die Anzahl derjenigen, die unerlaubt fernbleiben der Armee, die gesucht werden. Wir haben da eine Zahl von zwei Millionen Männern, die gesucht werden, angeblich gehört aus Regierungskreisen. Also die wächst. Wir hören viel von Suizid an der Front. Also es ist mitnichten eine einfache Situation. Und wir waren jetzt tatsächlich auch in Dnipropetrovsk in einem Lager, was uns vorher nie gelungen ist, in dem gerade solche Männer hinkommen, die sehr wahrscheinlich als Infanteristen an vorderster Front kämpfen werden.
Erstmal haben wir...
Es gibt Lager, in dem man die Soldaten vor ihrem Einsatz einsperrt, damit sie nicht flüchten.
Ja.
Das ist immer eine neue Information, finde ich.
Ja. Und sie sagt ja, es ist uns jetzt erstmalig gelungen. Das heißt, fünf Jahre Krieg. Und wir haben ein solches Informationsdefizit, dass jetzt mal gerade hier...
Den wird, glaube ich, auch etwas gesagt. Sie sind jetzt in dem Lager. Also derzeit ist nicht geplant, dass sie das Lager verlassen dürfen. Also derzeit bleiben sie noch hier.
Es ist noch alles viel schlimmer. Pass auf.
Und der Kommandeur hat zu mir gesagt, ich habe ihn gefragt, guck mal, ich habe, der Mann hat mir das im Interview erzählt, der das. Und wie ist das aus deiner Sicht? Und er hat gesagt, bitte erzähl mir gar kein einziges Detail über die Männer, mit denen du sprichst. Ich werde die nächste Woche alle an Vorderste Front schicken und wahrscheinlich wird keiner überleben.
Sehr gut. Das ist ein sehr therapeutisch aufgeklärter Umgang mit belastenden Situationen. Ja.
Also bitte zeig mir nicht die Individuen, die da sind.
Bitte denn keine Namen. Das ist nur wieder traurig. Den Hausdieren keine Namen geben.
Ja.
Es gab so eine Art Psychologe dort, mit dem ich gesprochen habe. Also der hat keine Psychologie studiert oder irgendeine Ausbildung. Der war Techniker im Telekommunikationsunternehmen vorher. Aber er ist eben für die psychische Betreuung verantwortlich. Und ich habe ihn auch gefragt, wie viele Männer, die da bei euch sind, wollen denn kämpfen? Und dann sagt er, es gibt in jeder Gruppe unheimlich viele, die verzweifelt sind, die sich ungerecht behandelt fühlen, die sagen, warum bin ich hier, die immer noch bis zum Schluss denken, das wäre alles ein riesiges Missverständnis.
Aber Arthur Weingarts Weigans Dank ist ihnen sicher.
Von München aus im Literaturhaus noch mal zu rufen.
Er denkt auch rüber nach, vielleicht demnächst auch zu unterstützen. Vielleicht. Aber erstmal gut.
Und Christina Dunz will noch die, die hier noch frei rumlaufen, dahinschicken, wegen der Fairness.
Ja, die Fairness.
Und dann gibt es auch eben viele, die sich bis zum Schluss weigern und sagen, ich mache das nicht. Und er sagt, das wäre dumm, weil sie werden so oder so an die Front gehen. Aber sie lernen dann eben nicht in den wenigen Wochen Ausbildung, die sie da überhaupt haben.
Das heißt, keine Verweigerung mehr möglich.
Bei Stormship Troopers, die sterben einfach noch früher.
Ja, stimmt.
Und da schämen sie rein, die Klappe geht halt 30 Sekunden herauf.
Stimmt. Müsste man eigentlich sich auch nochmal ansehen. Ja. Ronsheimer, kannst du das auch nicht so recht glauben.
Aber Susanne, ganz kurz, wenn du da als junger Mann hinkommst, wir haben hier auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass das ja tatsächlich passiert. Ich kenne auch Freunde von mir, die mitten in Kiew beim Einkaufen dann einkassiert wurden und dann in Richtung eines Übungszentrums gebracht wurden, weil sie eben werpflichtig sind. Und aber dennoch, also diejenigen, die dann dort sind, die du dort gesehen hast, getroffen hast, wenn die jetzt sagen würden, ich will nicht an die Front, ich werde nicht kämpfen, dann bleibt ihnen ja theoretisch die Möglichkeit, ins Gefängnis zu gehen, oder?
Also Ronsheimer erinnert sich gerade, dass mehrfach Freunde, wie er sagt, weggecashed wurden, während sie einkaufen waren. Also ich kann für mich sagen, wenn nur einer von denen ich sage, dass mein Freund so was passiert, beschäftigt mich das Rest meines Lebens.
Ja.
Und es ist ja nicht so eine blasse Erinnerung, die ich, als wir gerade drüber reden, stimmt, ich hatte da ja mal einen Peter und er wurde weggecashed.
Ja. Ich bin auch total verblüfft, das jetzt alles mal gerade so zu hören. Also wo gab es das jetzt vorher, dass das so gesagt wurde? Ja, genau, da sind ja auch Freunde von mir. Was passiert das alles mal? Ihre Antwort jetzt, die können auch ins Gefängnis gehen, stimmt das denn so oder was bedeutet das?
Genau, diese Frage habe ich auch gestellt. Also ich habe sie nochmal quasi geöffnet, habe gesagt, was passiert, wenn sich jemand bis zum Schluss standhaft weigert? Aber man muss ja sagen, in dem Fall sind diese Männer mit dem Bus schon in Richtung Front gefahren worden. Nicht in Kiew oder Umgebung, in einem Ausbildungslager. Und er sagt, im besten Fall gehen sie ins Gefängnis. Realistisch gesehen kommen sie in eine ein bisschen unbeliebtere Einheit und landen ein bisschen früh an vor das der Front.
Ja, kannst ja dann desertieren, soweit die Füße tragen, gibt es einen Film.
Falsche Erwartungen werden dann auch geweckt. Denn das haben wir ja auch jetzt mehrmals in so Berichten gesehen. Man geht in Schulklassen und sagt, würdet ihr dann kämpfen? Und dann gibt es immer ganz viele, die sagen ja, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, so als Thronenpilot zu arbeiten. Und dann denkt man immer so, ja, wahrscheinlich wird der ganze Krieg nicht nur aus Thronenpiloten bestehen. Was wir hier hören ist, es gibt keine Wahl mehr, weil die ganze Zeit immer so suggeriert wird, ja dann kann man das ja so oder so machen, kann da oder dort sein. Es ist keine Wahl mehr. Interessant ist ja auch, dass wir sehr viele Berichte bekommen haben, in den vergangenen Monaten Kamerateams gehen, hier in Deutschland in den Schulklassen und fragen, und, würdet ihr kämpfen? Dann gibt es Gott sei Dank viele, die sagen nein. Und manche sagen aber dann immer so gern, ja ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, so Thronenpilot oder so zu sein.
Das waren schon die 70er-Engtern.
Man stellt sich ja immer gerne irgendwas vor, was dann doch nicht ganz so schlimm ist, oder Funker oder als Journalist berichten dabei, Sanitäter, aber der Krieg braucht ja auch Leute, die an der Front sind und da direkt kämpfen und sterben. Interessanterweise hört man selten Leute, die sagen, ich würde gerne Frontsoldat werden und gehe dann da richtig ins Manöver.
Ich stelle dir mal so eine Debatte vor. Ole sitzt da, macht sich einen Spaß draußen, sagt total gerne, ich wollte schon immer mal, darf man da auch mit einem Schwert? Also wenn man nah genug dran ist, darf man da noch mal richtig oder muss man schießen? Was ist dann los, wer ein Publikum? Also Krieg ja, aber bitte nur aus der Distanz schießen und nur einschießen, bitte direkt in den Kopf.
Das sind die falschen Erwartungen, die dann auch dort anzutreffen sind, Peterson berichtet.
Aber das ist ja grausam. Also es ist ja...
Ach, das ist grausam.
Es stellt sich raus, das ist grausam.
Diese Fälle, wir hören von denen immer wieder. Aber wenn du da diesen jungen Männern in die Augen geschaut hast, also gerade wenn sie dann an die vorderste Front gebracht werden und sie wissen dann ja, dass die Überlebenschancen sehr gering sind, oder?
Ja, und ich muss auch sagen, es war was, was mich in einigen Jahren mit am meisten belastet hat, auch immer noch belastet, weil ich in dem Moment, in dem ich am Anfang mit denen gesprochen habe, das nicht wusste. Und erst durch diese Aussage von dem Kommandeur dann, nachdem ich schon vier Stunden mit all diesen Männern geredet hatte, wir waren insgesamt acht Stunden da, hat mir das klargemacht, weil die Männer selber zum Teil haben mir noch so erzählt, sie haben eine kleine Hoffnung, dass sie sich so gut im Training anstellen, dass sie vielleicht Drohnenpiloten werden, weil das wurde denen wohl erzählt, dass es noch eine Handvoll Männer gibt, die gesucht werden als Drohnenpiloten und darauf haben aber ungefähr 300 Männer dann gehofft.
Ja, man kann sich denken, dass das nicht geht. Ja, anknüpfend an den Text von Christina Dunz.
Ein Mann ist mir auch im Kopf geblieben, der halt zu mir kam und immer so ein bisschen abseits gewartet hat und der dann gesagt hat, wissen Sie, mein Sohn ist in Deutschland, der ist abgehauen, der wäre auch im richtigen Alter, um hierher zu kommen, hat er gesagt, aber jetzt ist der Sohn in Deutschland und der Vater hier.
Ja, und Christina Dunz wird jetzt wieder in der Familienzusammenführung planen.
Nee, das ist schon schade. Genau, so um Familienzusammenführung.
Ja, unglaublich. Letzter Clip dazu. Worum geht es eigentlich immer? Wir reden ja von Individuen da, die kollektiviert werden und plötzlich irgendeinem Zweck dienen müssen, der nicht ihr Zweck ist. Genau das schildert sie jetzt auch.
Was mir extrem aufgefallen ist und was mich auch immer noch so beschäftigt ist, dass die alle versucht haben, mit uns zu reden. Und das waren einfach zu viele. Und ich mag als Journalistin auch immer nicht so gerne mit allen sprechen und das dann nicht verwenden. Und dass sie alle versucht haben, zu zeigen, ich bin nicht irgendeine anonyme Masse. Also alle haben sehr persönliche Geschichten erzählt, die sind dann extrem offen.
Tja, also wir hatten ja einen sehr guten Salottext von ihr dazu, in dem diese Idee thematisiert wurde, was wäre, hätte Christian Drosten das Coronavirus nur von Twitter gekannt. Also so sehen diese Kommentare in Deutschland halt aus.
Das hatte Roman Witter diesen Text geschrieben für den Merkur.
Das eine Frau, die mal hingefahren ist und den Krieg ins Auge gesehen hat. Und selbst Ronzheimer kann sich nicht dagegen wehren, dass du einfach Horrorgeschichten von dir selbst sagst, dass du mich gerade kruselst. Das kann man jetzt hochskalieren. Das gilt grundsätzlich für alle überhaupt. Wer noch nicht so denkt wie Ronzheimer gerade, wow, das kruselt mich und so, der kennt das Virus nur von Twitter.
Ja, genau.
Und das kann man auch mit anderen Kriegen sehr gut erzählen. Und deswegen habe ich es auch angeknüpft an diese Passage da von Miriam Meckel, die sagt, da haben wir alle applaudiert, jetzt endlich in Afghanistan Einsatz. Ja, das bedeutet, dass dann deutsche Soldaten in Afghanistan irgendwo darum liegen und hoffen, dass sie nicht erschossen werden. Abschließend dazu, im EU-Parlament, wir reden ja gleich noch über Ungarn, ist jetzt die Sache durch. 90 weitere Milliarden für die Ukraine. Ursula von der Leyen sagt Folgendes dazu.
Die informale EU-Korps hat mit guten Nachrichten für Europa und Ukraine angefangen. Im Frühjahr haben wir gesagt, dass wir auf den 90-Billionen-Euro-Lohn für die Ukraine ein Weg oder das andere ergeben würden. Jetzt haben wir uns gut auf dieses Versprechen gemacht.
Die antwortigen. Die mutigen Ukraine, die gefangen gehalten werden, weil sie gar nicht sich mehr als mutig erweisen wollen.
Ukraine ist nicht der einzige Krieg. Es gibt auch einen im Iran und wir erinnern uns dunkel, denn daran schließen wir direkt an, dass Trump angedroht hat, diese Zivilisation auszulöschen, die vielleicht die älteste ist, die wir haben. Und wir wollen noch mal kurz nachhören, wie die deutsche Bundesregierung sich dazu so verhalten hat. Wir beginnen bei Merz.
Direkt kritisieren will Merz Donald Trump aber offenbar nicht. Angesprochen auf diese Aussage meint der Bundeskanzler, er habe das auch als rhetorischen Teil der Strategie Trumps verstanden.
Ich glaube, er ist selbst nicht davon ausgegangen, dass man ein Land wie den Iran vollkommen auslöschen kann. Dazu wäre es nach meiner festen Überzeugung nicht gekommen.
So Merz.
Was bitte ist das für eine Erklärung?
Ja, also wahrscheinlich hätte er nicht das gesamte Land in Schutt und Asche legen können. Vielleicht nur ein paar Millionen treffen.
Also ich halte das für eine unglaubliche, für mich ist das sofort zurücktreten. Ja. Das darf nicht, also so jemand darf nicht Bundeskanzler sein. Journalisten. Jasmin M. Barek im Podcast von Micky Beisenherz.
Diese Drohung und diese verrohte Sprache, die er auch schon Micky analysiert hat und diesen Ausfall, den Trump hatte vorgestern, ich habe das Gefühl, das hat so was.
Öffnet die...
Das hört man jetzt nicht so richtig. Das ist unser großer Kanzlerversteher Markus Feldenkirchen.
Vorgestern, ich habe das Gefühl, das hat so was.
Öffnet die verdammte Straße, ihr verrückten Mistkerle, oder ihr werdet in der Hölle landen.
Ja, Junge, so welche Hölle?
Das ist zumindest ein Trump-Zitat. Also, da weiß man gar nicht, was ist hier blöder, derjenige, der es vorträgt oder das Zitat.
Soll das denn sein? Also, dann macht doch die Hölle. Ich würde das gerne sehen, was er damit meint, weil diese Drohung ist so luftleer, die wirkt wie von so einem schreienden Kleinkind.
So, dann macht doch die Hölle. Ich würde das gerne sehen.
Ja, wir bleiben immer in der Zuschauerloge sitzen. Egal welcher Krieg.
Also, von Berlin aus zu sagen, macht doch die Hölle auf Teeran, da komme ich mir fast vernünftig vor, wenn ich sage, nö, da gibt es ein paar historische Städte, die ich gerade noch besuchen möchte.
Ja.
Obwohl das selber Schulden sozusagen kein okayer Gedanke ist. Aber das ist, also wir können ja hier kurz zusammenfassen, das, was Trump im Iran veranstaltet, ist die Hölle. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Definition anders lauten kann, als das halt die Hölle. Dass wir davon nicht sehen, ja gut, das ist nun mal in Afghanistan auch so gewesen. Da gibt es halt kein Internet. Im Iran gibt es jetzt gerade auch kein Internet. Da kann keiner berichten, das Land ist riesengroß. Also, Hölle ist halt da, auch wenn Jasmin im Barak es nicht serviert bekommt auf ihrem Silbertablett.
Ja, und wenn man es ja bekommt dann von Gaza, dann will man trotzdem nicht drüber sprechen. Also das haben wir ja auch die ganze Zeit erlebt.
Beirut.
Ja, also die Bananen, deutlich unterrepräsentiert, vor allem auch, dann nimmt man da dann Meldungen aus der israelischen Armee für Pressemeldungen und damit ist gut. Also das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt die ganze Zeit beobachten können.
Die New York Times hat die Hölle mal beziffert, denn auch wenn wir die Zerstörung nicht sehen, sie haben die Waffen durchgezählt. Es gab Berichterstattung von Eric Schmidt, also von dem New York Times Eric Schmidt. Und er sagt es gleich selber in dem Clip. Ich glaube, es war der uns ohnehin bekannte, ah ja, Jonathan Swann, den wir auch auf The Daily hören. Die sind mal die amerikanischen Waffenbestände durchgegangen. So er nennt jetzt gleich die Zahlen. Ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen. Es ist die am besten finanzierte Armee der Welt. Historisch einmalige, man könnte mehrfache Weltkriege, und zwar historische Weltkriege, wie sie stattfanden, mit dieser Art Zerstörungskraft wachen. Und jetzt hören wir hier die Zahlen, inwieweit diese Technik dort eingesetzt wurde.
Ich war in der Pentagon-Pressekonferenz mit einer Frage in meinem Kopf. Wie viele Bomben und Missile hat die US-Militärwesen in ihrer Kampagne gegen Iran? Der Vorgängerpräsident antwortete eine weitere Frage, als er plötzlich umgekehrt und direkt an mich geschaut hat. Und hier ist was er gesagt hat.
Ich würde die Pressemitglieder empfangen, zweimal zu denken, was die Leben, die sie in ihren Publikationen in den New York Times veröffentlicht haben, sehr wichtig sind.
Die Beratungen von mir und meinem Kollegen Jonathan Swan zeigen, dass die US-Militär durch kritische Waffen auf sehr hohem Pace geblieben ist. Die Menschen im Pentagon, im Militär, im Kongress waren bereit, uns darüber zu sprechen, sogar diese Konfidenz-Ansatzungen zu zitieren, weil sie sich auch darauf beantwortet haben, dass es wichtig ist.
So, das ist kurz vor 5050, hier wurde der halbe Bestand verschossen. So, hier geht es schon fast an ein Drittel ran.
Man ist ja doch erstaunt, dass es so schnell geht, dass die Munition knapp wird. Aber für eine so hochgerüstete Nation ist es dann doch noch...
Er spricht hier von 1000 Tomahawks. Trump hat in der ersten Amtszeit gegen Syrien 60 verschossen. Die ganze Magerding war in Aufruhr und so. Das ist die Hölle, für alle, die das unten erleiden müssen.
Auch hier, bei Patriots, keine Ahnung was das, 30 Prozent, Auch hier, bei Patriots, keine Ahnung, ist das 30%, ein Drittel vielleicht.
Also das sind wirklich, hier geht es an die Substanz und es ist jetzt nicht ein jahrelanger Krieg oder so, sondern das waren jetzt wenige Wochen.
Die Militäre haben auch mehr als 1000 Präzisionsteigungs- und Ground-Strike-Missile gegen die Ziele in Iran gefeiert. Jetzt, nach den internen Pentagon-Estimaten, haben die Militäre nur ein paar hundert von diesen übrig.
Also da ist man weit drüber. Da werden uns ungefähr zehn mal hundert Dots angezeigt und drei sind remaining. Das kann man noch bis Juli machen oder so und dann braucht man ernsthaft eine neue Strategie.
Aber auch interessant, dass er hier noch schon sagt, dass sei produziert worden für einen Krieg, einen Potenzial gegen China. Dass das hier schon einfach so ausgesporn wird, da steht ja eh bald an, wie ihr wisst.
Also wir nehmen natürlich hier amerikanische Berichterstattung.
Ja, ja, ich finde diese Selbstverständlichkeit ist so unglaublich, dass man sagt, ja die waren ja schon geplant eigentlich für den Krieg gegen China.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wie bei Snowden damals die Amerikaner rüber kamen und die deutsche Debatte damit mitprägen wollten, dass sie sagten. Und dann plötzlich hat die CIA einfach auch Amerikaner abgehört. Und alles, deutsch Publikum so, wow. Ja, hier wurde jetzt auch abgehört. Also ja, er nennt hier noch eine Zahl, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er sie schon genannt hatte.
Wir haben die White House für die Kommentare erzielt. Und das ist das, was Caroline Levitt, die White House-Presssekretärin, gesagt hat. Die USA hat den weltweit stärksten Militär, mit mehr als genügend Waffen und Munitionen, in Stockpilen hier zu Hause und überall auf der Welt.
So eine Milliarde Dollar am Tag kostet es allein Munition, diesen Iran-Krieg zu machen. Also wenn das nicht, zeigt mir, die Hölle ist. Ja, dann weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, worauf Jasmin in Bariq dann noch wartet. Eine gute Erklärung ist im heutigen Journal mal so untergekommen, dadurch, dass wir hier so völlig entgrenzte amerikanische Politik sehen.
Präsident Trump scheint darauf aus zu sein, die verrückten Theorie auf eine neue Ebene zu heben, indem er zeigt, dass es im Grunde keine roten Linien und keine Grenzen gibt, was er bereit ist zu tun, um seine Ziele zu erreichen. Was genau seine Ziele sind und wo seine roten Linien, das könnte Donald Trump morgen verraten, bei einer von ihm anberaumten Pressekonferenz im Weißen Haus.
Ja, also Mad Men auf die Spitze getrieben. Da würde ich sagen, dafür, dass 60 gegen tausende Tomahawks plötzlich in nur einer spätere Amtszeit im Raum steht, das ist schon wirklich brutal. Was sagt die deutsche Justizministerin Frau Hulbig dazu? Sie ist eingeladen im Deutschlandfunk Interview der Woche. Und ich würde sagen, also hier gibt es auf jeden Fall viele Gründe, vieles zu sagen. Sie entscheidet sich dafür.
Was Positionierung gegenüber Donald Trump betrifft, er hat dem Iran gedroht, eine ganze Zivilisation würde sterben und nicht zurückkehren. Das ist eine Drohung mit Kriegsverbrechen. Muss der nicht schon widersprochen werden, damit sie nicht als solche Folgen hat?
Ich persönlich halte diese Äußerung für verstörend und auch für erschreckend. Es ist auch kein Mittel in der Politik. Es ist auch kein Mittel, um Deals abzuschließen, solche Äußerungen und solche Drohungen auszusprechen.
So, sie sagt jetzt also, naja, sie ist schon persönlich verstört. Sie hat aber in dem politischen Interviewgespräch nochmal nachgefragt. Ja, okay, gibt es eine politische Dimension?
Wie sieht es mit dem Libanon aus? Bei den letzten Angriffen sind mehrere hundert Zivilisten gestorben.
Das sind Entwicklungen, die im Nahen Osten passieren, die in der Tat höchst problematisch und schwierig sind.
Wenn der Krieg, was jetzt den Iran betrifft, völkerrechtswidrig ist, was heißt das für die Nutzung der US Airbase im Rheinland-Pfalzischen Rammstein?
Ich bin die Justizministerin und das sind Fragen, die vor allen Dingen auch das Außenministeriumsverteidigungsministerium betreffen. Ich würde mich heute an dieser Stelle nicht äußern, aber wir wissen, dass wir innerhalb der Bundesregierung natürlich über solche Dinge auch diskutieren und sprechen.
Ach so.
Aber so lang läuft es erst mal jetzt wochenlang weiter.
Ja, das finde ich echt nicht gut. Ich weiß nicht, als...
Vor allen Dingen, bei anderen Themen sind die ja sofort immer Generalisten für alles Zuständige und fordern und machen und tun.
Genau.
Und hier geht es ja wohl um rechtliche Fragen. Da müsste eine Justizministerin vielleicht eine Ahnung haben, wie das einzuordnen ist.
Genau. Wenn man als Parlamentarier, also man hat ein Mandat von uns bekommen, was zu vertreten und dann so sagt, naja, Herr Schulz hat ja gesagt, wir sollen uns alle nur drei Themen suchen und das ist jetzt nicht eins von meinen, okay. Aber als Justizministerin zu völkerrechtlichen Fragen und deutschen Grund und Boden, Rammstein, so zu antworten, geht auch nicht.
Nein.
Also wir haben jetzt März und die Justizministerin gehört, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wir werden niemals etwas von unserem Außenminister Herr Wadepoel hören. Ja, den habe ich sowieso schon lange nicht mehr gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo er ist im Ausland. Das ist wirklich nicht gut. Wir wollen das Thema aber nicht zu groß machen, denn wir wissen alle Bescheid, ist da wirklich schlimm. Ich referiere kurz ein Clip im ProfG-Market Podcast bei Ed Elson. Er war der Morgan Stanley US-Chefökonom. Wie ist genau seine Funktion? Naja, also der Amerikachef von Morgan Stanley zu Gast. Und der meint dort, die Einbrüche durch Inflation im Privatportemonnaie der Amerikaner ist mittlerweile auf Augenhöhe mit den Entlastungen durch dieses Big Beautiful-Bild, wo er einfach per se steuert. Das muss man auch erst mal hinkriegen als amerikanischer Präsident. Dass man ein Gesetz macht, das sowieso schon ökonomisch so reinschneidet wie ein Iran-Krieg, aber im positiven Sinne. Und dann macht man einen Iran-Krieg, der das Ganze wieder ausgleicht. Das ist ja auch nicht mehr zu verstehen. Wenn jemand wirklich glaubt, Politik wird nochmal, das muss man nur inhaltlich erklären oder so, sage ich, nein, das sind wirklich nicht die Themen. Also inhaltlich, klar, kann man vieles machen und so. Aber irgendwie muss man ja anders drüber diskutieren.
Auch das wäre ja, wenn wir jetzt mal an diesen Podcast von Heidi Reichineck denken, Themen, die man mal wirklich besprechen könnte. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Was wir erleben jetzt durch diese erhöhten Energiepreise durch den Iran-Krieg ist, dass Geld abfließt. Das heißt, das Geld ist ja nicht einfach irgendwo anders, wo man sagt, das ist jetzt zu den Restaurantbetreibern gewandert und jetzt geben die das eben aus und dann ist das auch für die Volkswirtschaft gut, sondern dieses Geld wird ja aus Deutschland abfließen. Und damit fehlt es ja. Man hat also eine Situation, es wird alles teurer und es fließt Wohlstand ab. Dazu muss man sicher verhalten. Und da kann man ja nicht einfach, also da reicht ja auch nicht über Gewinnsteuer oder sowas. Das reicht einfach da nicht aus. Da kann man auch nicht über Vermögensteuer reden, weil das da nicht die betrifft, ja, eine Vermögensteuer auf einer nationalen Ebene. Wenn ich weiß, jetzt haben wir eine Inflationsrate von 2,9 Prozent. Wenn ich weiß, dass die Wirtschaftsinstitute jetzt wöchentlich dabei sind, ihre Prognosen nach unten zu korrigieren. Jetzt redet man von 0,5 oder 0,3 Prozent Wachstum. Also einigen von uns aus wird kein Wachstum geben. Mal sehen, ob wir noch Minus bekommen. Dann muss ich ja darauf doch Antwort nehmen bzw. muss das ja in anderer Weise diskutieren, dass das jetzt gerade der Fall ist. Aber mir scheint, dass das jetzt auch so als gegeben hingenommen wird. Und dann ist es einfach so.
Das denken immer alle zu klein. Das ist, also, wie heißt unsere Lieblings-Surplus? Junge, neue Mutterökonomin, die zum Beispiel beim...
Du machst doch jetzt den Anlauf Martina Linatas vielleicht?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, die Professorin, die aus Amerika herbeigeführt ist.
Isabella Weber?
Ja. Isabella Weber. Das finde ich die einzige Stimme, die einfach kurz darauf hinweist, dass alle, die gerade am Gespräch beteiligt sind, zu klein denken. Also, so wie du es jetzt meintest, also über Gewinnsteuer. Dazu kommt man politisch nicht, aber eigentlich wäre es schon viel zu wenig. Adam Tuls und Isabella Weber. So, das sind eigentlich die beiden Stimmen. Und hier gibt es noch abseits dieser ganzen, was so thematisiert wird, ich habe einmal kurz aus dem Heuterschanal zusammengetragen, in drei Clips, was diese Düngerproblematik angeht. Die Zahlen, die hier genannt werden, sind ja wirklich, also, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Auf den Flächen der Agrargenossenschaft Großmachno wird zurzeit die Wintergerste gedüngt. Sie braucht Nährstoffe. Das Frühjahr war kalt. Mineralischer Stickstoffdünger ist der Goldstaub der Landwirte. 800 Tonnen brauchen sie hier im Jahr. Seit dem Kriegsausbruch steigen die Düngerpreise.
Wer jetzt natürlich kaufen muss, der hat eine ganz unschöne Situation, weil es zusätzlich noch auf die Erzeugerpreise trifft, die seit letztem Jahr, seit der letzten Ernte sehr niedrig sind. Das heißt, die Gewinnmarge wird immer kleiner.
In Großmachno hatten sie Dünger schon letztes Jahr eingelagert. Von den aktuellen Preissteigerungen sind sie nicht betroffen.
Das ist derzeit, würde ich sagen. Jetzt, wenn hier, also das ist jetzt ein Betrieb, da braucht 800 Tonnen die globale Dimension.
Ungefähr die Hälfte der weltweiten Nahrungsmittelproduktion ist auf Mineraldünger angewiesen. Das betrifft dann insbesondere Getreide, Reis, aber auch Tierfutterproduktion. Und wenn dieser Mineraldünger jetzt ausfällt, wenn der Krieg sich noch lange hinzieht, dann führt das bei uns zu steigenden Preisen und in ärmeren Ländern dann wahrscheinlich auch zu Hunger.
Ja, wir haben also, und das betrifft ja diese Agrardünger insbesondere, sowohl eine Energiekrise als auch die noch so eine Materialgrundlagen-Rohstoff-Krise.
Und zugleich haben wir ja wieder das eigentliche Ziel bei der Entwicklungshilfe unterschritten. Auch in diesem Jahr wieder.
Also das ist wirklich brutal und da ich ja großer Froster-Fan bin, gucken wir noch diesen einen Clip. Froster hat so ein bisschen versucht, vorzusorgen.
Bis 2030 will Vorstandschef Ahlers den gesamten Strombedarf selbst erzeugen. Ein Ziel, das er auch der Umwelt zuliebe verfolgt, aber nicht nur.
Bei der enormen Energiekosten durch den Golfkrieg ist das natürlich umso richtiger. Das war ja nicht vorhersehbar, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es solche Energiekrisen auch in der Zukunft noch geben wird. Und dann fühlt man sich einfach besser, wenn man unabhängig ist.
Die wachsende Unabhängigkeit vom Strompreis hilft Felix Ahlers in der jetzigen Lage aber nur bedingt. Zwar steigt der Umsatz mit Tiefkühlgerichten, gleichzeitig wächst aber auch die Unsicherheit. Die Auswirkungen einer Weltpolitik a la Trump, also gestörte Lieferketten und Handelsrouten, spürt man auch bei Frosta.
Die Düngemittelpreise sind deutlich gestiegen. Und gerade jetzt, wo die Felder gesät werden und auch Düngung gebraucht wird, ist es natürlich ein sehr ungünstiger Moment. Und das wird sich natürlich in irgendeiner Weise auch auf die Kosten und Preise auswirken.
So, typischerweise leben wir ja, haben wir gelernt, in einer Ökonomie, in der Unternehmer alles outsourcen. Die Sauberkeit in Räumen wird dann in irgendwelche Subunternehmer ausgelagert. Geräte werden sowieso gekauft und nicht selber hergestellt. Dass jetzt Nahrungsmittelproduzenten anfangen, ihre eigene Energie herzustellen, weil es der Staat nicht hinbekommt, denen das ordnungspolitisch oder wie auch immer zu organisieren, finde ich wirklich, also klar, hat sich das andere Lager, ja, hat irgendwie gesagt, Marktwirtschaft ist toll und so, ist moralisch komplett überlegen, aber es funktioniert ja gar nicht.
Ja.
Die machen ja nicht mal Marktwirtschaft.
Und Unternehmer sagen sich, die können nicht planen, also planen wir.
Ja.
Ja. Während die Bundesregierung jetzt gerade nochmal Ordnoliberalismus durchspielt und sagt, wir müssen jetzt nochmal gucken, ob wir mit irgendwelchen anreizen oder mal schauen, wir dürfen jetzt gar nicht zu viel ins Markteschein eingreifen. Und wenn man es dann macht, dann macht man es ja auch tatsächlich verkehrt oder macht so Unsensgesetze wie Tankstellen nur einmal am Tag Benzin preis erhöhen.
Ja, genau.
So und dazu zwei Clips. Ich konnte es gar nicht glauben, bevor wir gleich zu deinem zweiten großen Thema kommen. Energie. So, die Katharina Reiche macht ganz schön viel Blödsinn. Wir greifen uns jetzt nur einen dieser Punkte mal raus. Wir hatten diese Spiegelberichterstattung zum Thema. Sie fragt nochmal bei den Gas-, äh, wie heißen sie? Kraftwerkbetreibern an, wie jetzt die Argumentation dafür laufen soll, dass man nicht im Batteriespeicher geht für Spitzenzeiten, indem man mal kurz einen Zuschuss an Energie braucht. Ich habe im Mikroökonom-Podcast nicht schlecht gestaunt, aber es scheint wirklich schlimm, schlimm, schlimm zu sein. Denn es wäre das eine zu sagen, die Politik organisiert das nicht richtig, weil der Markt könnte es ja auch alleine organisieren. Aber noch den Markt bei der Selbstorganisation zu torpedieren, also da wird es wirklich grotesk, ja. Wir haben sozusagen eine Bundesregierung, die gegen ihre eigenen fundamentalen ideologischen Überzeugungen handelt, um particulare Interessen. Das ist natürlich auch ein Vorzug der CDU, dass man nur mit jemandem Freund sein muss und dann wird man da gefördert und so. Aber das ist wirklich grotesk. Also hier wird das mal kurz bei den Mikroökonomen durchdiskutiert.
Und jetzt könnte man sich noch fragen, warum will Katharina Reichedeck keine Batteriespeicher? Na, obwohl sie sich ja eigentlich von alleine rechnen. Du stellst die Digger auf, du brauchst Netzanschluss, billig Strom rein, 10, 15 Cent teurer zum höchsten Strompreis des Tages wieder raus und der Steuerzahler muss keinen Cent dazu geben. Das ist Fakt. Die Investoren sitzen da, die wollen die Digger bauen und die brauchen nur eine Anschlussgenehmigung.
Nur die Anschlussgenehmigung muss die Politik geben. Alles andere. Da muss nichts gefördert werden. Das ist alles fertig. Es geht nur um die Anschlussgenehmigung ans Netz.
Dann bauen die die und fangen dann an, Geld zu verdienen. Das Problem für die Batteriespeicher ist genau das, sie verhindern, dass die Gaskraftwerke angehen. Denn die Gaskraftwerke waren bisher immer die Kraftwerke, die in den schwitzen Zeiten angegangen sind.
Punkt. Das ist die Politik der Bundesregierung. Einen funktionierenden Markt Schachmatt zu setzen durch eine politische Entscheidung.
Mich wundert es immer noch, dass überhaupt der CDU nach Wirtschaftskompetenz auch auf dieser Ebene zugeschrieben wird. Wir haben das ja auf der anderen sozialpolitischen Sache und so, das ist völlig klar. Das war ja immer so, aber dass man jetzt genau hier ein solch irrwitziges Handeln hat, dass wir Autokonzern, Chefs hören, die darüber klagen, dass jetzt die Bundesregierung schon wieder das Verbrenner austrotteltiert. Das ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass wir solche klagen können. Dass hier Märkte, die entstehen könnten, abgewirkt werden durch bürokratische Hürden, die man baut, wo man sich die ganze Zeit auf die Fahnen schreibt, wir entbürokratisieren. Das ist fast nicht mehr, man greift es nicht, beziehungsweise man fragt sich, welche Partikularinteressen sollen es überhaupt noch sein?
Genau, so, das wissen wir. Das sind die der Gasfabrikbetreiber.
Ja, aber wie machtvoll sollen die schon sein?
Also sie haben auf jeden Fall sehr viel Geld. Hier ist einer, Christian Küchen. Er ist, kann ich raussuchen, sage ich euch gleich, aber es gibt einen Fuel & Energy-Verband, irgendwas und so, er ist eine Chefe. Er ist im Deutschlandfingernut Interview zu Gast und wird gefragt, machen sie nicht gerade ein paar viel Gewinne und so?
Sprechen wir mal auch über die Übergewinnsteuer. Die wird ja auch diskutiert, also, dass Mineralölkonzerne auf übermäßig hohe Gewinne mehr Steuern zahlen müssten.
Fuels & Energy e.V.
Das wünschte sich die SPD, Wirtschaftsministerin Reiche CDU blockte ab und der Kanzler sagte auch nur, wage mal sehen. Haben Sie sich schon bei Katharina Reiche dafür bedankt?
Das habe ich nicht, aber wir haben natürlich eine grundsätzliche Einschätzung dazu. Und zum einen gibt es eine ganz klar rechtliche.
Wie wird wohl die grundsätzliche Einschätzung dazu sein?
Fragestellung, was eigentlich Übergewinne sind. Es gibt auch keine Entschädigungen für Untergewinne oder Verluste. Gewinne werden besteuert und wer mehr Gewinne macht, zahlt höhere Steuern. Und Unternehmenssteuern sind im internationalen Vergleich vergleichsweise hoch. Insofern muss man schon erstmal diese Frage klären, was das eigentlich ist und der zweite viel wichtiger Punkt ist, das Geschäft ist enorm volatil und damit man Achtung, jetzt kommt sein Argument, warum man das ganze Geld braucht. Versorgung auch in Zeiten wie jetzt auf welche halten kann, wo es extrem herausfordernd ist, müssen auch mal Gewinne gemacht werden können, die dann entsprechend versteuert werden. Ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt ist, und ich glaube, das ist, das müssen wir langfristig im Blick behalten.
Das heißt, das ist eine Querfinanzierung wie bei einem Verlag. Wir machen drei Bücher mit Sebastian Ficek und dafür verlegen wir dann auch fünf, nicht so gutgehende, aber literarisch wertvolle.
Wir müssen ja noch investieren. Was eigentlich? Also die Batterien kommen ja von jemand anderem. Das ist ja deren Problem. Das ist wirklich grotesk, was wir hier erleben. Die Bundesregierung macht Antipolitik.
Vor allem hat man ja dann auch bei der Bundesregierung irgendeine Einnahmequelle haben wollen und dann erhöht man die Tabaksteuer. Und dann sagt sie, ja, damit machen wir es jetzt.
Das werden die Milliarden und Milliarden reinspülen. Ja, ja.
Kommen wir nach Ungarn. Auch da bin ich einigermaßen verwirrt, was da passiert ist. Erstmal kann man sich ja freuen. Viktor Orban ist weg. Das sollten wir bei all dem nicht vergessen, dass man sich darüber kurz freuen kann. Aber dann muss man es vielleicht doch ein bisschen differenzierter einordnen, differenzierter beispielsweise als der Booktalker Samuel Benke, der sich folgendermaßen zu Ungarn bei Instagram geäußert hat. Wir fangen sehr niedrig an, was das Nibuan anbelangt.
Ich finde diese ganze oder gar nicht Haltung von vielen Linken in meinen Kommentarspalten, besonders wenn es um Ungarn geht, so wahnsinnig frustrierend. Ja, Mordjör ist kein linker Kandidat, das ist klar. Er ist wahrscheinlich auch aus unserer Sicht ziemlich konservativ. Aber in Ungarn wird er auf jeden Fall in Richtung Europaschauen, in Richtung Demokratieschauen. Er hat schon angekündigt, queere Menschen will er nicht verfolgen. Das ist schon mal super. Rechtsstaatlichkeit, keine Korruption mehr. Die Leute können frei sagen, was sie wollen. Das Land kann sich wieder mehr anschließen an Europa. Und das ist ja schon mal ein großer Fortschritt, also zu sagen, das Leben von vielen ungarischen Menschen wird wahrscheinlich dadurch dramatisch besser. Die freuen sich. Können wir uns auch freuen? Ich finde schon. Können wir noch für mehr hoffen? Klar. Aber so eine Aufgeberhaltung, ja, es ist kein perfekter linker Kandidat und deswegen interessiert mich das Ganze nicht, das finde ich irgendwie schade.
Ich kenne diese Aufgeberhaltung gar nicht. Ich finde, auch hier wird mit den Papstkameraden gearbeitet. Es ist aber auch das Zeichen einer generellen Bewegung nach rechts, dass man jetzt einen ehemaligen Fidesch-Politiker, der mit nahen Mannparteis geschafft hat, nach vorne zu kommen, plötzlich als die Rettung der Demokratie betrachtet. Wir werden das jetzt mal Stück für Stück uns genauer ansehen. Wie ist eigentlich dieser neue Peter Maja? Ich glaube, ich spreche das falsch aus.
Peter der Ungar.
Peter der Ungar, richtig. Wie ist er so groß geworden? Also erst mal, wie schon gesagt, stammt er selbst aus der Fidesch-Partei, hat da lange Zeit Karriere gemacht an der Seite seiner Frau, die Justizministerin war. Oliver Soos vom Deutschlandfunk sagt dazu.
Das Interessante dabei, Peter Modja kommt selbst aus der Fidesch-Partei.
Er war mal Fidesch-Beamter und Diplomat für das ungarische Außenministerium in Brüssel. Vor gut zwei Jahren wurde er über Nacht berühmt durch dieses Video-Interview für die unabhängige ungarische Online-Plattform Partisan.
Da erklärte Peter Modja, dass er aus der Fidesch-Partei aussteigt.
Ich war sehr lange Mitglied im Fidesch-Zirkel.
Bis jetzt konnte ich aber nichts sagen, weil meine Frau noch Teil des Systems war und zur Wahl stand. Partisan, müssen wir uns schon mal merken, ist ein YouTube-Kanal, ein ungarischer, also ein journalistisches Format auf YouTube. Dazu kommen wir aber nachher nochmal. Bei der Asylpolitik von Orban und heute und jetzt dann von Peter Modja wird man keinen Unterschied merken können. Orbans strikte Asylpolitik wolle er nicht groß verändern. Wenn man sich auch Interviews ansieht mit Modja, es gibt ein paar auf Englisch, dann wird das auch so bestätigt. Oliver Soos sagt, der Erfolg rührt auch daher, dass Modja so unglaublich viel unterwegs war. Ich habe auch Artikel gelesen, denen es hieß, dass er bis zu acht Auftritte, Wahlkampfauftritte am Tag absolvierte und Reden schwang. Peter Modja zog durch hunderte Städte und Dörfer, erhielt Reden auf Marktplätzen und überzeugte die Menschen von seiner neuen Teaser-Bewegung. Ja. So, wenn wir uns dem Ganzen jetzt mal anders nähern, dann müssen wir erst mal schauen, wie ist denn dieser Politikstil zu charakterisieren? Da habe ich einen Podcast gefunden, der heißt der Pragmaticus Podcast. Das ist ein österreichisches Format. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Genaupolitiker stehen. Habe mich auch gar nicht so interessiert. Da war aber eine Politologin zu Gast von der Universität, ich glaube in Wien, Esther Kovacs. Und die versucht es ein bisschen einzuordnen.
Was für ein Politiker er ist. Also er hat sehr gute politische Instinkte. Für das stellt ihm ständig Fallen, um seine sehr breit aufgestellte Wählerschaft zu spalten. Er kann damit sehr gut umgehen. In seiner Kommunikation folgt er ein bisschen. Er hat den Traum, dass er die Medien umgeht. Wenn er irgendetwas mit ihnen zu tun hat und haben muss, dann ist er da nicht besonders höflich, sondern eher aggressiv. Aber er kann direkt kommunizieren.
Sorry, dass er die Medien umgeht. Die Medien umgehen ihn.
Zum einen das, zum anderen hat er mit der ausländischen Presse kaum gesprochen, weil er sagte, ich konzentriere mich jetzt ganz auf die Ungarn. Und er hat auch gemerkt, es ist eigentlich viel sinnvoller, wenn er selbst Medien macht, und zwar über die sozialen Medien. Dazu kommen wir gleich. Und ja, es ist natürlich so, dass die Opposition im Staatsfernsehen, im Ungarischen, nicht mehr vorkam. Da gibt es wirklich groteske Zahlen. Da weiß man dann von der Wahl davor. Der Gegenkandidat kam während des gesamten Wahlkampfes acht Minuten vor und der Rest dann gar nicht. Wir sehen, dass da Orban natürlich alles plattgemacht hat.
Die Wahllokale waren ja bis 19 Uhr offen. Dann haben die so eine 20 Uhr Tagesschau oder so, aber machen keine Exit-Polls. Aber es gab schon so, ja, geht vielleicht nicht so gut aus für, weil dann grotesk, wie krass es nicht gut für Orban ausging. Und im Fernsehpodcast haben sie, oder im Heutzinal, wir haben es im Fernsehpodcast gehört, haben sie einen Ausschnitt gezeigt, wie an dem Abend die Nachrichten beginnen und das erste Thema nicht die Wahl ist. Ja. Das kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen.
Warum auch? Ja, welchen Vorteil hat Morocha, Kubacz sagt?
Er kann mit seiner Bekehrungsgeschichte auch punkten. Also, dass er die Wähler entschuldigt oder Absolution verteilt. So Leute, ich habe auch zu spät eingesehen, wie korrupt und wie schrecklich das Orban-Regime ist. Man kann auch zu spät aufwachen. Also bitte, wacht auf.
Das sollten wir uns jetzt merken für die Republikaner in den USA, dass da sich sehr gut jemand lösen kann, noch ein bisschen früh, vielleicht noch so fünf Monate warten, auch gucken, ob es noch desaströser wird mit Trump und dem Iran. Und dann sagen Leute, ich habe mich da schrecklich geirrt, ich habe genauso wie ihr vertraut in Donald Trump, aber...
Das ist ein ganz großes Thema bei dem Herrn Hegemon, wie diese Erlaubnisstruktur ist. Also, wann man wem rechtfertigen muss in dem Gespräch. Nee, Peter hat es auch gemacht und so. Und jetzt haben wir ja schon Taka Karlsen, also du hast es schon angesprochen. Das sind die interessanten Knackpunkte, da wo jemand wirklich all in geht und sagt, ich reise jetzt eine Brücke ab, aber nur um den Weg weiterzugehen und werde dann einschwenken.
Ja, aber den Weg weitergehen. Also das ist jetzt wichtig, wenn wir darüber reden, dass wenn ich sage, ah, jetzt wird alles anders. Also die parlamentarische Situation in Ungarn sieht ja so aus, dass wir jetzt Fidesz haben, dann haben wir die Partei von Maozsa, dann haben wir noch eine Neonazi-Partei und das war's. Das heißt, alle linken Kräfte sind zusammengeschrumpft auf ein paar Prozent.
Ja, wir müssen aber kurz zu Ungarn sagen, altenrepublikanisch, kein Land hat mehr Bevölkerung verloren, kein Land weltweit hat ein krasseres Wirtschafts-, also Einbruch, acht Prozent pro Jahr und so, geht einfach die Wirtschaft zurück. Das sind einfach, also hier kann man jetzt unendlich viel, was Leute sagen, wie die so drauf sind, was die Vereinstellungen haben und so, ne. Aber hier reißt einfach so ein Dämon-Demografie wirklich eine Stimmung mit.
Ja, zu dem wirtschaftlichen kommen wir gleich nochmal kurz, denn es ist auch das Thema für Moja in seinem Wahlkampf gewesen. Wir hören aber jetzt erstmal kurz in das SWR-Forum, da wurde auch über Ungarn diskutiert. Ich bringe aber jetzt nicht die Stimmen, die jetzt nochmal zeigen, wie dieses Orban-Regime funktioniert und so was, sondern ich bringe jetzt jemanden hier, der in der FDP ist, aber so das rechte Lager bildet, das eine Brücke bauen will zur Werteunion und so was. Der ist also Vorsitzender der Deutschen-Ungarischen Gesellschaft, heißt Gerhard Papke. Der findet Orban gar nicht so schlecht, können wir uns denken, oder findet Orban gut. Wir hören uns aber jetzt erst mal an, wie der Mordja charakterisiert. Man sollte hier erwähnen, in Ungarn weiß das jeder, dass Mordja damals, bevor er Tissa übernahm, ein Gespräch mit seiner früheren Ehefrau Judith Waager heimlich aufgezeichnet hat, weil er meinte, damit Beweise für die angebliche Korruption der Regierung Orban sammeln zu können. Also da muss ich das mal vorstellen, jemand, der heimlich ein persönliches Gespräch mit seiner ehemaligen Ehefrau aufzeichnet und das dann veröffentlicht.
Also mit Verlaub, ein Politiker, der so etwas in Deutschland gemacht hätte, dessen politische Laufbahn wäre sofort beendet gewesen.
Stimmt, aber er kann dadurch natürlich noch viel authentischer jetzt sagen, ich bin ja einer, der alles aufgedeckt hat.
Die Leute wollen Authentizität und es ist ein unschlagbarer Move.
Das ist populistisch selbstverständlich, aber genauso funktioniert das da. Richtig, dass er es anspricht, lässt den auch in einem komischen Licht erscheinen. Interessant war ja auch, dass die Orban-Regierung immer wieder versuchte, Kampagne gegen Monschall zu machen mit irgendwelchen Sexgeschichten, wo er dann ja ganz offensiv damit umgegangen ist, ich bin ja ein Mann von Mitte 40, natürlich habe ich Sex und so. So geht es so nicht, also nicht in dieser Weise, aber er sagt, ich lasse mich davon doch jetzt nicht hier küttern, weil er natürlich auch ein Publikum vor sich hat, und sagt, naja, unser Kandidat hat noch Sex. Immerhin, das kann man nicht von ihr rauben. Ich habe einen Artikel bei Guardian gelesen, da geht es dann um die Frage, warum konnte jetzt Mosher gewinnen? Und dann kommt natürlich Korruption, Armut eklatant gestiegen, Infrastruktur desolat, alltägliche Realität immer bitterer. Man muss ja sagen, als Orbán übernahm mit der Finanzkrise 2008, hat sich ja erst einmal auf vieles gebessert in Ungarn. Es war ja jetzt nicht eine direkt Abstiegsgeschichte ökonomisch gesehen, aber dann dieser Selbstbereicherungsladen, der es wurde und die ganzen politischen Fehlentscheidungen und da auch, dass man Geld aus der EU nicht bekommen hat, hat die Situation schwierig gemacht. Aber, sehr interessant, Tibor Desefie schreibt das, politische Analysen vermeiden oft physische Erklärungen. Doch der Kontrast war auffällig. Orban, einst ein Meister des Wahlkampfs, wirkte zurückhaltend und vorsichtig. Er beschränkte sich oft auf eine einzige kontrollierte Veranstaltung pro Tag. Im Gegensatz dazu agierte Morscher mit politischer Hyperaktivität. Er schaffte 7 oder 8 Auftritte pro Tag und war online wie offline intensiv präsent. Während Orban versuchte, sich an die Logik der sozialen Medien anzupassen, bewegte sich Morscher darin wie ein Muttersprachler. Kommen wir jetzt gleich noch dazu, was das bedeutet in den sozialen Medien. Die Anhänger sahen eine Wahl zwischen einer routinierten Großvaterfigur und einem jungen, energiegeladenen Herausforderer. So muss man es betrachten. Jetzt gehen wir aber nochmal zu diesem SWR-Forum zurück. Hören wir uns jetzt mal an, wie ein rechter FDPler über Orban und sein Verhältnis zu Europa spricht. Die Frage, die ich darüber schreibe, ist, ist hier Gerhard Papke aus der Zeit gefallen? Und ist vielleicht auch Victor Orban einfach aus der Zeit gefallen? Ja, und das hängt natürlich damit zusammen, dass Orban und seine Regierung für Positionen stehen, auch für Werke, die der, ich darf das mal so deutlich sagen, der politischen Linken in Westeuropa zutiefst zuwider sind. Orban ist der Bannerträger, der Leuchttum für eine selbstbestimmte nationale Politik im Rahmen der Europäischen Union. Das ungarische Volk vertritt zugegebenermaßen konservative Positionen, etwa in der Familienpolitik, die vielen Linken in Europa und auch in Deutschland zutiefst zuwider sind. Hier wird es noch mal gesagt, links, links, links. Was ja bei Rechten immer noch präsent ist, ist zu sagen, die EU ist eigentlich eine linke Konstruktion. Wir würden aber sagen, die EU bewegt sich ja immer mehr nach rechts. Und das sehen wir nicht nur in der Migrationsfrage. Hier wird aber so getan, als sei Orban jetzt mit seinem Kampf gegen die EU einer, der gegen linke Politik kämpft. Dabei sehen wir ja, gibt es ja gar nicht die linke Mehrheit in der EU. Das ist ja Unsinn. Er sagt dann weiter, Möchte ich gerne nochmal auch die Behauptung einordnen, die Regierung Orban sei anti-europäisch. Also aus Sicht der Brüsseler Institutionen, insbesondere der politischen Linken, die ja wesentlich das Bild der europäischen Institutionen prägen. Von der Leyen ist dann offenbar links.
Gilt alles als anti-europäisch, was sich gegen den zunehmenden Brüsseler Zentralismus richtet.
Ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen, dass die Ungarn in überwältigender Mehrheit Anhänger der Europäischen Union sind. So, diese Unterscheidung, die hier gemacht wird, ist Zentralismus, links Brüssel, auf der anderen Seite europafreundlich, Ungarn, aber selbstständig. Was dann auch dazu führt, dass er sagt...
Aber die Ungarn wollen ein Europa der Vaterländer, der selbstbestimmten Nationen, die wollen sich nicht von Brüssel diktieren lassen, wie sie ihre Kinder zu erziehen haben.
Und das ist ein Impuls, der, glaube ich, aus Ungarn auch in andere Länder der Europäischen Union momentan geht.
Eine Diskussion, die uns auch in Deutschland erreichen wird, früher oder später. Die Anfänge kann man schon erkennen. Und ich glaube, dass das aus der Sicht, und das sind sicherlich alle überzeugte Europäer, dass das aus der Sicht Europas mit Blick auf die Frage, wie können wir Europa im weltpolitischen Zusammenhang wieder stärken, eine wichtige Debatte ist. Ich glaube, dass wir die Europäische Union wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße stellen müssen. Er verfehlt hier etwas ganz Entscheidendes. Also zum einen, denkt mal näher, da hat er ja einen Punkt getroffen, wenn er sagt, es geht um diese Selbstständigkeit der Staaten. Wie weit kann man sich also einem Zentralismus unterordnen? Das ist ja ein Konflikt, der für alle Länder gilt. Und das wird ja auch gerade in Deutschland immer dann gut gespielt, dass man dann doch das letzte Wort bei vielen Sachen haben will. Was aber überhaupt nicht mehr zutrifft, diese Diagnose, ich habe hier den Eindruck, ich höre Clips von 2016 oder so, ist ja, dass so getan wird, als hätte man linke Technokraten, die unsere Freiheit beschneiden, weshalb wir dagegen kämpfen müssen. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, die Freiheit ist natürlich auch eine, die man dann immer mehr abgibt. Je mehr man europäische Institutionen stärkt, das ist nochmal eine Debatte, die wollen wir zum Schluss aufmachen. Aber eines scheint mir doch völlig verfehlt zu sein, dass so getan wird, als sei die EU ein linkes Projekt. Ich würde sagen, wir erleben jetzt mehr und mehr, wie die EU zu einem rechten Projekt wird, weshalb sich ja auch eine Meloni Pudelwohl darin fühlt. Kannst du dich noch an einen Artikel erinnern?
Die große Angst vor Meloni.
Die Postfaschistin haben wir in den letzten Monaten, letzten zwei Jahren nichts mehr zugelesen zu diesem Thema. Marin Le Pen wird auch kein Problem mit einer rechten EU haben. Wir haben jetzt gerade von der Tagesschau recherchiert, herausgefunden, dass die EVP, also die Konservativen, zu denen ja die CDU z.B. dann zählt auf Europaebene, mit der AfD eine WhatsApp-Gruppe betrieben hat. Da heißt es bei tagesschau.de, die Fraktionen von CDU und CSU im Europaparlament kooperiert, eine Berichtsschrift zufolge deutlich enger mit der AfD und anderen rechten Parteien als bislang bekannt. Nach Recherchen der Nachrichtenagentur DPA arbeitete die EVP jüngst gemeinsam mit dem rechten Flügel in einer Chatgruppe und bei einem persönlichen Treffen von Abgeordneten an einem Gesetzesvorschlag zur Verschärfung der Migrationspolitik. Wir haben eben schon gehört, Monja sagte auch, Migrationspolitik, wie Orban sie betrieben hat. Richtig. Das geplante Gesetz soll unter anderem die Abschiebung von Asylsuchenden in sogenannte Return Hubs in Staaten außerhalb der EU ermöglichen. So.
Alles beschlossen mittlerweile?
Wir sehen also, aha, es gibt ein großes rechtes Projekt, EU, was auch bedeuten kann, imperiale Ansprüche gelten zu machen. Im Zuge von die Huttis in die Steinzeit zurückbomben und so. Wir hatten ja die Clips hier schon gespielt. Wissen wir, wohin da die Reise geht.
Ja, lass mich mal kurz einen Gedanken einwerfen. Denn man hört ja, du stellst vor allem Rätsel in den Raum. Wie kann das sein, dass jemand vermutet, da ist eine linke Macht, gegen die man kämpfen muss, wie auch immer. Braucht nicht gerade in Ungarn der neue Präsident Einwanderung. Also will man wirklich auf Wirtschaft ganz verzichten, wie auch immer. Die Leute machen sich Sorgen um ihre Kindererziehung. Das hat ja alles eins gemeinsam. Wir können es nicht so richtig greifen. Wovon reden die? Was meinen die? Und so. Und dein Lieblingsrezenzent im Deutschlandfunk, Schniederjahn. Wer ist der mit dem Vornamen?
Nils.
Nils Schniederjahn hat im Deutschlandfunk-Andruck ein Buch besprochen und zwar von Eva von Redeker. Das Buch heißt Dieser Drang nach Härte.
Ja.
Und in dieser Besprechung, ich habe nur den gesamten sechs Minuten Clip, deswegen referiere ich nur kurz, wird ein neues, ein neuer Grundbegriff gelegt, der natürlich bei mir total auf Sympathie fällt, weil er in so einer Hegemon, was ist denn das? Überbande, Einflugschneise, was soll der Quatsch und so. Wir gehen im Mai auch mit Texten grundsätzlich darauf ein. Das, was die Rechten hier verteidigen, ist Phantombesitz. Ein sehr merkwürdiger Begriff, der aber, finde ich, alles beschreibt. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen, aber ich finde ihn jetzt schon überzeugender. Phantombesitz. Es ist also eine Vorstellung von, man hat eine Angst über Bande. Wenn das nicht glät, dann verliere ich meine Kinder an, was ja, was auch immer. Phantome halt. Und genau so wird natürlich auch der Gegner aufgebaut. Es gibt keine linke Mehrheit. Und du machst natürlich einen wackeren Kampf. Aber ob wir es jetzt noch einmal oder noch zehnmal sagen, die EU ist ja gar kein linkes Projekt. Jaja, das klärt nur niemanden auf. Denn der Hinweis lautet einfach, es ist halt eine Phantomdebatte. Die dreht sich ganz konkret und sehr materiell und sehr politisch um einen Phantom. Das gibt es also gar nicht. Nur in der Vorstellung.
Was dann aber bedeutet für die andere Seite, dass sie auf dieses Phantom jetzt auch nicht hereinfallen darf. Das heißt, wir haben ja von grün-linken Sozialdemokraten oft die Sicht, ja fast auch so, als sei die EU kurz davor, das linksprogressive Projekt zu werten, von dem wir alle schon immer geträumt haben. Und das ist aber nicht der Fall. Man übersieht nämlich dann die Austeritätspolitik, die ja jetzt wieder verschärft werden soll. Wir sehen Ursula von der Leyen, die sagt, ja, denk doch mal in Deutschland wieder über Atomkraft nach. Wir sehen Verschuldung wird zugelassen, aber bitte nur für die Aufrüstung.
Also, wenn ihr schafft, droht, aus der NATO auszusteigen, ist für alle dort großes Fest.
Genau. Und das ist immer dann aber ein Europa, das nicht ein linkes Projekt ist, Meinungsfreiheit einschränken. Also, ÖSIN, DOKU haben wir heute schon darüber gesprochen über diese Vollsanktionen. Social-Media-Verbote könnte man jetzt nochmal ansprechen. Der Green New Deal wird auf Eis gelegt, weil man dann plötzlich sagt, nee, jetzt doch nicht und außerdem nicht mit China und überhaupt die alternativen Medien verbreiten, die nicht alle Russen-Propaganda oder China-Propaganda. Das heißt, man muss jetzt auch, wenn die noch das Phantom mit sich tragen, muss man es selbst nicht noch mit sich tragen. Wir sagen ja genau, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt alles genauso unterstützen wegen der EU, weil ja hier so Leute wie Papke und Orban sich dagegen stellen.
Das ist unser Hinweis auch an die drei Frauen aus dem politischen Lager. Ganz richtig. Kein Phantom-Podcast.
Ja. Ja. Esther Kovacs sagt etwas Interessantes über den Wahlkampf von Morscha. Nämlich, er ist jemand, der diese Kulturkämpfe nicht betrieben hat.
Er führt nicht diese Kulturkämpfe. Also früher war es immer so, wenn Fidesz irgendeine Minderheit angegriffen hat oder die EU angegriffen hat, dann hat die alte Opposition die diametrische entgegengesetzte Position automatisch aufgenommen. Dann waren die Fronten klar und die Polarisierung klar und er geht nicht in diese Richtung und er redet einfach konsequent über Lebenserhaltungskosten, über den Zustand der Krankenhäuser, über die marode Infrastruktur, zum Wettbewerb, für die Bahn.
Sieh mal einer an.
Ja, woher kennen wir denn so Erfolgswahlkämpfe?
Nicht von Klingbeil.
Ja, das hat er gemacht. Und sie sagt auch, das zeigt ein Scheitern der Linken in Ungarn.
Und selbst wenn Journalisten ihn fragen, so was würden sie mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit machen? Was würden sie mit Pride machen? Dann sagt er, Leute, liebe Journalisten, komm bitte aus eurem liberalen Bubble heraus. Ich möchte mich einfach mit den Problemen beschäftigen, mit denen es die Menschen zu tun haben. Also es ist populistisch, aber auch ein sehr unangenehmer Spiegel an frühere linke und liberale Parteien, dass sie das nicht hingekriegt haben und dass diese Herausforderung von rechts kommen soll.
Im Kreisky Forum war unter anderem der Rechtswissenschaftler Adam Scholtern zu Gast. Der schreibt auch für den Verfassungsblog.
Er sagt, Und es ist auch wahr und auch wichtig, dass Peter Maja selbst, der ein Populist ist, der keine demokratische und politische Partei runnt, er runnt Populisten. Ich meine, seine Partei hat ungefähr 29 Mitglieder. Ich kann nicht als Mitglied seiner Partei werden.
29 Mitglieder. Wir erinnern uns auch hier an die Debatte um die Wagenknecht-Partei BSW, wo es auch nicht möglich war, so einfach Mitglied zu werden.
Oder Gerd Wilders.
Das heißt, das sind Prinzipien, die wir da wiederfinden können. Deswegen ist auch so eine Glorifizierung, die mitunter jetzt stattfindet, in liberalen Medien doch mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Es gibt keine demokratischen Wahlen in seiner Partei. Ich meine, es könnte sein, dass die 29 Leute in einem demokratischen Weg Entscheidungen machen. Aber es ist nicht so, als würde ein normaler Hungarian ein Mitglied der Partei werden. Es gibt keine demokratische Wahlen in seinem Bewegungsweg. Es ist ein Bewegungsweg, lediglich von einer einzelnen Person. Und diejenigen, die ihn unterstützen, können ein Teil der sogenannten Tisza-Islands sein und kreativ arbeiten.
Ich glaube, in Ungarn gibt es Publizisten, die so Ideen haben wie, komm, wir lassen einfach einen an die Macht, vier Jahre, ach komm, sieben, und dann macht er einfach sowieso ohne Parlament so Freischuss. Also so Chirach-Style.
Ja, ja, ja. Es geht sehr in diese Richtung. Scholtern sagt weiter.
Ich bin ein populistischer Mann, der eigentlich für persönliche Gründe den anderen Weg gegangen ist und als Kritiker des Regimes statt von der Normandklatur, die er bis zum Anfang 2024 war, als eine Opposition mehr effizient als jeder demokratischen Partei. Einer der größten Gründe für das ist, dass demokratische Parteien sich immer für einander kritisieren, weil sie demokratisch sind. Und sogar ihre Mitgliederkommission können ihre Leidenschaften kritisieren, was sehr kompliziert ist. Es ist ein konversierter Prozess, ein Demokrat zu sein. Er ist kein Demokrat, er führt einen populistischen Bewegungen. Es ist eine viel einfache Geschichte.
Was uns doch eigentlich zu der Frage führen sollte, wird hier mit Moja vielleicht einfach nur Orban minus Korruption minus Russland etabliert. Was bedeutet, der kommt bald gut mit Meloni und vielleicht auch mit Marine Le Pen und so raus. Und das Europa, die EU als rechtes Projekt ist jetzt gerade gestärkt worden.
Ja, also wir haben im Fernsehpodcast auch noch mal kurz an Orban erinnert. Der ist jetzt 63 oder so. Irgend so ein handlanger Typ aus seinem Team besitzt drei Milliarden. Alle vermuten, das ist eigentlich Orbans Geld.
Das ist so wie der Koch von Putin.
Mit 63 Jahren, du hast zwei Reisemöglichkeiten. Das eine ist in Brüssel, alle moppen dich rum und so. Oder auf irgendeiner Insel mit 70 Jungfrauen.
Will ja jetzt nach USA, Orbán, erstmal.
Also, welche Reiseroute nimmt man? Also, Orbán wurde jetzt nicht geköpft oder sowas, ja? Der wurde einfach, und alle sind zufrieden und keiner schaut auch noch nicht mehr, was ist denn da jetzt noch? Sondern der ist einfach in Rente gegangen.
Und ich muss sagen, wir kommen jetzt gleich mal auf diese Frage der elektoralen und liberalen Demokratie. Ich bin doch einigermaßen verwirrt, weil ich natürlich um diese Zustände in Ungarn weiß, wie da die Medien gleich geschaltet wurden. Das Wort fällt einem dazu ja gar nicht ein. Und wie dort natürlich ganz viele Rechte beschnitten wurden. Aber einerseits ist es ja dann schon bemerkenswert, dass mitunter das Bild von einer Diktatur gezeichnet wurde, einer Quasidiktatur. Und dann hat man hier eine Wahl. Und wenn 70 Prozent der Stimmen ausgezählt sind, sagt Orbán schon, dass er verloren hat. Ohne irgendeine Friktion findet das statt. Das heißt, dann frage ich mich, war die Demokratie jetzt so ineffektiv oder funktioniert sie vielleicht sehr gut?
Na, für Orbán hat sie sehr gut funktioniert. Ich würde mich auch für die Rente entscheiden.
Ja, nur sehen wir ja dann, okay, es ist also möglich, ein Orbán-System zu stürzen, weil ja auch sehr viele Stimmen zu hören waren vor der Wahl, die so sagten, naja, vielleicht wird er das gar nicht akzeptieren und da gibt es gar keine Chance und so weiter. Aber das sehen wir offenbar schon. Was einem ja auch Hoffnung geben kann, dass man es vielleicht nicht alles immer so schwarz sehen muss, im Sinne von die unterwandern alles, wie wir das eben auch wieder gehört haben, die unterwandern alles und dann ist Ende mit der Demokratie. Es gibt dann auch einfach Wahlen und dann wird man abgewählt.
Also was diese Amtsträger ja vor allem in diese Not treibt, unbedingt am Amt bleiben zu müssen, sind ja die großen drohenden Gerichtsverfahren. Trump, Netanyahu und so weiter. Das ist ja bei Orbán nicht.
Das nicht, ja.
Und das macht halt einen Unterschied. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich sage, bitte nicht juristisch verfolgen, sondern wie man als Ministerpräsident eines nicht sehr großen ungarischen Landes innerhalb von 16 Jahren drei Milliarden anhäufen kann, würde ich noch mal, also würde ich eine Prüfdemo erst mal machen, ja.
Vielleicht.
Aber irgendwie kommt er ja fein raus da jetzt. Alle sind zufrieden, dass jetzt einfach der nächste Fidesz-Typ kommt.
Morczak war ja schon recht erfolgreich bei der Wahl zum Europaparlament. Da hat er ja schon 30 Prozent oder so der Stimmen gehabt. Das heißt, er war ordentlich im Parlament vertreten oder ist ordentlich mit seiner Thesis-Partei vertreten und war dann ja auch Teil von der EVP. Das heißt also der Gruppe, in der die CDU-Leute zusammen sind, unter anderem Konservative, aber Orban ja nicht mehr, soweit ich weiß. Der ja dann sich dann losgemacht hat und sagte, genau, Orban machte sich los und sagte, das mache ich nicht mit euren Ukrainekurs und so weiter.
Und der Reber musste sehr huffiert werden, damit so was kommt.
Damit man mal irgendwann doch mal zu meistern.
Damit es nur noch WhatsApp-Gruppen sind.
So jetzt, Morjah ist jetzt in der EVP mit seiner Partei auf EU-Ebene. Jetzt haben wir ja schon von der ganzen Berichterstattung gehört, der ist jetzt nicht mehr jemand, der die Ukraine-Hilfen streichen will, sondern der ist ja quasi der Antipode von Orban. Hier sagt aber dein Adam Scholtern ja auch nochmal was Interessantes, nämlich, dass hier während des Wahlkampfes jetzt und auf Europaebene Morjah gegen die 90 Milliarden gestimmt hat, auf EU-Ebene erst.
Und das ist, warum sie in Brüssel so behalten, wie sie so behalten. Denn was sie tun, ist, dass sie keine Prinzipien oder Ideologie wirklich folgen. Sie versuchen, sich zu fühlen und versuchen, sich zu messen, ich meine, durch die Opinion, was die Wahlkampfwahl sie tun erwartet. Die 90-Billionen-EU-Lohn in der Ukraine. Sie waren der einzige Mitgliedspartei der EPP, der Europäischen Menschenpartei, die die Wahlkampfwahl gewählt hat. Sie haben die Wahlkampfwahl gewählt, weil sie merken, dass die meisten, oder die größte Teil der hongarischen Wahlkampfwahl sie erwarten, so zu machen.
Das wurde ihnen aber nicht von der EU jetzt vorgeworfen, interessanterweise. Sonst könnte man ja sagen, aha, Orban will kein Geld an die Ukraine geben, Morjah ja offenbar auch nicht, sonst hätte er nicht als einziger in der EVP dagegen gestimmt.
Weißt du, wie sie es gelöst haben, dass die 90-Mailern jetzt fließen?
Das komm mir jetzt gleich zu, das darfst du noch nicht verraten, das ist so wunderbar. Jedenfalls war damit aber offenbar eine Verabredung zwischen Morjah und der EU, ihr skandalisiert das nicht, ich mache das aber jetzt gerade mal so, weil ich ja diese Wahl gewinnen muss. Wenn ich jetzt dazu stimme, gewinn ich die Wahl nicht, dann habt ihr wieder den Orban am Bein. Jetzt wissen wir, Ursula von der Leyen, wir haben sie eben schon gehört, hat diese 90 Milliarden jetzt losgeschickt. Also es geht ja darum, Kredite und über zwei, drei Jahre verteilt, wie dem auch sei. Zunächst hören wir da, dass angeschlossen wurde ja auch ein Sanktionspaket. Wir haben wieder ein Sanktionspaket gegen Russland, das 20. Man kommt ja nur mittlerweile durcheinander. Ja, Öl ist schon das gute Stichwort dazu. Wir hören uns das jetzt erst mal an. Ich meine, das ist ja eh eine völlig paradoxe Situation mit den Sanktionen. Also ich bin ja nicht derjenige gewesen, der anfangs sagte, jetzt alles auf Null fahren, weil ich auch wusste, dass das ein zu großes wirtschaftliches Fiasco werden würde. Aber dass man 20 Pakete braucht, um irgendwelche Dinge zu machen. Also wenn ich diesmal treffe ich dich mal ganz hart. Aber in fünf Monaten nochmal härter.
Ich glaube, wir würden Champions League so machen. Hinspiel, Rückspiel, Rückspiel vom Rückspiel, Rückspiel, Rückspiel, Rückspiel. Dann in drei Jahren haben wir dann das 20. Sanktionspaket.
Während Russland auf seine Aggressionen zerstört, zerstört Europa unsere Unterstützung für Ukraine. Und ja, die Sanktionen sind zerstört. Sie haben einen zerstörten Effekt auf die russische Wirtschaft.
Ja, wenn man nur fest dran glaubt, dann wird das jetzt ganz anders mit dem 20. Wir hören den Tagesschaubericht, der uns erklärt, wie das denn jetzt kam, dass doch die 90 Milliarden für die Ukraine freigegeben wurden, obwohl doch Ungarn dagegen war unter Orban und mancher doch auch eigentlich dagegen gestimmt hatte noch auf EU-Ebene. Jetzt aber gibt es wohl die Möglichkeit, dass es doch gezahlt werden kann. Es gibt einen Deal und da behalten wir das mit dem Sanktionspaket im Hinterkopf.
Seit vier Jahren muss sich die Ukraine gegen Russland verteidigen und für den Krieg braucht das Land dringend neue Finanzhilfen. Heute konnten die EU-Staaten einen 90 Milliarden Euro Kredit freigeben, weil auch Ungarn nach monatelangen Verzögerungen zugestimmt hat. Grund ist die Reparatur der Druspa-Pipeline. Die Ukraine hatte sie gestern endgültig in Stand gesetzt. Jetzt fließt wieder russisches Öl nach Ungarn und in die Slowakei.
Ungarn ist besonders oder mit der Slowakei zusammen abhängig von russischer Energie.
Ich bin gerade verwundert. Ich hatte eine andere Pointe. Sie wird Recht haben. Sie ist eine Daubner. Man hat das in der Sitzung gemacht, in der Orban schon abgewählt war, aber noch nicht im Amt. Man hat einen vakanten Sitz gehabt. Einstimmigkeit heißt ja kein Veto. Deswegen ja auch, dass sie ja schon mal diesen Move angesprochen hat, dass Merkel so, Herr Orban, wir haben jetzt so eine Abstimmung, wollen Sie kurz zum Kaffee gehen und so. Und ich dachte, das wäre unter Abwesenheit, also nicht Zustimmung, aber sie sagt es explizit.
Es gibt einen Deal. Das heißt also, wir haben, also natürlich ist es ein Dilemma, das ist mir schon klar. Nur die Situation ist jetzt die Folgende. Man gibt der Ukraine mehr Geld, gibt aber zugleich ja auch Russland mehr Geld, indem man ja sagt, wir nehmen wieder die Energie aus Russland, also Östrobarkai und Ungarn dürfen zugreifen und legt aber nochmal ein 20. Sanktionspaket für irgendwas auf.
Ich würde auch sagen, wenn man...
Und davor haben wir noch gehört, wie die ukrainischen Soldaten dort behandelt werden. Es ist kaum noch zu fassen.
In Sachen ökonomischer Isolierung Russlands Rückschritte macht in den Sanktionspaketen, sollte man auch die Numerierung wieder rückwärts machen.
Ja.
Also auf das 20. Erfolg dann das 19.
Im Kreisky Forum jetzt nochmal Adam Scholtern.
Ähm, specific, specific names.
Like for example, four years ago, the candidate of the Unified Opposition, Peter Markezaj, was on state television for exactly eight minutes. Eight minutes during the whole electoral campaign. Eight minutes. Has Peter Mordjör ever been quoted on official TV? Not as far as I know. His first interview was given at Partizan. I know, I know. Which is a partisan media.
Which is, yeah, yeah, obviously.
I personally don't know, but to be honest, I don't really think that at this point it's very important. So everybody knows that these are partisan organizations. So if you are critical of the government, you are simply not watching public television.
It's the rules and goes by it.
Everybody knows the credit or the merit and the credit worthiness of these organizations. You just simply don't give credit to them.
Wenn ich weiß, das ist ja eh Staatsfernsehen, dann brauche ich da ja gar nicht mehr hingehen. Dann muss ich auch darüber gar nicht versuchen, irgendwas zu erreichen. Und die Leute, die Ungarn wissen ja auch, ah ja, das ist ja eh Staatsfernsehen. Was habe ich dazu erwarten? Also gehe ich einen anderen Weg. Wir hatten jetzt viele Debatten in Deutschland und der EU, wie schädlich die sozialen Medien sind für unser politisches Klima. Bis hin zu, wir müssen nochmal Wahlen wiederholen oder nicht stattfinden lassen in Rumänien, weil da TikTok und so weiter viel zu einflussreich war, da ist irgendwas passiert. Im März sah es auch noch so aus, als wäre das Social Media Game auf Orban's Seite. Hier ein Artikel von Reuters, 16. März. Istvan Hollow, ein 76-jähriger Anhänger des ungarischen Ministerpräsidenten Viktor Orban, verbringt täglich bis zu einer Stunde auf Facebook, um die Botschaften des rechtsgerichteten Politikers zu verbreiten und so dessen Chancen bei den Parlamentswahlen zu stärken. Anfang März startete Orban eine 40-tägige digitale Herausforderung und forderte seine Basisunterstütze auf, täglich mindestens zehn Minuten damit zu verbringen, Beiträge und Kommentare in den sozialen Medien zu teilen, um der starken Online-Präsenz seines Rivalen Peter Morger von der Mittlerechtspartei CISA entgegenzuwirken. So, das war also der Stand und die Idee. Jetzt versammelt euch im Netz und tut was gegen mich. Wie sieht es aus? Kovac, die wir eben schon gehört haben, beschreibt es, wie das in den Medien so ist, die staatlich kontrolliert sind.
Wie konnte in diesem kontrollierten Mediensystem Peter Madja so groß werden?
Also, das ist tatsächlich vieles Kontrolle in den ganzen öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien. Sie sind Propaganda-Organe geworden. Auch vieles, was auf Papier unabhängig ist, aber ist in den Händen von Parteileualisten und Oligarchen. Und da ist wirklich ein starkes Message-Kontroll und alles geht nur durch, was die Regierung will. Aber so 20-30 Prozent der Medien, vor allem online, ist frei. Also frei. Das heißt, man kann jede Meinung abdrücken. Man kann normalen Journalismus machen.
Das Internet ist damit Ort der Freiheit. Natürlich sind Unternehmen, die dann dort werben, auf diesen Plattformen auch wieder irgendwelche Repressionen ausgesetzt. Aber eine ganz andere Freiheit herrscht da.
Vielleicht sollten wir künftig mitlaufen lassen. Wir reden hier vom Internet, meinen aber Silicon Valley Silo-Konzerne und deren Plattform.
Vor allem aus, es gibt an Ungarn, muss man noch hinzufügen, es gibt echt sehr viel guten Journalismus, so höre ich, ich kann es ja nicht im Original lesen, von Bloggern, die auch echt sehr große Reichweiten haben. Denn das ist ja dann oft der Effekt, wenn man sagt, das ist eh alles in staatlicher Hand. Und es ist ja dann offensichtlich, ich meine, so blöd wird ja kein Ungar sein, dass wenn die die Nachrichten am Tag der Wahl abends einschalten und dann als erste Meldung nicht zu den Nachrichten, nicht zu der Wahl bekommen, dann sitzen die ja nicht davor und denken, ach so, ja, dann ist wohl die Wahl nicht so wichtig. Eben, das ist fraglich, das hören wir nämlich jetzt gleich. Wascha, in den sozialen Medien, Facebook.
Also Peter Mojar hat das teilweise genutzt. Die unabhängigen Medien haben ihm auch geholfen. Und sie mussten es auch. In seinem Sinne, so groß war seine Reichweite über Facebook. Ungarn ist ein Facebook-Land, da passieren sehr viele Debatten und da geht auch eine direkte Kommunikation. Und er hat sehr direkt kommuniziert. Und das ist praktisch ein Teil des ungarischen Journalismus geworden. Er schreibt irgendetwas und das wird zur Nachricht. Er hat eine unglaublich große Reichweite.
Du hast ja schon auf die Demografie verwiesen. Klar, ältere Leute sind wo? Bei Facebook. Aber sie sind dort. Sie sitzen dann doch nicht mehr zwingend vor dem Fernseher. Sie sind dort. Wenn ich mir bei Facebook so das ansehe, ich bin ja noch bei Facebook, du bist ja nur so nicht präsent auf Facebook, dass man dir folgt.
Ja, ich weiß schon, wie du es meinst. Ich weiß gar nicht, Facebook. Also ich höre auch immer, dass das Leute benutzen.
Also ich kenne viele Leute, die den Schritt nicht gemacht haben. Also sicherlich ältere Leute als wir, aber die den Schritt nicht mehr gemacht haben zu Instagram oder sonst irgendetwas. Und was dort wahnsinnig gut funktioniert, das sehe ich dann, ist irgendwelche Skandale, Politikskandale von da hat jemand Geld veruntreut und sonst was. Da können die sich richtig müd machen dran in den Kommentaren. Das ist also genau das Thema. Also ich würde sagen, alles, was die Orban-Regierung ausmacht, dieses Orban-System, diese Korruption, ist genau das Thema, was wahnsinnig gut bei Instagram funktioniert. Bilder und Text und Kommentar dazu. Dann kann man so richtig loslegen und das machen. Dass der das bespielen konnte, das leuchtet vollkommen ein, aber eben nicht nur für das ältere Publikum, war in den sozialen Medien. Man kann sich das übrigens mal ansehen, wenn man seine YouTube-Seite sich anseht, also von Peter Moja, da gibt es ganz viele Reels und so weiter. Und da sieht man auch, wie er überall rumläuft. Also er geht in Krankenhäuser rein. Er zeigt dann hier, hier gibt es ja nicht mehr Toilettenpapier und so was. Also er geht da richtig durch, macht das auf die eine Seite. Dann macht er Tänze und spektakuläre Videos. Das heißt, er kann auch ein jüngeres Publikum ansprechen.
Und noch möchte ich hinzufügen, dass er nicht nur auf Facebook ist, sondern auch auf Instagram und TikTok sehr erfolgreich ist, was wegen Generationen wichtig ist. Also verschiedene Generationen sind auf verschiedenen Plattformen.
Das heißt, hier sind es dann die Tech-Konzerne, die überhaupt es ermöglicht haben, dass jemand gegen Orban eine Chance hat. Das wäre vorher nicht da gewesen. Das muss man, wenn jetzt immer wieder so von Verboten, sowas die Rede ist, dann muss man sagen, ja hier hat es dann mal geholfen. Man kann sich aber nicht immer aufsuchen, wo es gerade hilft und wo man sagt, das wollten den Kandidaten, wollen wir aber nicht. Da werden wohl die russischen Trolls dahinter stecken. Das kann auch einfach mal so sein, dass es mal die eine, mal die andere Richtung geht.
Dennoch nochmal mit BMNs. Also ja, alte Medien, neue Medien, redaktionelle Medien und dann Tech-Konzerne, wie wir sie nennen. Wir wissen, wie sehr die in Amerika unter Kontrolle stehen. Familie Ellison, Elon Musk und so weiter. Deswegen unterscheiden wir jetzt. Also ich füge es nur ein, ja, als analytische Heuristik. Die alten Medien, Fernsehen, Radio & Co. Die neuen Medien, Twitter, Facebook, Instagram. Und dann kommt erst das Internet, wo man sich auch betätigen kann, ohne dass irgendwer die Protokolle, also eine Person die Protokolle dominiert.
Wobei du zugeben wirst, dass die viralen Hits nur über diese von dir genannten Plattformen bislang möglich sind.
Genau. Aber du freust dich ja jetzt, dass die Konzerne, die Silikonwelle Konzerne eine Macht gegen die alten Medien haben. Und die Macht über das Internet ist genauso groß. Also sozusagen dasselbe Problem nur in die andere Richtung.
Ja, ich sehe natürlich das Machtproblem da auch. Ich sehe aber jetzt erst einmal, dass es die Möglichkeit ist, aufgrund dieser algorithmischen Getriebenheit, dass dann plötzlich irgendjemand nach oben kommen kann, der im staatlichen Fernsehen nicht mehr da ist. Und jetzt leben wir ja nicht in ungarischen Zuständen. Aber das bedeutet natürlich, dass ein ganz anderes Meinungs-Spektrum plötzlich stattfinden kann und auch Meinungen populärer werden, die sonst zum Beispiel keine Talkshow-Relevanz erhalten hätten.
Das stimmt.
Das wäre das, was ich sagen würde.
Vielleicht erleben wir die Zeit, in der nicht nur Langform, also Podcasts, frei von Silicon Valley, Silo-Denken, sondern auch die Short-Videos demnächst. Das ist nicht ausgemacht, dass in dieser, in der Code einfach überall geschrieben wird, es ganz rasant geht und sich die Leute fragen, warum muss ich jetzt vor jedem Video 30 Sekunden Werbung gucken? Ich kann auch einfach bei PeerTube gehen und so.
Sollten wir auch noch hinzufügen, Roger ist natürlich auch jemand, der in den Podcasts viel zu Gast war, nämlich freie Podcasts. Gibt es gerade da viel, wo staatlich das dann nicht abgedeckt ist. Da sehen wir also, da ist eigentlich viel Free Speech möglich. Sehr lustig fand ich dann, dass wir ja alle mitbekommen haben, dass Facebook das eingeschränkt hat, dass politische Werbung gemacht werden darf. Wie hat das jetzt bedient?
Also sehen wir jetzt in der Küche oder was?
Nein. Interessant nur, was das für einen Effekt hatte.
Und ja, Fidesz ist nicht so erfolgreich damit. Es hängt auch damit zusammen, dass Metta die politischen Anzeigen seit letztem Herbst verboten hat. Und da sieht man, dass wenn Fidesz nicht mehr Anzeigen schalten kann, dann ist die organische Reichweite extrem gesunken. Während bei Tissot gibt es eine organische Reichweite. Also das gibt vielen auch die Hoffnung, dass die Menschen einfach das teilen und das alles wird viral auf TikTok, auf Instagram und auf Facebook.
Morja hat da ja nicht Werbung geschaltet, sondern als Privatperson sich geäußert. Also Privatperson als politische Person natürlich sich geäußert. Das ging viral, wurde geteilt, kopiert, irgendwelche Auftritte von ihm zusammengeschnitten bei TikTok. Ja, das war etwas, wo wir mal bei Maximilian K sagten, naja, da ist eine Gefahr. Aber wo die Gefahr groß ist, da wissen wir, wächst das Rettende auch. Und das sehen wir dann hier. Also das ist dann auch möglich. Und dann ist plötzlich ein Orban mit seinem ganzen Geld machtlos, weil er da nicht mehr werben kann. Deshalb er dann die Leute aufrief, jetzt müsst ihr mal jeden Tag mindestens 10 Minuten für mich irgendwelche positiven Posts absetzen.
Aber das ist halt in Deutschland genau umgedreht. Die etablierten Parteien bezahlen, machen Kram, aber es ist halt immer politische Kommunikation. Während die AfD einfach so Vlog-Style mäßig, ich bin ja gerade beim Parteitag, ich wurde gerade wieder gewählt und so.
Ja, aber da muss man sich ja dran anpassen, wie auch immer. Reden wir jetzt noch mal ganz kurz über die Demokratie. Denn es wurde ja die ganze Zeit gesagt, die Demokratie, die ist ja in Ungarn quasi schon abgeschafft. Jetzt sehen wir, ach so, dann gibt es eine Wahl. Drei Stunden später, Orban sagt, ich habe verloren, fertig. Das ist ja erstmal ein deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass es Demokratie gibt.
Oder funktionieren Renten für einen Typ.
Ja, sie funktioniert dann für ihn. Aber gut, wir gehen jetzt nicht davon aus, dass wenn Orban ein bisschen weniger Geld gehabt hätte, dass er jetzt Armeen losschickt, die...
Also ich würde mit drei Milliarden auch mit 63 in Rente gehen.
Ja, es gibt allerdings ja auch Leute, die gehen mit sehr viel Geld erst in die Politik hinein. Da steht man auch nicht. Wir haben auch einen Bundeskanzler, der müsste jetzt nicht mehr ran.
Ich meine, Trump war älter, als er sich hat wählen lassen, als Orban, als er ausstieg. Ja. Also das gibt es schon, das würde man sagen.
Und Donald Trump könnte ein wunderbarer Podcaststar sein, neben Jerome oder so. Müsste überhaupt nie das Weiße Haus betreten haben. Philipp Mahno, den haben wir hier schon mehrmals erwähnt.
Dein Liebling.
Derjenige, der das Buch unter Beobachtung geschrieben hat, wo er sagt, na ja, liberale Demokratie. Das ist ja komisch. Also, denn wir haben bis 1990 eigentlich immer nur von Demokratien gesprochen. Und da sehen wir auch, ja, Demokratien, die sollen liberal sein im Sinne von, du hast eine Meinung dazu, ich habe eine andere. Und da haben wir die. Und dann ist das möglicherweise auch parlamentarisch repräsentiert. Aber liberal meint ja auch das Institutionelle und Verfassung sowas. Das ist etwas, ein Trend, der mit den 90ern aufkommt. Weshalb er sagt, er kann da gar nicht so mit einstimmen. Diesen Abgesang auf die Demokratie.
Manow war jetzt in der Körberstiftung und sagt, es gehört schon zur Problemdiagnose hinzu, dass, da bin ich auch nicht ganz alleine, dass wir eigentlich in den letzten 30 Jahren eine Verschiebung von Zuständigkeiten aus dem Nationalstaat in Europa natürlich an die Europäische Union vor allen Dingen gesehen haben. Man könnte auch andere Beispiele nennen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur alles EU. Die WTO sozusagen wurde zuständig für Marktöffnung, Europäischer Menschengerichtshof, generell Menschengerichtshof. Also wir sehen eigentlich seit den 90er Jahren eine sehr starke, ich würde sagen in vielerlei Hinsicht eine Konstitutionalisierung. Also dass sozusagen Dinge auf die supranationale Ebene geschoben wird. Und das heißt automatisch eigentlich, dass sie dann rechtlich reguliert werden. Es werden Verträge geschlossen und die Verträge müssen dann rechtlich ausgelegt werden.
Das bedeutet aber auch, um das mal ganz zu überspitzen, es wird ja damit dem Wählerwillen etwas entzogen. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, weil wir wählen ja noch das Europäische Parlament und wir haben ja auch die Leute gewählt, die das dann mit auf den Weg bringen. Aber wir merken, es wird immer indirekter. Ich war ja jetzt wieder in der Schweizer Seite, das Vergnügen wieder im Schweizer Dittaturklub aufzutreten, hab dann auch mit Schweizer natürlich da gesprochen, hab dann auch gesagt, weil es ja eigentlich bei sagen wir linken, des linksliberalen Schweizer auch eine große Bestrebung gibt, mehr hin zu EU. Und dann hab ich gesagt, aber das ist ja auch in gewisser Weise ein bisschen aufgeben von demokratischer Souveränität. Und das kriegen die auch gar nicht so, also es ist auch gar nicht so leichter, wenn man es mal wirklich in diesem Konflikt benennt, dann ja, da eingeständnisse machen und sagen, ja, das wäre dann wohl so. Das ist aber nicht ein Thema, das jetzt hier aufgreifen will mit der Schweiz, sondern was natürlich dazu führt, wenn wir immer mehr auslagern, also wir können ja mal nicht sagen, wir reden ja immer jetzt von so Leuten wie Orban oder eben diesem Papke, den wir gehört haben, der dann gleich kommt, ja, die Prusla-Elite, erzählt uns, wie wir unsere Kinder erziehen sollen. Aber ich habe es ja schon mal als Beispiel gebracht. Adam Toos war ja damals sehr gelassen, als Donald Trump den Fettchef angegriffen hat und jetzt war er auch sehr erfolgreich, wie wir sehen, und sagte, ja, wir wollten ja eigentlich aus dem progressiven Lager doch längst mal die Zentralbank politisieren und wollen nicht nur bei dieser Technokratie bleiben und den Status quo verwalten. Manu sagt jetzt auch, die Schlussfolgerung aus dieser Institutionalisierung, also immer mehr die liberale Demokratie stark zu machen, bedeutet?
Ich glaube, dass wir an verschiedenen Politiksektoren festmachen könnten, dass das unter anderem dazu geführt hat, nicht nur zu dem subjektiven Empfinden, sondern wahrscheinlich auch zu einer objektiven Lagebeschreibung, dass die Leute in vielerlei Hinsicht den Eindruck hatten, Wahlen machen nicht mehr so viel Unterschied. Also es ist eigentlich egal, wen ich bekomme.
Wir sind ja auch eigentlich hin und her gerissen. Wenn wir beispielsweise sehen, Karlsruhe kommt und sagt, ne, ihr könnt das Bürgergeld gar nicht weiter senken. Das Limit ist erreicht. Ihr müsst einen gewissen Lebensstandard absichern. Dann sagen wir Gott sei Dank, gibt es Karlsruhe, die die Verrücktheiten der CDU wieder einfangen. Andererseits sagen wir, schade, dass wir die Schuldenbremse in der Verfassung stehen haben, denn die nimmt uns in den Spielraum. Dann hat man eine große Idee und fängt sogar an zu regieren, wird aber dann plötzlich wieder gestoppt durch Karlsruhe. Das heißt, man ist da sehr hin und her gerissen. Und da ist dann die Frage zu stellen, die kann ich jetzt auch nicht hier beantworten, aber das ist, glaube ich, eine Debatte, die wir mehr führen müssen. Ist eigentlich es doch vielleicht mal so weit zu sagen, wir trauen uns zu, dass wir weniger institutionelle Demokratie haben und mehr direkte Demokratie, nicht im Sinne von, wir machen jetzt ständig Umfragen, also im Sinne von Volksabstimmung, sondern dass wir sagen, dann hat auch eine Regierung mehr Handlungsmacht dann mal. Dann ist die Verfassung ein bisschen dünner. Nicht bei den ganz grundsätzlichen Dingen, aber dass man sagt, da schreiben wir nicht noch alles mit rein. Das ist ja eine Sache, die eigentlich auch sagt, das trauen wir Wählern dann auch zu. Denn man könnte ja sagen, diese Institutionalisierung, diese ganzen Forderungen nach noch mehr Verrechtlichungen und prüfen und machen und tun, ist ja auch eine Skepsis gegenüber den Wählern. Man sagt mal, nicht, dass die mal zu dumm sind dafür. Lassen wir das die schon mal rechtlich einhegen.
Also das ist ein sehr guter Punkt, da wir die Argumentation von Manu soweit kennen und wir haben auch ein Buch von ihm gelesen. Man kann Themen neu aufhängen. Also raus aus der EU-Institutionalisierung, beispielsweise in den Bundestag oder du hast die Schweiz angesprochen, direkt dem Wähler sagen, ja, also wenn du es nicht wegdelegiert haben willst, dann befasse dich damit. Wir gehen also jetzt mal vom 24.4. die 25. Sitzung des Bundestags durch. Das sind also jetzt Themen, von denen wir jetzt im manuschem Sinne sagen, nee, das wollen wir nicht, dass irgendwelche Institutionen das machen. Ich hätte gern selber Mitspracherecht. Also 24.4., 9 Euro Ticket, Senkung der Energiesteuer, Anpassung des Verpackungsrechts, Erwerbsminderungsrente, Gasnetzentgelte, eine aktuelle Stunde zum Keine Sozialerbau bei Kindern. Die Sitzung davor. Kommunales Vetorecht gegen Zuweisung von Asylbewerbungen, Maritime Wirtschaft, Konsensbasiertes Sexualstrafrecht, aktuelle Stunde, Projekt der Amadeo-Antonius-Stiftung, eine EU-Verordnung zum Thema Datenaustausch bei Kurzzeitvermietung, dann eine Vermögenssteuer. Da würde ich das erste Mal sagen, da würde ich gerne kurz mitreden. Dann geht es weiter mit Weiterentwicklung der Treibhausgasminderungsquote.
Beim neuen Euro-Ticket würdest du auch mitreden wollen?
Ja, da würde ich sagen, will ich, aber die Debatte ergibt sich. Reden bitte zu Protokoll, ja. Weiterentwicklung der Treibhausgasminderungsquote, Familienversicherung, Änderung des Energiewirtschaftsgesetzes, Gerichtsurteil zu korrektiv wird besprochen, dann findet eine Aufhebung der Immunität statt. So, 73. Sitzung. Ja, also jeder kann ja mal seine Interessen so abklopfen auf das Argument. Bitte nicht in irgendwelchen Institutionen, sondern...
Ich sage dir ganz klar...
Aktuelle Stunde zum Thema Raumfahrtnation Deutschland.
Was hast du Lust?
Drei Stunden.
Nein, das wäre nicht der Punkt. Er wird übrigens angesprochen, auch zum Thema Bürgerrat, und da ist er jetzt nicht so ein Fan von Mano.
Wieder in Betriebnahme abgeschalteter Kernkraftwerke. Noch mal eine Stunde debattieren, alle zusammen.
Moment. Es geht ja nicht darum, ob ich da mitreden will, sondern die Frage ist, wenn ich das Kreuz mache, für eine Politik, die ich gut finde, egal um welches Thema es jetzt mal geht, dann kann ich ja sagen, und wenn die dann eine Mehrheit bekommt, diese Position, dann kann das durchgesetzt werden. Toll. Wenn ich aber zugleich Institutionen darüber habe, die diesen Willen wieder torpedieren, im Sinne von, ja, es gibt eine Mehrheit in Berlin, für deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen, aber dann gibt es institutionelle Rahmenbedingungen, die das so ziemlich verunmöglichen, dann sehe ich plötzlich, aha, mit meiner Stimme habe ich gar nicht viel bewirken können. Wenn ich sehe, ich kann hier versuchen, Kreuz zu machen, mache es auch, aber am Ende ist es EU-Recht und darauf habe ich keine Auswirkung, dann ist das ja eine nicht gerade demokratisierende Maßnahme. Und diesen Widerspruch gibt es ja in der Tat.
Ich kann dir noch einen nennen. Wir sitzen hier im Bahnhofsviertel Frankfurt am Main. Alle, die uns zuhören, wissen, was das bedeutet. Drogen, Gewalt und so weiter. Für die Sicherheit im Bahnhofsviertel ist die Polizei zuständig. Jeder Deutsche so, klar, wer sonst? Die Polizei. Es gibt eine Stadtpolizei, das ist das Ordnungsamt. In keiner Fragestellung, die irgendwann mal zu irgendwas, was Bahnhofsviertel Sicherheit thematisiert wird, findet das Ordnungsamt, also klar, Emissionsschutzgesetz, Lautstärke, eine Disko darf nie zu laut sein. Alles andere Landespolizei. So, wir gehen also auf die Straße, denken unser Bürgermeister ist zuständig. Wir gehen zur ersten Sitzung unseres Stadtparlaments. Und, ach so, hier ist eine andere Ebene zuständig. Also klar können wir immer sagen, ich hätte das gerne im Bundestag, das macht aber das Europaparlament, das finde ich irgendwie blöd. Bei noch viel mehr Themen, sage ich, warum macht das nicht die Stadt, warum ist es das Land, Hessen? Das ist dieselbe Diskussion. Würde jetzt jemand kommen und sagen, ich finde irgendwie, Hessen ist so ein rechtes Projekt, also ich würde es sofort sagen, aber wir hätten niemals eine Diskussion, wie wir es bei der EU machen. So, jetzt können wir natürlich, also ich bin jetzt plötzlich der Große, warum denken wir noch in Nationalstaaten? Es gibt halt die Kommunale, die Landes, die Bundes- und dann halt die EU-Ebene. Dass irgendwo da eine Nationalstaatsgrenze ist, schön und gut.
Nur hat die EU-Ebene ja die meisten demokratischen Defizite verglichen jetzt zum Beispiel mit Deutschland.
Ich wähle meinen EU-Parlamentarier schon ziemlich direkt. Der ist gar nicht so indirekt.
Ja, den Parlamentarier, aber du weißt ja, wie auf der EU-Ebene Entscheidungen mit Kommissionen und so weiter getroffen werden.
Ich wähle meine Justizministerin nicht. Das passiert genauso indirekt.
Na, es ist schon ein Unterschied. Also es ist schon ein Unterschied, wie die EU konstitutionalisiert ist, als wir das jetzt hier konstituiert ist, als wir das in Deutschland haben. Also das ist ja jetzt unbestreitbar, dass die EU mehr demokratische Defizite hat als Deutschland.
Also, wenn ich nach Hessen schaue.
Wir haben ja das Buch von Nico Semsrott auch gelesen dazu.
Ja, absolut. Meine hessische Landesregierung, die hat mit mir wirklich ganz, also da fühle ich mich, ich will mich vom Europaparlament besser vertreten als vom Landtag Hessen.
Das mag sein, aber das ist dann einfach, weil du was Deckungsgleiches hast. Ich könnte auch meine Schwierigkeiten nicht von...
Das EU-Parlament ist genauso rechts wie das Landesparlament Hessen....
mich von Boris Rhein vertreten zu lassen oder sowas. Darum geht es jetzt nicht. Es geht doch jetzt mal um diese Frage. Abstrakter formuliert, sollte man jetzt aus einer Nicht-AfD-Position heraus sagen, wir sind die Verteidiger der Technokratie mit den liberalen Institutionen, denn nur das ist für uns Demokratie? Oder trauen wir uns in irgendeiner Weise zu, mehr Demokratie zu wagen? Wie das genau ausgestaltet würde, wäre zu besprechen. Aber ein Vorschlag von Adam Toos dann, politisiert doch ruhig mal die Zentralbank und deren Geldpolitik. Hört doch mal auf, an diese Unabhängigkeit zu glauben. Wäre ja zum Beispiel ein Ansatz, den man auch auf deutsche Wohnen enteignen übertragen könnte, zu sagen, ja müssen wir uns eigentlich an diese Eigentumsordnung da halten, könnte man das nicht stärker politisieren? Und steckt da nicht auch ein Potenzial drin, um zu sagen, ja damit Wahlen tatsächlich in irgendeiner Weise etwas bewirken, man nicht einfach sagen, ja wir haben die jetzt da gewählt, die sind uns auch viel sympathischer, weil wir die schon im Podcast dreimal gehört haben. Aber leider sind ihnen ja die Hände so schrecklich gebunden. Und das ist ja die Frage, ob man eigentlich da von so einer Art Postliberalität bald ausgehen wird. Dass also alle sagen, na vielleicht ist es mit den liberalen Institutionen, die einfach immer weiter konstituiert werden, am Ende auch eine große Enddemokratisierung. Manu weist ja auf etwas hin, was wir auch aus deutscher Perspektive häufig vergessen.
Diese Beispiele haben wie Verfassungsgerichte, wir erzählen uns das natürlich die ganze Zeit so. Ja, ja, da kommen jetzt diese Rechtspopulisten an die Macht. Und was machen sie? Die zerstören die Institutionen der liberalen Demokratie. Sie greifen zum Beispiel die Verfassungsgerichte an. Ja, sie greifen die Verfassungsgerichte an. Das stimmt. Aber aus unserer bundesdeutschen Perspektive fallen wir natürlich in Ohnmacht, weil man sagt, das geht ja gar nicht. Wir sind aber sehr, sehr speziell. Also wir sind eigentlich so bis Ende der 80er Jahre eins der ganz, ganz wenigen Länder mit einem, überhaupt mit einem Verfassungsgericht in Europa. Und dann aber auch noch mit einem ganz besonders starken Verfassungsgericht wie Karlsruhe. So und vor dem Hintergrund scheint uns das immer klar. Ja, zu einer Demokratie gehörten Verfassungsgericht. In Schweden gibt es kein Verfassungsgericht, in Dänemark gibt es keins, in der Schweiz gibt es kein, in Niederlande gibt es kein, in England gibt es keins.
Die stehen jetzt auch nicht alle ganz schlecht da, diese Länder, die er da aufzählt. Das meine ich ja nur. Ich sage jetzt auch nicht, schafft das Verfassungsrecht ab oder so. Ich glaube nur, dass diese Debatte ziemlich notwendig ist, wenn man sagt, was kann man denn eigentlich mal bewegen. Denn ein Punkt ist mir noch entscheidend. Wir haben jetzt darüber gesprochen, dass ein Gegenkandidat zu Orban kommt und plötzlich ist er sehr erfolgreich. Und die Leute wählen zu über 80 Prozent in Ungarn, eine Rekordwahlbeteiligung. Wir merken immer mehr, Rekordwahlbeteiligung gibt es. Und das bedeutet aber auch, alle Lager gehen mehr wählen. Wenn jetzt gesagt wird, so häufig von Linken oft so vorgetragen, wir haben es eben im Podcast da von Heidi Reichineck auch gehört, und die wollen dann die Demokratie abschaffen. Aber wer will die Demokratie wirklich abschaffen? Also wir sehen ja, es gibt autoritäre Züge bei verschiedenen Akteuren und dann versuchen die, zum Beispiel liberale Institutionen zu unterminieren. Oder wir sehen auch Einschränkungen von Meinungs- und Pressefreiheit, auch aus anderen Lager, nicht nur aus dem rechten Lager. So, das können wir jetzt erst mal so konstatieren. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal von den Wählern ausgehen, ich habe also schon Leute getroffen, die schlimme Sachen wählen, aber ich habe zum Beispiel noch nie jemanden getroffen, der sagt, ich würde gerne die Demokratie abschaffen. Manu sagt folgendes.
Meine Disziplin unterhält sich jetzt die ganze Zeit über die Frage, können wir uns eigentlich, also wie sollen wir uns das vorstellen, dass eine Mehrheit dafür stimmt, übermorgen nicht mehr stimmen zu dürfen? Ist das ein plausibles Szenario?
Also das ist das, was wir in der Einführung gehört haben, diese Frage, ob dann sozusagen man einmal zur Wahl geht, um zum letzten Mal zur Wahl gegangen zu sein.
Richtig, richtig.
Ist es ein plausibles Szenario? Und wollen die das? Stellt man sich das wirklich so vor, dass Zentral-Mittel-Europa, dass diese Leute in Polen, in der Slowakei, dass die noch mal 50 Jahre oder 40 Jahre länger unter der Diktatur gelebt haben als wir, dass die sagen, ach, nö, mit der Demokratie brauchen wir eigentlich nicht. Also ich bin da insgesamt sehr viel skeptischer. Ja, wir sehen.
Also ich kann dir Thüringer nennen, die sagen, können wir einfach Höcke wählen und dann war's das.
Die wird es geben, aber ich sehe nicht da eine Mehrheit.
Es gibt ein Argument, das sowieso gilt gegen das, was er sagte, indem man sagt, die wollen ja nicht sich das Stimmrecht nehmen, sondern nur anderen. Dann sind es die Migranten, dann sind es die Armen und so weiter.
Das ist das Problem mit dem Minderheitenschutz, auch bei der Elektoraldemokratie, dass es ja quasi der Gegenbegriff zur liberalen Demokratie nicht abgedeckt ist.
Darüber sind wir sehr weit hinaus. Leute wollen mittlerweile sich selbst das Stimmrecht nehmen, wenn sie es damit auch allen anderen nehmen. Die gibt es in Deutschland.
Ein paar Prozent.
Ja, klar, aber er sagt ja, ist das wirklich plausibel? Und ich denke mir so, ich habe zerstörungslos gelesen. Die Leute wollen nicht nur sich das Stimmrecht wegnehmen, sondern die wollen einfach hier Tabula rasa machen.
Ja, die gibt es aber in dem in dem Buch wird ja auch nicht behauptet von Nachtweih und Amlinger, dass das jetzt die gesellschaftliche Mehrheit ist.
Ich sehe zum Beispiel jetzt an einem Prinzip Ungarn. Es gibt eine faschistische Demokratisierung.
Ja, vielleicht ist der Begriff auch schwierig. Wenn wir jetzt nochmal, also Ungarn ist ja nun wirklich das Paradebeispiel gewesen für einen liberalen Staat, der autoritär umgebaut wird, dass er illiberaler wird. Und Orban hat ja auch gar nicht geleugnet, dass er das tut. Er wurde ja schon vor Jahren von Jean-Claude Juncker gar nicht so spöttisch begrüßt mit Ah, the dictator is coming. Kann man sich ja noch alles bei YouTube ansehen. Das heißt, wir haben da ja wirklich das absolute Negativbeispiel gesehen. Und jetzt sehen wir, es gibt eine Wahl und Orban, paar Stunden später, ist weg. Jetzt geht er sogar ganz, wie wir hören, aus der Politik raus. Jetzt sagst du, ja, mit dem Geld im Rücken würde ich auch rausgehen.
Na ja, mal ehrlich, das ist doch eine ganz relevante Frage.
Ja, das mag ja nicht.
Mit drei Milliarden auf der Bank und ohne juristische Konsequenzen würde ich doch sofort in Rente gehen.
Völlig richtig. Nur daran zeigt sich ja auf jeden Fall, Orban hat es nicht geschafft, jetzt zum Beispiel jemanden zu etablieren, der es ihm einfach nachtut. Er hat nicht jetzt eine Dynastie aufgebaut oder was auch immer.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher. Keine Angst vor Verschörungstheorien.
Ich will einen Punkt noch einmal, Manu, hören, was eigentlich das Entscheidende doch immer sein muss, wenn wir über Demokratie reden. Die Menschen gehen also wählen. Und es mag sein, dass es auch immer mehr Leute gibt in einem kleinen radikalisierten Spektrum, die sagen, ich brauche die Demokratie an sich gar nicht. Aber im Ganzen habe ich eher den Eindruck, dass es ein Ja zur Demokratie gibt, aber auch mit allen negativen Seiten, die so ein Ja zur Demokratie haben kann. Es geht aber immer darum, schon die Möglichkeit zu haben, abwählen zu können. Und auch Trump wird abgewählt werden.
Aber vielleicht der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass wenn wir wirklich ein ganz simples Vorstellung von Demokratie haben, dann ist eigentlich das Wichtigste gar nicht so sehr die Wahl, sondern die Abwahl, dass sie jemandem die Macht wieder nehmen können. Macht zu haben scheint, ich bin Wissenschaftler, ich kenne das nicht so gut, aber es scheint irgendwie attraktiv zu sein. Und Politiker wollen gerne wiedergewählt werden. Und das ist der Mechanismus, durch den man Politiker bekommt, nicht nur in ihrem Interesse zu handeln, sondern im Interesse von mir, von ihnen, von uns, von der Gesellschaft. Also dass sie sich quasi an Gemeinwohl interessieren oder dass sie sich zumindest an politischen Mehrheiten interessieren. Und wenn es die Abwahl nicht gäbe, dann würden sie das nicht machen. Da hätten sie keinen Anreiz dazu. Das ist schon das Problem bei Präsidenten, die einen zweiten Term haben, die nicht wiedergewählt werden können. Da wird es schon problematisch, weil dann die Drohung der Abwahl eine leere Drohung ist.
Das fand ich auch ein sehr gutes Argument, deshalb, weil wir ja schon mal mit Unter in Deutschland diskutiert haben, ist es eigentlich gut, dass man 16 Jahre regieren kann. Manu würde jetzt sagen, ja, es ist gut, dass wir das nicht nur auf zwei Amtszeiten verkürzt haben, weil dann könnte sein, dass dann in der zweiten Amtszeit, wenn man weiß, man würde eh nicht mehr rankommen, möglicherweise sagte ich, zettel mal einen Krieg gegen Iran an oder das auch immer. Das heißt, ich finde, es ist sehr differenziert zu betrachten. Und ich sehe durchaus eine, also es gibt gerade so eine Lust daran, eine Untergangserzählung aufzumachen. Und ich würde ruhig mal diesen Gedanken von Mano wirken lassen und überlegen, schaffen die da alle gerade die Demokratie ab oder wollen die die abschaffen? Oder sollte man nicht schauen, was ist denn eigentlich noch, außer jetzt so die Technokratie und die liberalen Institutionen zu verteidigen, hinaus eigentlich denkbar an Politik? Und traut man sich das zu und traut man das auch den Wählern zu? Und wenn man das denen nicht zutraut, dann muss man sich vielleicht mal überlegen, ob man vielleicht eher eine Furcht vor der Demokratie gerade hat. Ich habe ja im vergangenen Salon dieses Buch sehr ausführlich besprochen von Jörg Barbarowski, Am Volk vorbei. Und das gibt mir doch immer mehr zu denken, warum ich das auch so stark mache, ist, weil wir jetzt eingangs den Podcast mit Heidi Reichinek da gehört haben, dass wir so eine Haltung sehen von, wir müssen die ganze Zeit die Demokratie verteidigen. Das sagen die drei ja da im Podcast. Vielleicht wäre es einfach mal zu sagen, jetzt machen wir gute Politik und lassen wir das mal gerade mit dieser Demokratie verteidigen weg. Vielleicht ergibt sich ja aus dem einen das andere. Aber wenn ich erst sage, ich verteidige die Demokratie und komme dann zu meiner Politik, dann habe ich eigentlich schon den Schulterschluss mit CDU gesucht, weil ich sage, ja, erst mal muss ich ja den institutionellen Rahmen verteidigen und dann gucke ich, welche Politik ich mache. Vielleicht einfach mal sagen, wir machen gute Politik.
Ja, das ist, ich sage es, wie es ist, kein sehr raffiniertes Argument. Wir haben es häufiger gemacht und es stimmt.
Es ist aber trotzdem richtig.
Ja, es ist absolut richtig. Nur der Manu ist irgendwie immer noch das falsche Fundament dafür. Denn so sehr, wie wir hier Leuten vorwerfen, zum Beispiel diesen Frauen in diesem Podcast, dass sie sich so Rosinpicker-mäßig so Themen raushuchen, die sie jetzt interessiert. Und ich eben diese kleine Pointe versucht habe, sagen, ne, dann schaut euch doch die Bundestagssitzungskalender an und fragt euch, wollt ihr das wirklich selber machen?
Aber das will ja Manu auch nicht.
Genau. Aber Manu nimmt sich auch so ein paar Pointen raus, wie zum Beispiel, die können alle abgewählt werden, wo ich mir denke, ja gut, wenn man jetzt so ein Hardcore-Theorie-Demokrat, ich bin ja Wissenschaftler, ich weiß nicht, macht für mich jetzt nicht so attraktiv und so. Also ja, stimmt, aber wir haben halt sehr viel mit Leuten wie Modi, Putin, Xi zu tun, die können nicht abgewählt werden.
Das würde er aber auch nicht sagen, dass das einfach nur illiberale Demokratien sind. Das würde er nicht sagen. Also ihm geht es ja wirklich jetzt um Demokratien, wo die Frage ist, wie viel Verfassungsgericht darf es sein? Aber er sagt ja jetzt nicht, die, also alle Führer dieser Welt sind im Prinzip Demokraten. Das würde er auf keinen Fall sagen.
Aber das mit diesem Verfassungsgericht, ne?
Aber er würde jetzt zum Beispiel bezogen auf Polen oder Ungarn sagen oder auch auf Italien könnte man das so sagen. Dort findet schon demokratische Wahl statt.
Ja, dieses Argument mit der Liberalität in Bezug auf Demokratie. Und dann hat man so Institutionen, die nicht so richtig sich wiederfinden, weil sie nicht gewählt werden. Das Verfassungsgericht, da würde ich einfach. Also ich würde auf so einer Sitzung auf so einem Panel mit ihm dann einfach fragen. Herr Manuel, das verstehe ich schon. Es ist nicht sehr raffiniert. Sagen Sie kurz was zu den Landesverfassungsgerichten. Wie ist das denn da? So, und dann wäre er, glaube ich, total blank, weil du kriegst keine interessante Argumentation fürs Publikum hin, wo du plötzlich so ebenden Unterschiede hast, dass man das Bundesverfassungsgericht, ja, da würde ich sagen, ja, dann mach's doch einfach historisch. Such dir journalistische Pointen. Wir gehen die Geschichte durch. Eine ehemalige Verfassungsrichterin hat jetzt ein Buch darüber geschrieben, wie wichtig das Verfassungsgericht ist, was man da so im Einzelfall machen könnte, aber eben ganz spezifisch bezogen auf das deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht, wie wir es sonst nirgendwo finden. So, aber es ist ja nicht das einzige Verfassungsgericht, sondern wir haben überall Verfassungsgerichte. Die Verfassungsgerichtbarkeit funktioniert auch in allen Bundesländern ein bisschen anders. Wir haben eigene Geschichten. Da wäre er zum Beispiel ganz blank. So, und das würde man aber erwarten, weil er sich ja selber so eine, ich denke jetzt mal theoretisch drüber nach, ich bin unangreifbar für die Attraktivität von Macht. Ich beobachte einfach und so. Also das ist für mich einfach nicht greifbar, was da hergerichtet wird.
Manu wird ja sehr viel gerade rezipiert.
Ich will nur noch anmerken, Das ist sehr gut für ihn, aber das zählt gar nicht.
Ich will nur noch anmerken, wer auch begeistert Philipp Manu rezipiert, Rickard An Lang.
Sehr gut, das passt doch zusammen.
Siehst du? Nein, eben nicht. Das ist ja das Verwunderliche.
Für mich passt das zusammen.
Nachdem, was ich eben im Podcast gehört habe, nicht.
Er redet über die Demokratie, sie redet über die Demokratie. Dass die innerhalb ihres Diskurses Inkompatibilitäten haben.
Weil eben haben wir den Reicheneck Podcast gehört, wo dann Nascha Reicheneck und Lang sich am Ende fragen, über was sollen wir als nächstes sprechen. Also wenn sie wirklich einen sinnvollen Podcast aufnehmen wollen, dann sollten sie jetzt das Buch unter Beobachtung mitbringen. Jeder hat das gelesen. Und dann sollen sie mal genau darüber diskutieren. Weil ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich interessant wäre, aus der politischen Praxis heraus zu erfahren, wie ein progressives Lager darauf blickt, dass also nicht die Demokratie vielleicht in Gefahr ist, aber möglicherweise die liberale Demokratie. Und ob das nur schlecht ist. Das wäre eine Debatte, die würde ich mit den dreien zur Not auch selbst führen wollen. Aber das könnten die zu dritt auch wunderbar in dem Podcast diskutieren.
Da stimme ich zu 100% überein mit der Pointe. Ist mir egal, was sie lesen, Hauptsache, sie lesen. So, wir kommen auf, wie soll man sagen, dem Papst.
Sehr gut.
Wie führt man das ein?
Endlich mal keine Demokratie.
Ja, also wir sind jetzt hier in einer Domäne, wo wir sagen, der Papst. Wir meinen natürlich Leo. Ja. Aber auch die Institution. Aber die Institution ist so special, dass es gerade Leo ist.
Ja, der Papst, wenn er spricht, spricht er auch für 2000 Jahre Kirchengeschichte, für alle Katholiken.
Genau. Aber es ist halt trotzdem gerade Leo Papst. So. Und das ist eine sehr interessante Konstellation. Und ich will es im Grunde nur mitbringen, weil die Thematisierungen von Leo dem 16. Oder ist er der 14.? Ne, der 16.,
ne?
In Deutschland finde ich interessant. Er hat eine, ihn umweht ein gewisses Unangreifbarkeitsdogma. Und ich finde, aber das wird nicht thematisiert, es ist noch viel interessanter, dass der Papst gerade der Antagonist zu Trump ist, während alle gewartet haben darauf, dass es endlich mal ein Antagonist ist.
Und es wirklich drohte, dass der iranische Ayatollah in diese Rolle des Puh, auch wir in Deutschland freuen uns, dass endlich mal jemand, jetzt sind wir plötzlich Ayatollah-Fans. Nee, das wäre blöd. Also in diese Rolle rutscht jetzt zum Glück der Papst rein. Also wirklich ein Glück. Wie das in Deutschland so thematisiert wird, finde ich hervorragend. Deswegen machen wir random-mäßig. Wir gucken einfach verschiedene Clips. Wir fangen an mit Jürgen Erbacher wohl. Das ist das CDUF-Heutejournal. Es gibt ja überall immer so Vatikan-Korrespondenten. Die HR-Kirchenredaktion und so.
Ja, aber das ist der tollste Job.
Es ist wirklich genial. Ich überlege auch schon, ob ich mich da einfach bewerbe, denn einmal die Woche kann ich ja wohl.
Ich glaube, du musst Latein und Italienisch können.
Das werde ich dir noch ausreden. Das schreibe ich aber auch in meinen 1000 Seiten Bewerbungsgespräch dazu. Also, heutejournal zum Thema Papst.
Also, da gibt es einiges. Aber die Diplomaten schätzen gerade die Diskretion des Vatikans. Deshalb bekommt man wenig mit. Aber die Drähte klühen schon rund um den Vatikan.
Im Sinne des Friedens. Herzlichen Dank, Jürgen Erbacher. Jürgen, ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt. Deine Doku, Leo der 14. Ein Papst sucht seinen Kurs, läuft heute 23.30 Uhr im ZDF Fernsehen und gibt es bereits jetzt bei uns zu streamen.
So, es wird also groß auf Filme verwiesen. Und es ist ganz toll, dass der Papst da ist. Und er kümmert sich auch um den Frieden. Aber wir wissen nicht, wie. Denn das ist eine Diplomatie, die natürlich nicht auf so was Profanes wie Aufmerksamkeit in Massenmedien, Silicon Valley, Siloos oder dem freien Internet Rücksicht nehmen muss. Auch sehr gut Herr Schüler, Professor Thomas Schüler, hat einen Lehrstuhl, der irgendwas zum Thema macht. Und wir hören.
Biologie jetzt, oder?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall in Theologe. Ich glaube in Münster. Er ist zugeschaltet bei HR der Tag, wo man ja ein bisschen Freiraum hat, mal einfach so zu sagen, was man so denkt. Und hier wird es konkret auf Trump auf der einen Seite, Papst auf der anderen Seite. Wir haben sehr viele Urteile über Trump gehört. Jetzt hören wir mal ein bisschen Lobhudelei über den Papst. Ich schließe mich natürlich komplett an.
Ja, es ist unklug. Wir haben schon viele festgestellt, bei diesem Konflikt, sich mit dem Papst anzulegen. Er ist die letzte moralische Instanz der Welt. Er ist multilateral unterwegs. Der Vatikan hat in allen Ländern der Welt diplomatische Vertretungen. Er ist ein völkerrechtliches Subjekt. Und er ist die Stimme der Moral und des Anstandes. Und da kann Herr Trump diesen Vatikan, diesen Papst auch nicht mit Zöllen belegen. Er ist machtlos und steht politisch nackt vor ihm da. Er hat aus diesem Streit nur verloren.
Schöner kann man es nicht zusammenfassen.
Ich finde, als ihr es gesagt habt, ist es die letzte moralische Instanz. Was sagen wir dazu? Wir haben ja auch alle Meinungen, was Gute und Böse ist.
Die letzte vielleicht nicht, aber sagen wir eine Instanz, die auf der Weltbühne gehört wird.
Ja, wir haben es auf jeden Fall mit einer Instanz zu tun, bei der wir immer mitlaufen lassen, dass andere auf sie hören.
Sehr richtig, ja.
Also der Herr Hegemann ist irgendwie im Vatikan zu Hause. Weshalb wir, ich kündige es schon mal an, im Salon einen Text lesen vom Vatikan, 22.000 Worte. Und es ist ein Text, auf den wir gewartet haben, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist noch keine Enzyklika. Aber kannst du dich erinnern, wir haben explizit gesagt, wir warten hier auf eine Enzyklika des Papstes zum Thema KI. Und zu diesem, er ist eine moralische Instanz, gehört auf jeden Fall eine normative Linie. Was der Papst sagt, gilt, auch wenn ich es kognitiv besser weiß, weil ich ja weiß, die normativen Grundsätze, die formuliert werden, gelten erstmal grundsätzlich für alle, die zuhören. Eine Enzyklika würde sich ja immer an alle richten, an alle Menschen von Interesse, die sie oder und so weiter. So, in dem Falle haben wir es jetzt mit einem Text zu tun vom Vatikan über das Verhältnis von künstlicher Intelligenz und menschlicher Intelligenz. Und ich werde schon mal ankündigen, ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, dass ich mich unterwerfe. Also wenn der Papst jetzt Räume definiert, in denen sich die KI nicht einwischen darf, wird es für mich ab sofort gelten. Ich hoffe, es steht nicht drin, dass man seine Podcasts nicht mit Kloot vorbereiten darf.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Vielleicht hast du vorher im August, wenn wir den Live-Salon machen, eine kleine Live-Taufe für dich?
Nein, denn ich werde mich natürlich... Also, ich mache jetzt im Mai meine erste Vatikan-Tour.
Oh je, ja.
Also, die Museen, Sixtinische Kapelle, Petersdom. Ein Tag vor Pfingstsonntag. Ich hoffe, es ist alle schon geschmückt. Ich weiß natürlich, dass ich mich nicht bekehren lassen werde.
Wie der Tannhäuser auf Knien wirst du da sein.
Tannhäuser kommt auch wieder ins Programm. Schön. Also, seid gespannt, wie es hier weitergeht. Aber wir hören jetzt noch einen Clip. Die HR-Kirchenredaktion ist natürlich auch zugeschaltet. Und es ist ein sehr interessanter Spruch zu dem, was ich eben einführen sagte. Also, wir haben einen Papst, aber es ist schon Leo XVI. Das ist gerade nicht Benedikt. Das macht schon einen Unterschied. Und es ist auch gerade der Antagonist ist Trump und nicht, was weiß ich, wer damals regierte, George W. Bush oder so.
Ich glaube, Leo vergleicht sich gar nicht mit irgendwem, der vor ihm Papst war. Er hat natürlich Bezüge, aber er geht so eben den ganz eigenen Weg. Natürlich, er hat eine ganz andere Amtsführung als Franziskus. Er ist nicht dieser charismatische Mensch, der durch die Kurie wirbelt, sondern er hat sehr hohen Respekt für die Kurie. Er ist ihr mit großer Wertschätzung wieder begegnet, hat sie wieder eigentlich deutlich gemacht. Er hat ja irgendwann gesagt, die Päpste kommen und gehen, aber die Kurie bleibt.
So, die Päpste kommen und gehen, aber die Kurie bleibt. Die Kurie ist ja diese Art Vorstandsverwaltung der Kirche in Rom selbst. Jetzt wird ja Leo schon wieder angefeindet, weil er gefragt wurde, Herr Papst, wie halten Sie es mit den Segnungen homosexueller Paare? Und er sagt, kann ich nie machen. Und es knackt natürlich so ein bisschen an progressiven Erwartungen, die an ihn herangetragen werden. Und da würde ich sagen, in diesem Spruch, der hier gerade referiert wurde, steckt im Grunde die, wir haben es eben schon mal genannt, Erlaubnisstruktur, um zu sagen, der Papst lehnt sich gegen Trump auf, weil das zwei Menschen sind, die jetzt gerade zeitgleich in dieser Welt und so weiter Dinge regeln. Die Frage, wer wird hier gesegnet und so weiter, ist allerdings eine Entscheidung der Kurie.
Naja, es könnte eine Entscheidung des Papstes sein, aber dann...
Könnte. Wenn er durch die Kurie wirbeln würde.
Dann, naja, das wäre jetzt auch nicht nur ein Problem für die Kurie, sondern das eine ist ja, was deutsche Bischöfe gerne tun würden und was die anderen Bischöfe dazu sagen. Und wir haben ja den Film Konklave gesehen. Und wir wissen, dass jetzt im Vergleich zu vielen Teilen der Welt jetzt deutsche Bischöfe als progressiv zu bezeichnen wäre. Zumindest jetzt in solchen Fragen, während das jetzt in anderen Ländern ganz anders aussehen würde. Das heißt, der Papst würde natürlich, wenn er das jetzt legitimiert für Deutschland, das ja für die Weltkirche legitimieren. Und dann gäbe es da wahrscheinlich sehr viel Gegendruck, weil da die katholische Kirche eben aus sehr viel konservativen und auch homophoben Leuten besteht. Und auch zum Teil einfach aus einem gänzlich anderen Familienbild, das sagt, nein, die Ehe ist für Mann und Frau vorgesehen und die verdient auch den besonderen Schutz und da kann man auch nicht so Zwischenstufen oder sowas wählen. Also gibt es verschiedene Ansätze dazu. Und die Kurie an sich ist natürlich noch mal eher auch so zu sehen, das ist ja quasi mehr so die Verwaltung des Ganzen. Das ist ja nicht nur ideologisch, das ist ja nicht nur ideologisch, aber da liegt ja eben auch sehr viel an dem, was... Also Kurie würde man ja eher mit einem System, das da entstanden ist, vergleichen, wo ja sehr viel Machenschaften sind. Also da geht es ja nicht um ideologische Auseinandersetzung nur. Da sind ja auch ganz andere Machenschaften. Weshalb ja auch Franziskus dann auch mit seiner Idee der Kirche der Armen gegen diesen Pomp der Kurie sich positioniert hat. Und die Kurie dann sehr mächtig ist, weil da viele natürlich Besitzstandswarend unterwegs sind und eigentlich auch, sagen wir, sehr weltlichen, nämlich monetär gelösten Folgen leisten.
Das sieht man ja in jeder, wie soll man sagen, wo die Reformation nicht so drüber gewischt ist, dass man sich fragt, wieso gibt es ja so viele Altare und so? Das waren ja nur die kleinen Kassenhäuschen.
Ja, das auch.
So. Also, Papste kommen und gehen, das würde natürlich der Manu auch nochmal ganz gut gutieren, dass Papste auch gehen.
Durch Tod in der Regel.
Sie werden nicht abgewählt, aber sie gehen.
Nur selten durch Rücktritt.
Wir befassen uns noch kurz mit Nachwehen der Klingbeil-Rede.
Oh ja.
Die wir ja letzten Monat geschaut haben. Klingbeil hat es selbst nicht geschafft, da irgendwie Traktion drunter zu legen, sondern das schleicht sich ja so rein einfach. Und wir machen das natürlich über Bande, indem wir dem Herrn Hegemann nachspüren, den wir bei Robin Alexander zuverlässig finden, weil das der Podcast ist, wo wir unterstellen, dass da alle zuhören. Und da wurde natürlich auch Nachwege betrieben. Zum einen im Machtwechsel vom 27.3. und dann vom 15. April. Da ist dann schon Entscheidungen, die im Koalitionsausschuss und so werden thematisiert. Und der Tenor hier lautet Lars Klingbeil von der SPD macht Vorschläge. Dann sagt März, hab ich zur Kenntnis genommen, ich war aber im Bundestag. Und dann sagt die Reiche, ich hab ja auch so eine Agenda. Und dann sagt März, ähm, sorry Herr Klingbeil, ich bin gerade mit Frau Reiche beschäftigt. Und dann sagen die Parlamentarier, ja, Frau Connewitz hat auch gute Ideen, müssen wir jetzt unbedingt immer Klingbeil und so. Und am Ende ist dann alles, was Frau Connewitz wollte. Und wir wissen, das ist im Grunde die rechte Hand von März. Und da werden immer Konflikte aufgemacht, die gar nicht da sind. Einfach nur, damit März sagen kann, ähm, sorry, wir müssen jetzt das machen, was die Connewitz wollte, weil sonst ist hier Streit. Oder so. Dann ist Oma Erna wieder unruhig, weil man ihr keinen geruhsamen Abend wünschen kann. Also Robin Alexander beginnt hier am 27.3., also relativ frisch, über die Klingbeiräte zu reden.
Also Montag hat er sozusagen die Parteiposition gefestigt, um dann Mittwoch in die Offensive zu kommen, mit dem er sich, wie beschrieben, an die Spitze der Reformdebatte setzt. Und ich glaube, dass er mit dem Move auch die Personaldebatte in der SPD gewonnen hat. Weil wenn die sich an diesem Freitag treffen, dann werden die doch nicht mehr beraten, wie ist Rheinland-Pfalz gelaufen und wie gut oder schlecht sind Klingbeil und Bas, dann werden sie ihm ein Mandat geben für diese Reform, die er vorgeschlagen hat. Und damit ist er tatsächlich in die Vorhand gekommen, weil jetzt können die Leute sagen, guck mal, die SPD sagt ABCD. Ja, dazu kann man sich verhalten. Aber plötzlich ist der Reformprozess, der ja vorher bei der Union war, der ist plötzlich bei der SPD.
Ja, Klingbeil hat umgesetzt, was er jetzt...
Also ich sag einfach so, ja, das war ungefähr die dümmste Zusammenfassung, was so Dynamiken sind zu und dann... Ja, genau, ja. Also der Reformprozess war vorher bei der CDU, genau. Weil nämlich Klingbeil sagte, mehr arbeiten, Rentner jetzt auch arbeiten. Das ist der Reformprozess in den Händen der CDU. Und dann sagt Klingbeil, ich mach mal drei Sätze dazu, wie wir alle alle ein bisschen runter rocken. Und dann sagt er, ja, jetzt ist der Herr Jürgen Rübergelwander zum Herrn Klingbeil und Dagmar Rosenfeld so, ja, genau, so war das.
Ich finde, das ist auch eine merkwürdige Vorstellung von gesellschaftlicher und politischer Debatte. Das könnte man sagen, jetzt habe ich hier den einen Hebel, den lege ich mal um. Dann geht die Sache in diese Richtung. Wenn es dann dahin läuft, dann kann ich dann wieder den anderen Hebel verwenden. Und dann machen wir eine Drehung und dann kommt es bei mir wieder an. Das sind ja so Vorstellungen von einer Allmacht und Kontrolle, wo ich einfach sage, der eine ergibt das andere. Und die Akteure werden hier mit großen Plänen und Strategien ausgestattet, die ich eher nicht sehe.
Du erinnerst dich ja, wir haben ja Robin Alexander's Buch gelesen. Da gibt es ja keine Gedankenwelt oder Reflexion oder irgendeine Metaebene über irgendetwas. Sondern Leute sitzen halt an dem Hebel und dann machen sie den so dahin und dann dahin. Es ist halt alles ein bisschen einfacher zu denken.
Der ja vorher bei der Union war, der ist plötzlich bei der SPD.
Ja, Klingbeil hat umgesetzt, was er ja auch angekündigt hat. Es hilft jetzt nichts über Personen zu reden. Wir müssen über Inhalte reden. Und das tun wir jetzt tatsächlich seit seiner Rede am Mittwoch. Du hast es die Flucht nach vorn genannt. Und die wird ja von manchen als Klingbeils Schröder-Moment beschrieben.
Ja, also von dir Dagmar Rosenfeld.
Also ein Parteivorsitzende, der seiner Partei Reformvorhaben zumutet. Über Klingbeils konkrete Vorschläge werden wir gleich noch sprechen. Aber die Reformen haben insgesamt, die verstoßen ja schon gegen das, was nicht wenigen Parteifunktionären als sozialdemokratische Gewissheit gilt.
Ja, umso mehr steht die Frage im Raum, wer genau sieht da jetzt den Schröder-Moment? Also aus der SPD hat man das nicht gehört. Puh, endlich ist wieder ein Gerhard Schröder da, der eine Reformagenda, mutig.
Ja, es ist immer nur dieser Journalismus. Ich kriege das ja auch viel mit, wenn man Handelsblatt-Podcasts hört, dann ist das ja auch da, Tenor. Dass wann immer ein Sozialdemokrat aufsteht und etwas Unsozialdemokratisches fordert, gibt es unendlichen Applaus und Mut und Zuspruch und all das. Ja, das ist ja keine Kunst, das herzustellen. Also das ist ja...
Aber die selben kommentieren, dass das ja voll positiv gesehen wird.
Ja, klar.
Ja, die CDU währenddessen.
Dann geht Klingbeil in die Offensive und das Kanzleramt war nicht vorgewarnt. März hat ja parallel im Bundestag gesprochen und da fiel ja richtig auf, dass das die interessante Begebenheit nicht im Bundestag war, sondern in dieser Bertelsmann Stiftung und dann auch am Donnerstag, wo man gedacht hätte, na, jetzt kommt halt die CDU mal mit ihren Vorschlägen um die Ecke, kam die nicht mit ihren Vorschlägen um die Ecke, sondern die Vorschläge von Lars Klingbeil dominieren weiter den Reformdiskurs. Das ist schon tatsächlich eine wirklich bemerkenswerte Konstellation.
Ja, ich frage mich, also wir haben die Rede ja gehört, Schritt für Schritt. Was ist nochmal so bemerkenswert daran und glaubwürdig, dass Klingbeil März nicht vorher Bescheid gesagt hat, hör mal zu, wenn du heute im Bundestag deine Befragung des Bundeskanzlers hast, rede ich bei der Bertelsmann Stiftung, aber keine Sorge, es ist genau dein Text. Ja. Ich werde bei der Krankenversicherung die Ehefrauen rausnehmen. Dann werden wir das ganze Lohngefüge absenken, also diese Rampe der Förderung von Familien und so weiter. Und dann werde ich nichts zur Erbschaftsstelle sagen. Und ganz kurz sagen, es wäre schon wünschenswert, also es wäre wünschenswert, wenn man beim Thema Vermögen noch mal kurz, noch drei Sekunden.
Ja.
Worüber wundert sich Robin Alexander gerade? Über den Mut von Klingbeil, März vorher nicht bescheid zu sagen, dass er jetzt das EU-Programm bei der Bertelsmann Stiftung vorliest.
Lieber Friedrich, ich verwandele mich heute Abend in einen Klon von dir und werde deine Position vortreten.
Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen grotesk, na gut.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch absurd, das zeigt ja, wie konservativ überhaupt diese ganze Berichterstattung ist. Niemals würde man es andersrum machen. Also man würde nie sagen, warum sind jetzt nicht mal mutige CDUler da, die eine dezidiert linke Position vertreten?
Würde man ja nicht sagen. Ja, würde ja gleich Bert Rührow und so. Völlig überraschende Clips, ich würde sich mehr Bürgergeld fordern.
Ja, so weit ist es gekommen.
So weit ist es gekommen. Also Robin Alexander möchte auch noch ein paar innertliche Anmerkungen machen, bei denen ich mich so frage, sorry?
Die Idee, die Rente auf Lebensarbeitszeit abzustellen, ist natürlich wirklich interessant, weil du dadurch Akademiker mit den langen Ausbildungszeiten hinterher auch länger in der Arbeit hast. Und die berühmten Dachdecker und andere, die immer ins Feld geführt werden, die früh anfangen zu arbeiten, also eben nicht zur Uni gehen, können früher raus. Also das ist der Versuch, etwas sozialdemokratisch zu erzählen, was dringend gemacht werden muss, nämlich bei steigender Lebenszeit auch steigende Lebensarbeitszeit zu haben.
Robin, und damit rettet er ja eigentlich auch die Rente mit 63, eine UR SPD Idee, ohne sie als solche nennen zu müssen.
So, ich referiere kurz, wir müssen jetzt nicht ein Bildgenerator anschmeißen. Jeder versteht sofort, was ich visualisiere. Zwei Bilder. Auf der einen Seite, wie die glauben, dass eine universitäre Ausbildung ist. Ein großes Kreuzfahrtschiff mit jeden Tag Eiscreme. Alle Obstsorten, die es gibt zum Frühstück und eine Achterbahn oben auf dem Dach fährt durch die Karibik. Und jetzt die Realität. Alle sind psychisch krank, man lebt ökonomisch verletzlich. Das erste Mal weit weg von den Eltern, dort wo irgendein Vermieter sagt, ja klar kostet es 50 Euro der Quadratmeter, was hast denn du gedacht? So, ja, das passt nicht zusammen. Ach, die haben später angefangen mit Arbeiten. Warum? Die haben fünf Jahre lang studiert, sofort rausnehmen. Diesen Wellness-Halligalli können wir uns nicht mehr leisten.
Um dann zu sagen, der rettet die Rente mit 63.
Es ist unglaublich, was wir hier hören. Na gut, Robin Alexander sagt auch was zum Thema GKV, also die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung. Denn da gibt es Argumentationen mit Verhetzungspotenzial. Da würde ich mich fragen. Also dann muss man aber fragen, wer hetzt.
Ist aber auch wieder, finde ich, ein Vorschlag, der, wie sagt man, in politischen Berlin immer so schön Verhetzungspotenzial bietet. Weil in der gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung gibt es ja eine, also wer viel bezahlt, subventioniert die, die wenig bezahlen mit. Das ist völlig in Ordnung. Ist ja eine Versicherung und keine Sparkasse. Aber wir haben ja auch eine Menge Leute, die gar nicht einzahlen und über die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung versorgt werden. Zum Beispiel Flüchtlinge.
Und Bürgergeldempfänger.
Und Bürgergeldempfänger. Und dann die Diskussion zu machen, die darfst du mitfinanzieren, aber die eigene Ehefrau nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, Verhetzungspotenzial, schwierige Debatte.
Also müssen wir die auch noch rauskegeln, die Bürgergeldempfänger oder was?
Ich finde es aber sehr gut, wenn Robin Alexander auf Verhetzungspotenzial hinweist. Für die anderen. So, Achtung, jetzt hetzt wieder irgendwer. Aber ich würde euch nur darauf hinweisen, also das haben die jetzt so organisiert, der Klingbeil. Der sagt jetzt, du darfst für deine Frau nicht mehr bezahlen, aber für die Migranten bitte weiter und für die Bürgergeldempfänger auch. Hat Verhetzungspotenzial.
Aber Vorsicht.
Vorsicht, Vorsicht.
Nicht noch dreimal sagen.
Jetzt nicht verhetzen, genau. So, ich nochmal erklärt. Also es ist wirklich brutal. Was Robin Alexander natürlich sehr gefällt ist, dass es sich jetzt ausgewummstert hat. Kein Geld mehr. Ich erinnere nochmal dran, 200 Milliarden für die Energiekonzerne, 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr und dann ein bisschen Corona-Hilfe, ein bisschen Tankrabatt und so. Aber jetzt ist Geld alle.
Und von der Leyen hat er jetzt auch...
Wir haben euch so viel gezahlt.
CDU hat ja getagt, von der Leyen hat er jetzt auch gesagt, also es geht nicht, dass wir immer mehr Schulden aufnehmen. Also sie verkündet 90 Milliarden mehr für die Ukraine, was ja bedeutet auch Kredite. Also die Ukraine soll sich auch mehr verschulden. Wir verschulden uns damit. Aber man soll sich generell nicht mehr verschulden.
Das heißt... Nein, das Geld ist alle. Wir sind in der Post-Wumms-Ära.
Wir können nicht jede Krise und jedes Problem einfach mit noch mehr Geld beantworten.
Ja, auch hier kommt überraschend die Realität zu ihrem Recht, weil...
Ja, das ist einfach die Realität.
Also ich finde es schon, das ist so ganz deprimierend. Wir haben hier den Podcast auch angefangen. Da war das so immer mehr, dass auch im Mainstream die Modern Monetary Theory diskutiert wurde, dass man anders über Schulden sprach. Man hat dann gesagt, eigentlich sind es keine Schuldenberge, sondern Vermögensberge. Also dieser Diskurs war ja mal eine Zeit lang doch schon relativ präsent und dass einfach nichts von übrig geblieben ist, außer dass man sagt, ja, aufrüsten können wir noch und nöchern. Wir machen einfach ein Sondervermögen nach dem nächsten. Und das war's. Man hat das komplette abgeräumte Projekt gescheitert.
Die Realität kam halt rein.
Hier kommt überraschend die Realität zu ihrem Recht, weil das Geld ist einfach alle. Aber du hast völlig recht, das ist die Emanzipation.
Das Geld ist einfach alle. Also ich war ja zuletzt viel an Europa unterwegs. Athen, Lissabon, ein bisschen Barcelona, jetzt Rom. Wir haben in Deutschland schon einen anderen Standard so insgesamt. Also wenn man in Lissabon durch die Straßen geht und man denkt sich so, alter, es ist Februar, was ist hier im Juli? Hier sind 45 Grad. Da sitzen die dann alle in dieser einen Ecke, die sie so ein bisschen gekühlt kriegen durch diesen kleinen Apparat, den sie sich da gekauft haben und man denkt sich so, wow, ich habe echt Mitleid. Und es geht kilometerlang so quasi kestenweise Menschen da drin. Und dass man in Deutschland einfach sagt, das Geld ist alle. Das ist doch grotesk. Also was sollen die denn dann da sagen in Portugal und Griechenland und so? Das ist einfach nicht schlimm.
Das ist die Vision von Lars Klingbeil von Olaf Scholz. Weil was war der Kern des Olaf Scholz Versprechen? You'll never walk alone. Also, wann immer etwas passiert, von Euro-Krise, Finanzkrise, Corona-Krise, der Russe überfällt die Ukraine. Wann immer es große Einbrüche in der Wirtschaft ist, dann stellt der Staat viele, viele Milliarden ins Schaufenster. Den Wumms, den Doppelwumms, den Quadruppelwumms. Und jetzt hat es sich ausgewumst.
Ja, also You'll never walk alone ist natürlich ein bisschen krass, das so auf diese Formel zu bringen. Aber das sollte ja nun wirklich grundsätzlich das Verschränknis von politischer Aufgabestellung sein.
Ja, aber ich möchte dann wieder in drei Wochen den Podcast hören. Ja, das ist wirklich traurig, dass die Leute, die das Vertrauen in unsere herrliche Demokratie verloren haben. Das ist alles so unsinnig und immer nur von Leuten vorgetragen, wo ich einfach, also da würde ich, wenn ich regieren würde, ich hätte ja durchaus auch autoritäre Züge. Ich würde dann einfach nach so einem Podcast sagen, so bei der Bank anrufen, Robin Alexander muss 50.000 Euro jetzt mal überweisen. Irgendwohin. Dann kommt er jetzt einfach weggenommen als kleine Strafe. Einfach so, ich will never walk alone, das Geld kommt jetzt weg.
Vor allem, was ich sehr gut finde, you never walk alone ist nicht mehr. Was bedeutet you will walk alone? Wohin? Nur an die Front.
Jaja, denn da, das haben wir ja heute bei Christina Dunz gelernt, da entsteht ja wieder der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt, den wir sonst abräumen.
Es ist zwar schade, dass wir deine Familie auseinandernehmen müssen, aber Front. Jetzt kommt, was immer kommt, Robin Alexander gönnt sich eine kleine Pointe, dass man die eigentlich ausarbeiten müsste, dass uns hier noch sehr viel Grundlagenwissen dazu fehlt, dass uns die große Merkel-Abrechnung fehlt und alles Mögliche. Das ist wirklich absurd. Also es kommt kurz auf den Streit Söder-Habeck. Habeck ist ja politischer Flüchtling, hat Asyl woanders gesucht, deswegen kann man das jetzt leider nicht nacharbeiten. Aber jetzt, so nachträglich, kommt jetzt das kleine Zugeständnis von Robin Alexander.
Deswegen ist das Kartellrecht jetzt wie...
So, es wird hier Söder kurz eingespielt....
wichtig, nicht nur drüber zu reden, sondern tatsächlich die Zähne zu schärfen.
Und dann geht es natürlich um Übergewinne. Die Zähne des Kartellrechts schärfen und jetzt Übergewinne und hier mal ein bisschen Benzinpreise.
Um klarzumachen, wenn hier möglicherweise Missbräuche stattfinden, dann muss da schnell reagiert werden und nicht in jahrelangem Verfahren. Und zum anderen wird jetzt auf europäischer Ebene diskutiert, wie Abschöpfung bei einer Übergebühr oder Übergewinn. Ich halte das Konzept für richtig und es soll auch verfolgt werden.
Lieber Jürgen und Thürer, Sie können es nicht sehen, aber Robin lacht. Und zwar aus tiefstem Herzen.
Ein herrlicher Autor. Also das musst du erstmal bringen. Du erklärst die Grünen zum Hauptfein, zum Gottsalbein und sind dem Mann zum Kinderbuchautor und gut, dass er weg ist. Und in der Krise setzt du dich hin. Du machst nicht nur die gleichen Maßnahmen, sondern du liest auch seinen Sprechzettel vor. Das ist echt Rutspe. Das muss man sich trauen.
Ja, das ist keine Rutspe und das muss man sich nicht auch trauen, sondern Ding Dong, hier kommt wirklich mal die Realität. Ja. Gegen jede Erklärung von Robin Alexander war die unbeliebteste Regierung der Nachkriegszeit, Ampel, offenbar nicht die dümmste, sondern sie hat einfach nur vernünftig Politik gemacht. Und zwar, man kommt nicht an iotopfam vorbei. Egal, ob man Söder ist und ihm kann es eigentlich egal sein, er ist ein halber Milliardär und ist der König von Bayern. Aber nicht mal er kommt um Habeck-Politik herum. Das muss einem doch zu denken geben, so als politischer Journalist auch. Hat man vielleicht die letzten Jahre Quatsch erzählt in seinem Podcast? Hat man vielleicht Blödsinn in Bücher geschrieben? Erzählt man jetzt gerade wieder Quatsch? Aber er lacht, er findet es lustig. Dagmar findet Robins Lachen lustig. Wir sollen ein bisschen mit lachen oder was auch immer. Also es ist wirklich schräg. Jetzt kommt ein Clip, den müssen wir dechiffrieren. Es wird nochmal auf Merz und Söder und so referiert.
Dass Merz gar nichts ausschließt, ist ja schon mal eine harte Abgrenzung zu Marco Söder, der in einem Interview zu Beginn der Woche sehr viel ausgeschlossen hat.
So, Söder hat also sehr viel ausgeschlossen. Merz sagt zum Beispiel, Rente wird nur noch Ding sein und Familien kriegen keine Mitversicherung mehr und so weiter. Und jetzt sagt Söder, nee, das machen wir alles nicht. Da würde ich ja mal sagen, ja, das ist halt so, dass Söder einfach einen Plan hat davon, wie man das Volk ruhig hält. Man schießt auf Migranten, aber nicht auf Familien. Man macht irgendwas mit Herdprämie. Hauptsache, man kommt irgendwie so durch. Dann vergehen so 20 Jahre und man merkt, CSU regiert immer noch und so weiter und so fort. Wenn Merz jetzt durchzieht, also Merz sagt einfach, nee, wir müssen jetzt alles sparen. Also wir nehmen jetzt mal alle Feiertage raus, alle arbeiten mehr und Rente ist nur noch Grundsicherung und so weiter. Wie sieht dann Deutschland in 20 Jahren aus? Die AfD hat einmal zehn Jahre durchregiert, alles liegt da nieder und wir können froh sein, wenn es nicht im Krieg ausgebrochen ist. So, das kann Söder natürlich antizipieren. Jetzt würde ich sagen, das ist halt so politische Intelligenz auf absolut Flughöhe zwei Meter. Das feiert man nicht noch ab, dass der Söder, der macht hier nochmal eine Begrenzung oder was auch immer. Da bin ich fast Axeleterist und sage, liebe CDU, mach CDU pur. Dann warten wir immer fünf Jahre. Ich will die Hölle sehen. Also das über den Iran zu sagen, ist ja einfach. Ich will die Hölle in Deutschland dann sehen. Und dann gucken wir mal, ziehen wir mal Bilanz. Und dann soll keiner kommen und sagen, ist irgendwie komisch, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Der war so ein rhetorisches Talent. Also da liegen ja alle Paarden schon bereit. Jetzt kommen wir zu Bert Rürup. Bert Rürup ist also einer der Mitbauer des Sozialstaats, wie wir ihn kennen. Irgendwelche Firmen bauen irgendwelche Finanzkonstrukte. Alle Omas sind Pleite und Herr Marschmeier ist Milliardär. So, selbst der Typ.
Gut zusammengefasst.
Als Chef-Volkswirt des Handelsblattes. Wo man sich fragt, wozu braucht das Handelsblatt ein Volks-Chef-Wirt oder wie das auch immer heißt. Das ist doch bescheuert. Das ist doch einfach nur, das ist so, als würde ich dich jetzt hier immer als...
Aber das ist schon...
Wie sollten wir uns nennen hier im Podcast? Du bist der Imperator und ich bin Präsident des Neuen Zwanziger Podcasts.
Chef-Intellektueller, Chef-Chefdenker, irgendwie sowas.
Und wenn sie das gut finden, wie wir hier darüber reden, über die Wirtschaft, dann abonnieren sie doch unser Newsletter.
Ja, aber das haben wir ja ohnehin, dass man also solche Titel sich gibt. Das ist ja so ein bisschen wie in der alten KOK-Zeit, wo jeder noch mal so ein Titel bekam vom Kaiser. Und so ist es heute auch und wir haben es ja schon mehrmals thematisiert, man verleiht sich gegenseitig Preise.
Das fehlt auch noch, dass wir uns hier richtige Podcastpreise und dann aber richtig eingravieren. Der Titel in voller Länge, dreizeitig. CTO, P, FD, GH und noch zuständig fürs Pressegericht. So, mehr Drürup. Aber doch nicht unmöglich ist, diese Diskussion, da ist natürlich noch Michael Hüther, er macht die kleine Rampe, Diskussion auch zu führen.
Ja und es wäre auch legitimierend, also diese 1000 Euro, die ja jetzt verlängert worden, habe ich wieder mal gehört. Ja, also das ist für mich also der Versuch, einen Atler mit ganz, ganz winzig kleinen Strohtkügelchen zu treffen. Das heißt, sehr viel sinnvoller wäre es doch einfach, das Bürgergeld zu erhöhen für die Leute, von denen wir wissen, dass sie arm sind. Und den anderen müsste man den Mut haben, dafür ist eine große Koalition klar zu machen. Ja, wir gehen jetzt durch die Duras Strecke.
Ja, Duras Strecke. Was wir hier hören ist, ist Bert Rüre plötzlich so ein Progressiver, der sagt, die Arme sollen ein bisschen mehr Geld haben. Nein, was er eigentlich sagt ist, bei dem ganzen Trubble, der jetzt ansteht, kann man den Arm nicht einfach fünf Euro mehr im Monat hinwerfen.
Ja.
Das ist eigentlich skandalös genug, aber es kommt hier plötzlich als so ein progressives Ding rüber.
Jaja, also die Sache ist, dass sie sich darüber aufregen, dass jetzt die Maßnahmen, die ergriffen werden, um zu kompensieren, wie hoch die Energiepreise sind, erstmal nicht richtig treffen. Dann kommt hinzu, dass sie sagen, naja, da ja wirklich Wohlstand abfließt aus dem Land, dadurch, dass die Preise teurer sind und diese Gewinne ja nicht an den Deutschland gemacht werden, sondern die werden ja woanders, wie wir wissen, gemacht. Heißt, dass das also Geld abfließt weniger da ist und damit müsste man einfach zurechtkommen, dass das so ist. Und dann könnte man denen, die gar nicht weiter vorankommen und das sind dann die Bürgergeldempfänger, die gar keinen Spielraum haben, sagen, wir erhöhen denen nochmal etwas das Bürgergeld. Nun bin ich ja auch jemand, der sagt, diese Maßnahmen, die da jetzt ergriffen wurden, die greifen viel zu kurz. Aber was hier ja so als Eindruck entsteht und das ist ja auch bei Monika Schnitzer in ähnlicher Weise ausgeführt worden, bei einem Talkshow-Auftritt ist, dass man der Ansicht ist, ja, da gibt es noch arme Leute, denen müssen wir nochmal helfen. Aber so in der Mitte wird das doch nicht allzu schlimm sein, wenn die für 30 oder 50 Euro mehr tanken im Monat. Wenn man aber dann sich ansieht, wer da mit dieser Mitte gemeint ist, der das doch gar nicht so viel ausmacht, dann sind das einfach Leute, die haben 400, 600 Euro zum Konsumieren im Monat und da fehlen dann plötzlich 50 Euro. Das macht dann schon erheblich was aus. Und wenn man dann sieht, dass generell die Preise gestiegen sind, dass wir ja auch wieder von einer Inflation von 2,9 Prozent jetzt sprechen. Und bei Lebensmittel geht das dann immer sehr viel schneller. Mit dem Dünger wird das ja vermutlich dann sehr krass noch einmal ansteigen, wenn dann eine wirkliche Knappheit entsteht. Dann heißt das ja, dass wir über diese Normalinflation hinaus, das ist eben ganz wichtig zu verstehen, diese generelle Inflationsrate hinaus, noch einmal eine besondere Inflation haben bei den alltäglichen Einkäufen wie auch bei der Energie. Es nutzt mir nichts, wenn ich alles zusammenwerfe, alle Preise und dann sage 2,9 Prozent, ich muss bei einem normalen Haushalt einfach ausgehen davon, wie viel Geld kann im Monat ausgeben werden für Konsum. Das heißt Supermarkt, Tankstelle, solche Dinge, Kleidung. Dann muss ich sehen, wie haben sich da die Preise verändert. Und wenn sich dann herausstellt, tanken ist jetzt 30 Prozent teurer und wegen mir gewisse Lebensmittel 10 Prozent teurer, dann haben die Leute von diesen 500 Euro plötzlich 80 Euro weniger oder 90 Euro weniger. Dann haben die eine Inflationsrate für ihren Konsum, also eine, sagen wir, Portemonnaie-Inflationsrate von 12, 14 oder 16 Prozent. Und das ist dann so erheblich. Bei 2,9 Prozent kann man immer noch sagen, naja, gut, so tragisch ist es doch nicht. Und da ist es aber dann tragisch. Und das gilt dann nicht nur für Bürgergeldempfänger, sondern das gilt für sehr große Teile der Bevölkerung, die am Limit sind. Selbst wenn sie einen etwas höheren Lebensstandard haben, heißt größere Wohnung oder sonst was, dann haben sie auch diese Fixkosten einfach mal. Also, ob sie jetzt in 60 Quadratmeter oder 90 Quadratmeter zu zweit wohnen. Die Fixkosten sind dann da und steigen jetzt plötzlich die Kosten so sehr durch Energie und Lebensmittel. Dann können die ja nicht sagen, ach so, dann ziehe ich jetzt einfach mal schnell in die kleinere Wohnung oder um die oder oder oder nehmen das E-Auto. Diese Flexibilität besteht ja einfach nicht. Und das wird von denen nicht begriffen.
Ja, das waren jetzt sehr lange Ausführungen, die sehr richtig waren. Ich kann sie aber noch auf so einen, weil die ja auch immer so Rätseln. Also warum macht Bad Rübe ein Podcast mit Michael Hüther? Weil Wirtschaft so eine komplizierte Sache ist, die man uns klein.
Aber manchmal haben wir doch Spaß mit ihnen sowieso.
Genau. Aber die Losung ist ja immer, wir sind so kleine Summers. Also wir haben so, wir wohnen halt wo und dann gehen wir morgens zur Arbeit. Und dann erklärt uns Biodes Rüro, was so in der Welt los ist. Und die Globalisierung ist kompliziert. Deswegen möchte ich kurz Aufklärung geben. Ich bin natürlich Leier, aber ich bin ja Podcaster. Ich kann zu allem was sagen. Und das mit dem Bürgergeld ist so, also wenn man sich den volkswirtschaftlichen Nutzen des Bürgergeldes anschauen will, dann braucht man eine Stoppuhr und ein Lineal, ein Zollstock und dann misst man einfach die Distanz von der Adresse des Bürgergeldempfängers bis zum nächsten Rewe. Und dann stellt man den Timer auf eine Woche. Und dann weiß man, wenn wir dem jetzt 100 Euro mehr zahlen, dann ist das eine Woche später zu 100 Prozent bei dem Eigner von diesem Rewe-Supermarkt. Das kann man wunderbar politisch budgetieren. Und dann kriegt man das auch ganz wunderbar eingerechnet, was das so bedeutet. Und hier wird immer ein Rätselraten gemacht. Wie viel sparen wir denn jetzt, wenn wir das und das machen? Sind es 30 Milliarden oder nur 68 Millionen? Also man verschätzt sich mal so ums 350-Fache. Man denkt ewig lange darüber nach. Das ist dann schon so ein halbes Jahr, ein Jahr, fünf Jahre. Ach so, jetzt haben wir schon 20 Jahre nicht mehr angepasst. Die Leute sind jetzt schon halb tot so. Das ist alles so merkwürdig. Ist einfach merkwürdig. Also hier muss einfach Obskurität auch mal gelüftet werden. Herr Robin Alexander macht Aufklärungsarbeit, die völlig Nonsens ist. Also das ist wirklich reine Propaganda. Und Bert Rürup, ja, ich finde, er sollte halt diesen Gedankengang mal kurz ausarbeiten. Warum, Herr Rürup, haben Sie jetzt einfach so lapidar gesagt, einfach das Bürgergeld erhöhen? Liegt das etwa daran, dass es so offensichtlich einfach, richtig planbar und einfach vernünftig ist? Und alles andere fürlefanz dagegen. Irgendwelche Luftbuchungen und hier wieder da. Und dann zahlen wir euch nächstes Jahr. Aber das Geld kommt nicht von uns, sondern vom Arbeitgeber. Ihr könnt es dann von der Steuer absetzen. Wenn ihr die rechtzeitig macht, kriegt ihr 2027.000 Euro erstattet.
Sofern eure Arbeitgeber die Möglichkeit haben und auch bindig sind dazu.
Genau, das ist ja die Politik.
Also auch dieses Outsourcen an die Arbeitgeber. Und die sollen das jetzt mal für sich entscheiden.
Dumm alles.
Dann muss ich ja auch sagen, was ist das für eine Wahnsinn.
Man hält es im Kopf nicht aus. Aber hier noch ein Einspruch von Robin Alexander zum Abschluss.
Und dann ist das eingetreten, was wir doch eigentlich, wenn wir ehrlich sind in dieser Koalition, schon öfter beobachtet haben. Wenn erst mal so eine Krisenstimmung ist, wenn sich durchgesetzt hat, wir müssen jetzt was machen, dann hat die SPD eine Menge Ideen. Und die CDU nimmt dann einfach SPD-Ideen. Das ist ja eigentlich schon, als diese Koalition entstanden ist in den legendären Sondierungsverhandlungen, als man plötzlich dann auch mit lauter SPD-Ideen um die Ecke kam. Ja, die CDU hat halt rhetorische Flughöhe. Aber wenn es ans Konkrete geht und gerade wenn es schnell und hektisch wird, dann sagt die SPD, ihr könnt A, B oder C machen und alles ist entweder Schulz oder Habeck.
Also, wenn die SPD SPD-Ideen hätte, dann wäre das ja ein ganz anderes Spiel. Wie kam es denn dazu, dass die SPD nur noch CDU-Ideen hat und die CDU sagt, angesichts der AfD-Bedrohung müssen wir nur noch CDU-AfD-Ideen umsetzen, ist doch, also ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Aber solange die SPD jetzt einfach den CDU-Kurs weitermacht, ist es dann immer eine SPD-Idee. Und dann kann man am Ende vielleicht sagen, und das wird ja der Schlussstrich unter dieser Regierung sein, ja, die CDU hat sich zu sehr der SPD angedehnt.
Das wird am Ende der TNU sein.
Das wird es sein.
Es ist alles wirklich sehr schlimm.
Sollen wir zum Abschluss noch zwei Dinge uns anhören? Und zwar will ich einmal sagen, dass ich mich fürchte, davor, dass die Spaltung in der Gesellschaft aufhören könnte. Wie ist das zu verstehen? Wir hören hier eine Nachrichtensendung, eine US-amerikanische, ich weiß genau, es ist ein Zusammenschnitt aus einem Podcast einer George W. Bush-Tochter. Dort war der Vater zu Gast. Und es geht jetzt in diesem kurzen Beitrag über George W. Bush, der für den heutigen erwähnten Afghanistan-Krieg verantwortlich war, wie auch für den Irakkrieg und seine Freundschaft zu Michelle Obama.
George W. Bush glaubt, dass er weiß, warum seine Freundschaft mit Michelle Obama immer Headlines macht. Der Ex-Präsident saß mit seiner Tochter Jenna Bush Hager für einen heutigen Show vor dem 250. Geburtstag in den USA und erhebte seine Reaktion zu einem viralen 2018-Moment mit der damals ersten Frau. Die Paare waren zusammen bei John McCain's Funeral, als Bush Obama angeboten wurde, was viele an der Zeit als Kaffee oder Kaffeebefall waren.
Sie sind dabei der Beerdigung und sie bekommt dann so einen Swint erreicht von George W. Bush. Das ging viral, dieses Video.
Ich habe eine kleine Antwort, wie du sicher weißt.
Und ich war neben Michelle, das ist die Person, die ich neben den Feiern sitze.
Und das war ein bisschen bewegend und so.
Und ich schlug sie in den Altoid.
Nicht als Witz, aber ich dachte, sie würde mich nicht wollen.
Und ich bin in die Auto gegangen und sie hat gesagt, du bist trendig.
Ich wusste nicht, was Trending bedeutet.
Es war nicht das erste Mal, dass die Leute Bush und der Ex-Flotus sich für einander beeinflussen. Und er hat seine Meinung aufgeschrieben, dass ihre Kommeraderie einfach eine frische Sicht auf dem politischen Spektrum ist.
Und es wird herausgekommen, dass das Land starbt, einen weißen, zentralen, rechten, republikanischen und afrikanischen, zentralen, linken, demokratischen Menschen zu sehen, und Spaß zu haben und zu können, nicht als politische Figuren, sondern als Bürger und Bürgerinnen und Bürger.
Und ich will das weiterhin tun.
Indeed, Obama selbst hat auch auf den öffentlichen Interesse in ihr und Bushs freundliche Beziehung gewartet, vorher heute gesagt, dass er ihr, quote, Partner in der Krim für alle großen Funktionen, die in den letzten Präsidenten und den ersten Damen betreffen, zu sagen, dass er zu dem Zeitpunkt gesagt hat, ich liebe ihn tot, er ist ein wunderschöner Mann, er ist ein lustiger Mann. Die Duos haben auch in 2016 eine berühmte Embrace an einem Museums-Dedikationszeremoni genossen. Wir sind nicht mit der Politik und der Menschheit verabredet, We don't disagree about love and compassion.
Ja, man kann also hunderttausende Tote im Irak-Krieg produzieren, dafür verantwortlich sein. Aber Hauptsache, wir verstehen uns auf einer zwischenmenschlichen Ebene ganz gut. Und da sehe ich genau das ganz große Problem. Wenn dieser Diskurs kommt, Spaltung der Gesellschaft überwinden, dass man genau da hinkommen will. Bitte wieder sowas, nicht so wie Trump, aber so fänden wir es wieder schön. Also heißt es auf Deutschland übertragen, AfD bitte nicht. Aber sonst können wir wirklich jetzt mit allen kuscheln. Und vielleicht können wir bald nicht nur Podcasts zu Tritt machen, sondern noch mit ganz vielen mehr. Egal, wo sie so gerade politisch sind. Das ist ja alles nur Binnendifferenzen in eigentlich einem großen Wir, dass wir unsere stolzen Nationen werden dürfen. Wo findet es schon im Kleinen statt? Und damit wollen wir schließen. Du hast eine Prognose abgegeben vor einigen Monaten und diese ist wahr geworden. Oder ich sage mal, ein Anfang ist gemacht. Ich habe mich ja mal aufgeregt über die Heute Show und darüber, dass Fabian Köster dann jetzt mittlerweile schon bei Instagram diese ganzen Clips mit den Politikern postet und man gar nicht mehr weiß, wer macht jetzt gerade diese Satire und dass man so kungelt damit. Und dann hast du gesagt, ja, es fehlt ja eigentlich nur noch, dass Fabian Köster mit Philipp Amthor ein Tournee macht. Der Anfang, würde ich sagen, ist gemacht. Sie machen keine Tournee, aber sie hatten jetzt ihren ersten gemeinsamen Comedy-Auftritt. Wir hören kurz in dieses Reel ein, das von Philipp Amthor selbst veröffentlicht wurde.
Heute habe ich euch einen echten Alterswitz mitgebracht.
Und zwar mich. Wir beide heute Abend auf einer Bühne zusammen.
Also man sieht jetzt, Amthor hat eingeleitet mit diesem Schwenk dann zu Fabian Köster, so wie das in der Heute-Show immer umgekehrt ist.
Ja, Fabian Köster hat es so oft zum Exzess getrieben, mit guten und mal weniger guten Philipp Amthor-Alterswitzen, wie mit dem Wahlprogramm. Ja, dass ich da heute mal eingreife ins Programm und in deine Berliner Show.
In Ernst Reutersaal, der ist von 1957.
Wie war das bei der Erzählung?
Den ganzen Auftritt kann man Gott sei Dank nicht sehen, aber das ist so Zustand momentan, es ist hier in Deutschland. Wir treten gleich mit den Politikern auf.
Ja, also dafür kurz in drei Minuten auch. Die wird natürlich rausgeschnitten von unserem Automatismen, aber wir haben gerade eine Minute getrauert. Und eine Sache, die mir derzeit wirklich Freude bereitet, weil ich lasse mich ja gerne unterhalten. Und die Frage macht Spaß, finde ich auch wichtig, ist dieses amerikanische Late-Night-Show Zeug. Also heute bei der Daily Show. Ich weiß nicht, wen ich da gerade am besten finde. John Stewart am Montag ist super geil, aber die anderen, die danach die Woche kommen, ist wirklich jedes Mal eine Freude.
Ich habe gar keinen Bezug dazu. Also nur, wenn du mir was schickst, dann kriege ich es schon mal mit.
Jimmy Kimmel gerade und Colbert natürlich auch. Das geht so ans Eingemachte. Also man sieht einfach, so etwas wäre einfach nicht mehr möglich. Dass da irgendwelche Leute, aus wem die kommentieren in der Regierung, mit denen nochmal irgendeine gemeinsame Sache machen. Die treffen sich nur noch vor Gerichten, da kommen diese, mehr der ist eigener von diesen Sendern und dann wird irgendwie ausgefochten und so. Das ist schon, finde ich, eine sehr gute Entwicklung. Da ist richtige Konfrontation.
Besser als diese heile Welt zumindest. Damit schließen wir für den Monat, verweisen darauf, dass wir uns im Salon wiedersehen, für alle, die den Salon nicht kennen. Das ist quasi der zweite Podcast, den man abonnieren kann hinter der Paywall. Da sprechen wir dann nicht anhand von Clips, sondern anhand von Textstellen über wichtige Sachbücher des Monats. Wir sprechen in der Regel über ein oder zwei Bücher gemeinsam ausführlich. Dann gibt es von uns noch sehr viele Tipps zu Büchern und Artikeln, die wir gelesen haben. Dieses Mal steht im Mittelpunkt das Buch Das Knappe Gut Arbeit von Florian Butollo, erschienen bei Suhrkamp. Wir beschäftigen uns also mit der KI aus einer ganz anderen Perspektive. Hier wird gesagt, mit der Automatisierung werden die Menschen nicht in eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit getrieben, sondern es geht eher in die gegenteilige Richtung. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das sein wird. Wir diskutieren darüber. Dann muss ich jetzt nachfragen hier, obwohl wir noch auf Sendung sind, wir hatten es noch nicht geklärt, ist dieses Wörterbuch etwas, was wir uns unbedingt mal ansehen sollten? Was ja in den Bestsellerlisten liegt.
Es liegt auf meinem Schreibtisch. Ich habe es natürlich physisch bestellt.
Ja.
Und ich kann es gerne mitbringen. Das ist ja nicht die Erwartung, dass ich es von vorne nach hinten durchlese.
Soll ich mir auch kaufen? Dann können wir vielleicht darüber doch reden, um zu wissen, wie ticken die denn? Denn ein bisschen wollen wir auch mal über die rechten reden.
Es ist halt ein echtes Wörterbuch, ne?
Es ist ein Wörterbuch.
Dann werden Wörter genannt und dann wird die erklärt.
Das ist links-deutsch, deutsch-links. Das bitte jetzt nicht nachkaufen. Wir kaufen das und reden darüber, aber nicht nachkaufen. Von Nios herausgegeben. Also Julian Reichelt schreibt dort ebenso, Walde Marhatmann, Gloria von Ton und Taxis.
Es ist nicht sehr amüsant. Ich weiß ja, wie es ist, solche kleinen Vorhanden zu machen.
Ja, aber was ich glaube, ist, dass wir doch noch mal so ein gewisses Boomer-Publikum damit sehr gut fassen können. Weil das sind ja Autoren, die sagen wir mal die besten Zeiten eigentlich hinter sich haben, jetzt sich zusammentun, um so ein Buch herauszugeben mit News. Und wir können glaube ich sehr viel dumpfes Denken dort noch mal analysieren. Insofern würde ich sagen, wir sprechen drüber. Also das ist dann das zweite Buch, das wir besprechen. Und alles, was ich sonst mitbringe, das würde ich mir dann noch offen halten. Und du hast schon angekündigt Vatikan.
Der Vatikan, ein großer Text. Außerdem dieses Kybernetik und Kritik sind aber 600 Seiten. Ich werde punktuell, es ist ja eine Gesamtgeschichte. Wir werden schon was Aktuelles hinten raus dann finden. Außerdem gibt es einen Text, die mir mein Cousin Lars empfohlen hat. Ich war ganz überrascht. Also es gibt ja Demografie als Thema immer unverständlich. Plötzlich werden so Themen auf Statistik runtergebrochen, die ich dann wieder zurückhole mit der Kinderwunsch. Repräsentiert irgendwas, der unerfüllte Kinderwunsch auch und so weiter. Und jetzt gibt es einen Text von mehreren Autoren zum Thema 2024 war ein großer, ich kann ja mal wie, ich lese mal vor wie Olivia für mich oder Alcina den Anlass. Die Veröffentlichung einer demografischen Studie auf Basis der UN World Population Prospects 2024. Also wir haben es im Grunde mit einer Standarddatenreihe, die die UN einfach so veröffentlicht zu tun. Die Forscher identifizieren das Jahr 2024 als den historischen Wendepunkt, ab dem die globale Geburtenrate von Frauen erstmals die der Männer übersteigt. Jetzt können wir uns alle eine Woche lang überlegen, was, was bedeutet das? Denn für ein Kind braucht man doch ein Mann und eine Frau, wie kann es da zu Disbalancen kommen und so weiter. Und wir haben aber zum einen materielle Phänomene, wie nach dem Krieg gibt es einfach weniger Männer und die Frauen kriegen aber trotzdem alle Kinder. Also hat man es da mit einer Disbalance zu tun. Dann allerdings kommt so Lebenserwartung rein, es gleicht sich aus und plötzlich schifft das so in andere Richtungen. Was bedeutet, sehr viele Männer kommen heute nicht mehr zum Zuge. Und das ist eine historisch einmalige Situation.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Wir haben diese chinesischen Zahlen, da kennen wir es ja, Frauen abgetrieben und so. Und wir haben es also mit, das ist ja mir sehr sympathisch, ganz konkreten Mennosphere, neue Gewalt, Rechtsdruck in der, also alles so Männer getrieben. Und wir versuchen das immer so inhaltlich. Kann man mit den Männern nochmal reden oder so. Aber vielleicht gibt es auch einfach Dämmer und Demografie, stille Grundlagen, die einfach schlussduräter zu führen. Genau, dass das wirklich begünstigt wird. Ja und natürlich Vatikan.
Wunderbar, das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon abonniert. Am besten auf neuezwanziger.de. Dann kommt man zum Salon. Also der ist abonnierbar über Patreon, Steady oder Apple. Ganz einfach. Dann hat man auch Zugang zu allen bereits erschienen Salons. Das geht also Jahre zurück. Und wir freuen uns sehr über die Unterstützung und weisen an dieser Stelle nochmal darauf hin, dass wir live zu erleben sind in Frankfurt im August beim Live-Salon am 22. Da gibt es auch schon Tickets. Auch da findet man den Link natürlich in der Beschreibung und bzw. auf der Homepage. Jetzt erst mal einen guten Monat.